Droht diesen Podcast der nächste Shitstorm? Wolfgang mit ohne Tempolimit auf der Autobahn und jetzt auch noch mit ohne Zigaretten?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, das ist alles möglich, denn es gibt ja diesen Satz von Jean Moreau, einer französischen Schauspielerin. Ein Mann, der das Rauchen aufgibt, wird bald auch die Liebe aufgeben. Ich hoffe, soweit kommt es nicht, aber ich habe mir gedacht, ich habe es vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr ritualisiert. Denn es ist ja so, dass ich sehr wenig rauche. Zwei bis drei Zigaretten am Tag und immer nach 22 Uhr. Und dann dachte ich mir...
Also sitzt nicht in der Oper.
Nein. Warum mache ich das eigentlich so ritualisiert? Das ist ja auch eine Art der Abhängigkeit zumindest, die eine rituelle Abhängigkeit ist, keine Nikotinabhängigkeit. Und dann habe ich mir das jetzt mal untersagt für einige Tage. Und es geht auch so, wenn man aus dem Ritual ausbricht und es ist ja doch so, ich will jetzt hier nicht den Gesundheitsapostel spielen, weil diese Rolle überhaupt nicht gut steht. Aber es ist ja doch so, dass auch wenige Zigaretten regelmäßig sehr schädlich sind. Und es ist nicht so, dass man sagen kann, 20 Zigaretten sind zehnmal so schlimm wie zwei Zigaretten am Tag. Das ist tatsächlich nicht das, was die Studienlage hergibt. Und da ich Jahrhundert werden will, wie du weißt, und wir dann immer noch diese Podcast machen, muss ich ja fit bleiben. Ja, du rauchst ja nicht. Du vapest hin und wieder. Das sehe ich mit großer Sorge.
Aber ich vape ja auch nur in meiner Lieblingsbar.
Okay, du meintest jetzt, ich soll nur noch in meiner Lieblingsbar rauchen.
Ja, Alkohol und Zigarettenkonsum war bei mir strikt limitiert auf Ort. Und damit auch relativ viel auf Zeit. Nun hat aber allerdings unser Lieblingsbarkeeper, ist nicht mehr. Es wird sich also einiges in den Mustern verändern. Mal gucken, womit ich dann nächsten Monat komme.
Und ich muss dann aufpassen, dass ich das Rauchen jetzt nicht mit Champagner kompensiere.
Ja, da musst du aufpassen, weil teurer. Obwohl Zigaretten sind auch teurer.
Ja, und auch vielleicht nicht so wahnsinnig gesund.
Das heißt, neue Muster in der Welt könnte ja sehr prägend sein für dieses ganze Gespräch, was wir heute über die Welt führen.
Ich denke ja.
Lass mich aber noch zu deinem Muster kurz fragen, wann kommt das Gemüse auf den Teller?
Ja, also wir wollen es jetzt nicht übertreiben.
Wann setzt du dich mal auf ein Fahrrad?
Ich will ja nicht 110 werden.
Ich habe dich in der Speak Easy Bar gehört, wie du gesagt hast, in deinem Leben möchtest du nicht mehr auf einem Fahrrad sitzen.
Ja, dabei bleibt es auch. Ich gehe gern mal zu Fuß, aber Fahrrad ist für mich absolutes No-Go. Ich finde es nicht bequem. Und auch nicht mit dem Anzug da rauf und so. Das geht alles nicht.
Man kann extra die Hose verstärken. Dann hast du da so Patches drin.
Ist das angenehm, so eine verstärkte Hose? Fühlt sich das an wie eine Pampers oder was? Nein. Du merkst, ich lasse mich da auf nichts ein. Du kannst mit den besten Argumenten kommen. Es ist völlig zwecklos. Gib mir eine Minute, um Werbung zu machen für mein neues Buch. Und zwar habe ich mit Ann-Christin Klusthi zusammen eine Anthologie veröffentlicht, die heißt Selbstschuld. Und da sind auch Texte, die dich interessieren können. Es geht nämlich zum Beispiel auch um Familie. Es geht um Generationen, dass das völliger Unsinn ist.
Sag mal kurz, wer den ersten Text geschrieben hat und wie du den findest und was wir von der Person überaus gerade jetzt im Oktober, im September halten.
Ja, das ist ein Glücksfall. Und zwar, den ersten Texten dieser Anthologie hat Sarali Heinrich geschrieben.
Eine Grüne?
Ja, nicht mehr. Das ist nämlich eine der Rebellinnen, die sagt, nicht mehr mit uns, wir wollen etwas Neues anfangen. Wir werden sie nachher auch nochmal in einem Clip kurz hören. Und sie hat über ihre persönliche Aufstiegsgeschichte gesprochen. Sie ist in Armut aufgewachsen. Und ich bin so begeistert von diesem Text deshalb vor allem, weil ich eher skeptisch war, eine Politikerin zu fragen, etwas zu schreiben, ist immer schon so eine Sache. Dann dachte ich mir, bekomme ich jetzt nochmal Fakten serviert, die ich schon kenne? Nein, ich bekomme einen Text, der literarisch sogar wertvoll ist. Und das ist für mich also die ganz große Überraschung. Aber die anderen Texte sind natürlich auch...
Also ich sage eine wahre Grüne.
Eine wahre Grüne, darüber wird jetzt gleich zu reden sein. Und vielleicht so als Einstieg will ich Roger Wilhelmsen zitieren, den ich in meinem Essay, ich habe über Wehrpflicht, was müssen wir eigentlich dem Staat schuldig sein und all das geschrieben, und habe dort ein Roger Wilhelmsen Zitat gefunden von 1991. Und da beschäftigte er sich mit der Bildzeitung. Und da ging es darum, wie die Bildzeitung Ronald Reckons Angriff auf Libyen dargestellt hat oder auch den sogenannten Falklandkrieg von Setscher. Und wie auch alle dann eigentlich diese Bildberichterstattung übernommen haben, also alle seriösen Medien sich auch dahinter versammelt haben. Und dann schreibt Roger Wilhelmsen, die Bildzeitung ist das repräsentative Organ der Deutschen. Alles andere ist Übersetzung ins Bildungsbürgerdeutsch oder Kosmetik. Noch in jedem Fall von nationaler Hochbedeutung, Kriege, Krisen, Terroristen, Wiedervereinigung etc. haben sich die größten Volksgruppen, inklusive der intellektuellen, ideologisch hinter dem Rembrandt-deutschen Hassblatt versammelt. Es ist sehr erhellend zu sehen, wenn wir daran denken, 2015 sagt Merkel, wir schaffen das, lässt sehr viele Flüchtlinge zu uns kommen. Und die BILD-Zeitung schreibt, ja, wir schaffen das, macht eine große Kampagne, dass das genau der richtige Schritt jetzt ist. Jetzt ist die BILD-Zeitung auf einem gänzlich anderen Kurs, schreibt uns jeden Tag noch mal auf, wie gefährlich Migranten sind und und und und dass jetzt endlich die Ampel durchgreifen soll. Und jetzt muss eigentlich März ran. Und damit ändert sich nicht nur die Stimmung im Land, also bei den einfachen Lesern, sage ich, sondern generell die Medien gehen ganz auf dieses neue Projekt der BILD-Zeitung und sind da im großen Einklang unterwegs und das ist beängstigend.
Ja, die, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie sie hieß, das war ja noch zu Kai Diekmanns Zeiten. Willkommen, nee, die hatten ja so eine Art, die konnte man sich sogar als Aufstecker aufklebern.
Die hatten Aufkleber, Willkommenskultur-Aufkleber und mit dem Fußball zusammen kooperierten, das waren viele Aktionen, ein ganzes Jahr.
Also das war eine Parenthese, das Wort der zweiseitigen Zäsur, die sich historisch einschleicht Anfang und Ende und sticht immer heraus als irgendwie komisch. Also in deren Sicht große historische Konsistenz. Ich weiß nicht, Williamson ist ja eine Weile tot, das ist wahrscheinlich schon ein 15 Jahre, 91, also 34 Jahre, 33 Jahre.
Ja.
Sehr gut. So du willst über die Grünen gleich am Anfang reden, weil du...
Du willst doch auch über die Grünen reden.
Ja, aber nicht gleich am Anfang. Ich würde lieber, also wie du magst.
Hat dir das keine Freude bereitet?
Doch. Wir können ja, also das grüne Ergebnis, was wir jetzt noch nicht haben, denn die Aufstellungen laufen und so, wir haben aber ein österreichisches Ergebnis. Ja. Und ich will noch mal dran erinnern und so, glaube ich, wir machen es jetzt im großen Bogen. Es gab mal eine Zeit, als es hieß, wenn Merkel erst mal weg ist, ist die AfD entzaubert, weil die sagen ja immer, Merkel muss weg. Und wenn Merkel dann weg ist, können sie das nicht mehr sagen, also läuft die Partei leer. Dann kam die Ampel und heute kann man sich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern oder sich es nur vorstellen, dass sie tatsächlich mal jemand anderen abgehatet haben, so wie die Ampel gerade abgehatet wird. Und das nächste große Projekt, das jetzt ansteht, ist Schwarz-Grün mit so verschiedenen Dingern, wie ich habe nichts gegen die Grünen und die Grünen sind dann gemeint, etwas jüngere, etwas korpulentere Frauen oder so was, die Friedrich Merz nicht gefallen. Also eine klare, wenn auch latent, also nicht sehr direkt ausgesprochene, aber eine klare Zuschreibung bei Söder ja auch. Nicht mit diesen. Die Grünen von mir aus irgendwie und so. Und dann lässt man sich von Daniel Günther erklären, dass die Grünen ja auch, wenn sie namenlos bleiben, ganz okay sind. So, das nächste Projekt ist also Schwarz-Grün. Das heißt, auf Merkel folgt eine Ampel und darauf folgt Schwarz-Grün. Und für die AfD ist das immer der gleiche Katalysator. Also die AfD wird das ganz wunderbar verstehen. Black Rock-Kanzler Merz und wen auch immer Habeck den Grünen abzuschießen. So, und wir haben jetzt in Österreich eine Wahl gehabt, bei der eine schwarz-grüne Regierung regierte und insgesamt 17 Prozent verliert, von einer Wahlperiode auf die nächste. Und die FPÖ auf Platz 1 in der Fraktionsstärke springt. Das sollten wir alles einpreisen. Wir hören nachher noch von der Zeit. Die machen ja einen Transalpien-Podcast, Stimmen, wie man so auf Kickel schaut. Und die Idee, ja, die werden sich schon entzaubern oder was auch immer und so. Wird einfach nur gelacht. Kleiner Teaser. Also da verorten wir uns jetzt gerade.
Ja.
Also wir gehen ja so weit über diese Neuen Zwanziger hinaus. Wir gucken uns jetzt.
Deutschland ist kein Sonderfall, sehen wir da.
Nee, Deutschland ist kein Sonderfall und Österreich ist uns voraus. Also vor 24 Jahren, als Haider dort in die Regierung kam, gab es noch Sanktionen von der Europäischen Kommission. So, was hier gerade passiert, ist in einer Langfristigkeit und in einer Triftigkeit klar und deutlich, dass man einfach nur sagen kann, also wir beide sehen sehr arisch aus, wir stehen quasi ein bisschen neben dem Problem. Weiß, männlich, urban und rot.
Ich glaube, dass man daran sehr gut sehen kann jetzt an dieser Entwicklung, dass die Grünen ja, obwohl sie die ganze Zeit von den Konservativen, also von der CDU gesagt bekommen, wie schlimm sie sind, fast unter so einem Stockholm-Syndrom leiden, dass sie aber unbedingt mit denen eigentlich koalieren wollen. Besser heute als morgen. Das ist ja das Erstaunliche. Wir werden das jetzt gleich ein paar Mal sehen, dass es diese Opposition, die von der Union da aufgemacht wird, eigentlich gar nicht gibt. Und es gab ja einen sehr guten Essay von Robert Pausch in der Zeit zu Habeck. Und er sagt da, tatsächlich haben sich die Grünen in nahezu jedem Politikfeld weit in Richtung Union bewegt. Sie bauten LNG-Terminals und diesen Kohlekraftwerke länger laufen. Sie stimmten 149 Autobahnprojekten ebenso zu wie eine Entkernung des Klimaschutzgesetzes. In der Agrarpolitik wollen sie längst keine weitreichenden Reformen mehr, die sie 2021 noch versprochen hatten. In der Verkehrspolitik sind Steuererleichterungen für e-SUVs heute die höchste aller Grünen Ambitionen. Und in der Migrationspolitik vertreten die Grünen mittlerweile eine Politik, die rechts von dem steht, was Horst Seehofer einst als Innenminister durchsetzen konnte. Sich das vergegenwärtigen, schreibt dann Pausch. Man kann derzeit dabei zusehen, wie der Habeckismus von einer Strategie zur Ideologie wird. Und was ist das Kennzeichen einer Ideologie? Sie kann nicht falsch sein. Wenn die Medizin nicht mehr wirkt, muss man nicht die Rezeptur verändern. Man muss die Dosis erhöhen. Die anderen hassen uns. Dann müssen wir ihnen zeigen, dass es dafür keinen Grund gibt. Und das erleben wir jetzt gerade. Und das ist sehr besorgniserregend, wie das immer weiter läuft. Also, dass es eigentlich jetzt für die schon ausgemacht zu sein scheint, dass Schwarz-Grün das allerbeste wäre. Und ich verstehe diese Machtbesessenheit da gar nicht. Da hat man ja fast Respekt vor der FDP, die sich lieber in den Untergang hineinrennt, als mit irgendwelchen Leuten zu paktieren. Ich kann es nicht begreifen, dass man Wert darauf legt, mit einer Merzunion zu paktieren.
Ich habe mal Claude nach diesem Text gefragt, was ist Hapikismus? Diet wollte das auf Twitter wissen. Claude macht es ganz interessant, weil da wird ja einfach nüchtern rausgezogen. Aber Diet war dann auch beeindruckt, dass der Vibe so bleibt. Und so können wir hier zusammenfassen. Hapikismus ist Pragmatismus und Kompromissbereitschaft hineinzubringen. Ein postideologischen Ansatz, von dem wir immer wissen, so postideologisch ist das dann nie, wenn es behauptet wird. Ein hohes Maß von Bündnisfähigkeit und Flexibilität, während man allerdings Selbstkritik und Fehleingeständnisse zulässt. Was ja nur bedeutet, kein Wunder, dass dann jemand wie Söder oder Merz daneben steht und sagt, naja klar, kriegen wir den zertrümmert und weichgespült. Während ich jetzt darauf hinweise, wenn wir jetzt ein bisschen langfristiger denken, also die Merz nicht zu verhinderte Blackrock Bundeskanzlerdominanz jetzt schon mal eingepreist, ein bisschen über die Zeitläufte hinaus, dass wir dann feststellen, vielleicht ist dieser Erfolg der AfD einfach nur dadurch zu erklären, dass sie immer nur Opposition macht. Und vielleicht ist es mit diesem berühmten Spruch, nur Nixon konnte nach China gehen. Vielleicht ist es viel besser für alle, wenn die Grünen einfach diesen Hapkissmus hinter sich lassen, groß scheitern und daneben aber eine wirklich rebellierende Jugend daneben steht, die nicht einfach nur ihre eigenen Ideen aufwirft, sondern auch noch gleichzeitig behauptet, egal ob es stimmt oder nicht, alle sind auf unserer Seite. Seht ihr die jungen Leute, wie sie euch die Leistung verweigern, wie sie in euren Arbeitsstellen einfach sagen, wir haben keinen Bock, das sind unsere Jugendliche. Also einfach behaupten, das sind unsere Jugendliche. So wie die AfD kommt und sagt, seht ihr das? Alle Ostdeutschen wollen keine Migranten. Und dann preist man die einfach ein und alle glauben denen das. Und dann kommt immer Steffen Maurer und schreibt so Bücher und sagt, die sind eigentlich gar nicht so gespalten. Und eigentlich ist alles, sobald man mit den Leuten redet, fällt das alles in sich zusammen. Und ich finde, man sollte jetzt von dieser jungen grünen Seite aus, wir gehen ja gleich ins Detail, im Großen und Ganzen sagen, wir sind die neuen Grünen, wir sind die wahren Grünen und wir haben alle auf unserer Seite.
Und das fällt auch gar nicht schwer. Unglaublich lang und breit hat Jörg Öztemir in der FAZ noch mal aufgeschrieben, wie er die Migrationspolitik sieht. Man kann es zusammenfassen mit die Verwertbaren ins Töpfchen, alle anderen ins Kröpfchen. Und da gibt es eine Passage in dem Text. Da heißt es, wer Ideologie in ihren tödlichen Zuspitzungen wirksam und an der Wurze bekämpfen will. Und ich nenne Rechtsextremismus, Islamismus und Antisemitismus ganz bewusst in einer Reihe, muss den Sozialstaat neu aufstellen. Man ist verdutzt. Was meint er? Weniger Transferleistungen, mehr gezielte Leistungsanreize und starke öffentliche Institutionen. Übersetzt heißt das also, man kann Hass dadurch bekämpfen, dass man Leuten noch weniger gibt, als sie jetzt schon bekommen. Gezielte Leistungsanreize heißt ja neue Sanktionsmaßnahmen auf den Weg bringen, starke öffentliche Institutionen, meint vermutlich vor allem Polizei. Also das heißt, wir haben es hier mit einer sozialen Kahlschlagpolitik zu tun. Da braucht ja nur noch Friedrich Merz ein Häckchen drunter setzen, und sagen ja genau, wir machen was.
Das ist Cem Özdemir's Hapäkismus. Auf die Kräfteverhältnisse in Baden-Württemberg gemünzt. Dort kann man ja durchaus Ministerpräsident Grün werden mit einer CDU als kleinen Partner. Das ist ja da sein Jahr in Gang und gäbe. Aber es ist wieder dieses falsch verstandene Pragmatismus und Kompromissbereitschaft zeigen, einen postideologischen Ansatz, also auch mal über die Gräben springen, große Bündnisfähigkeit zeigen und sich beim Thema Selbstkritik wieder sozusagen am Schlawitchen packen und durch die Manege schleifen zu lassen.
Aber immer nur von rechts. Also es würde ja jetzt niemals ein Artikel von Cem Özdemir sein, in dem er sagt, ja, das war ein großes Problem, dass wir das mit den Superreichen nicht angegangen sind, dass wir kein Bürgergeld erhöht haben. Das kommt ja ja nicht. Es ist ja immer die Kritik von rechts wird aufgegriffen und dann sagt man, ach so, ja, ich verstehe. Dann machen wir das genauso.
Ja, ich will noch eine Kritik von links mal formulieren. In diesem Text geht es ganz viel um seine Tochter. Und das geht nicht. Also dieses fairen Trennung.
Seine Tochter soll sich sicher fühlen, so argumentiert er da.
Dieses fairen Trennung muss immer beibehalten werden. Bundesliga Politik ist einfach nur Abstraktion politischer Themen, die sich irgendwie mobilisieren lassen. Und am Ende ist nicht die Frage, welchen von diesen 30 Joghurts nehme ich und falls mir keiner gefällt, mische ich die noch, sondern nein, man hat fünf Alternativen bei einer Wahl. So, das hat mit der eigenen Lebenswelt, also der medial unvermittelten Familie und also Family & Friends sozusagen nichts zu tun. Und man kann dann keine, wie soll man sagen, Übersetzungsleistung sich selbst abverlangen, weil die Rechten ja auch immer mit dem Schutz der Kinder argumentieren oder so was. Also das ist ja.
Ja, das ist, hier kann man es mal sagen, schlimmster Populismus.
Ja, das ist Kindesunterspruch. Das sehen wir nachher noch in einem anderen Fall. Denn beim Thema Thüringen hat ja die NZZ einen Text darüber geschrieben, mit der großen Frage, warum gibt man sich denn nicht dem Wahlergebnis geschlagen? Die CDU könnte doch bequem mit der AfD regieren. Und diese Autoren, deren Text ja auch noch vollständig in der Stellungnahme der AfD auftaucht, für das Verfassungsgericht, twittert dann die Autorin, ich sitze hier gerade mit meiner Tochter am Tisch, Thema Erfurt. Sie sagt, ich bin nicht auf deiner Seite. Sie, die Mutter, sagt, ja, kein Problem. Und ich möchte auch, dass du deine Meinung äußern kannst. Und dann sagt die Tochter, ja, ich will aber nicht, dass du deine Meinung so äußern darfst. Und das fasst dann die Sachlage gut zusammen. Also die Kinder da so reinzubringen, um irgendwie so eine Gefühlslage zu mobilisieren bei den Rezipienten, das ist wirklich unterste Schublade. Und, ich will es ausdrücklich sagen, disqualifiziert. Ja, Cem Özdemir ist jetzt disqualifiziert. Wir leben nicht in Baden-Württemberg.
Wir hören jetzt gleich noch, wer sich so langsam wieder qualifiziert, aber das kommt erst später. Erst mal gab es ja, bevor es die Abspaltung der Grünen Jugend gab, beziehungsweise des Vorstands der Grünen Jugend und der Landesvorstände, die sich angeschlossen haben, den Fall, dass Nouripour und Ricarda Lang zurückgetreten sind. Und Habeck ist am Abend im Heute-Journal zu Gast und wird von Christian Sievers gefragt, warum denn jetzt eigentlich?
Der heutige Tag war ein aufwühlender Tag und er zeigt noch einmal, wie gnadenlos und manchmal unbarmherzig das politische Geschäft ist. Gut, das wissen alle, die da reingehen. Trotzdem fühlt er einen noch einmal vor Augen.
Wenn wir uns das jetzt schon mal vergegenwärtigen. Er ist ja derjenige, der das angestoßen hat, dass die zurücktreten. Und er spricht aber jetzt vom politischen Geschäft, das jetzt diese zwei zerrieben hat. Aber er ist ja der Akteur in dem Ganzen.
Nee, da gibt es ja keinen Akteur. Das ist wie im Krieg. Menschen sterben.
Ja.
Das wird nicht erklärt. Und hier das Geschäft, also das spitzenpolitische Geschäft, machen die Leute unter sich aus, die mediale Präsenz haben.
Da das Fernsehen denkt, wir sind alle doof, sind das nur fünf Leute. So, diese fünf Leute bestimmen. Das ist wie bei Die Märkte. Wer sind die Märkte? Na, 100 Leute, die halt in Frankfurt, Paris und London sitzen. So, wenn er jetzt sagt, ein Passivsatz draus macht, ja. No. Das geht einfach gar nicht.
Wir hören weiter.
Mit welcher Härte hier manchmal agiert wird.
Und Ricarda, also es ist seine Härte, die agiert hat, nicht die Härte agiert.
Lang und Omid Nouripour haben heute etwas ganz, ganz Seltenes gemacht. Sie haben schnell und große Verantwortung übernommen und damit der Partei in einer schwierigen Lage, das darf man ruhig sagen, eine Chance gegeben, eine Chance geschenkt, möchte ich sagen.
Sie mussten gehen. Ja.
Nein, sie haben eine Chance geschenkt.
Das ist...
Es wird ihn auch nicht vergessen werden. Oh, Christian Sievers hat ihm gerade so einen Satz unterbrochen. Dann sage ich später nochmal, es wird ihn nicht vergessen werden.
Ja, das ist, wenn ich dich im Auto mitnehme und dann irgendwo in der Raststätte rauslasse.
Ja, das ist die härtze der Autobahn.
Ja, der härtze der Autobahn. Und ich habe aber auch eine Chance geschenkt bekommen, dass ich jetzt mal gucken muss, wie ich nach Hause komme.
Zehntausend Schritte am Tag. Die Losung der WHO.
Jetzt nochmal einen Neustart hinzulegen.
Was genau war denn der Fehler der beiden?
Die beiden haben stark für den Zusammenhalt in der Ampel gearbeitet. Und alle Kollegen haben das heute bestätigt, was das für verlässliche Menschen waren. Ich persönlich habe ungeheuer von beiden profitiert, die in einem engen Vertrauensverhältnis immer wieder geholfen haben, Mehrheiten herzustellen, schwierige Entscheidungen durchzusetzen. Und insofern haben sie eine Verantwortung übernommen, die ganz viele andere und vor allem ich auch trage. Ja, Herr Habegger, entschuldigung.
Das klingt jetzt so, als sollen sie die perfekten Parteivorsitzenden. Aber jetzt sind die ja heute gerade zurückgetreten.
Deswegen war die Frage, was sind denn die Fehler?
Welche Fehler haben die beiden denn gemacht, aus Ihrer Sicht?
Weil sie heute zurückgetreten sind, zeigt das noch einmal, was für gute Parteivorsitzende sie waren.
Ja, sorry, aber...
Weil sie zurückgetreten sind, waren sie gute Parteivorsitzende. Und nur ist man guter Parteivorsitzer, wenn man auch zurücktreten will.
Ich höre die Worte und verstehe auch, das ist deutsch Sprache, aber es ergibt keinen Sinn.
Ja, es ist ein Machtspiel, das dort aufgeführt wird. Und da gibt es Verlierer und Gewinner.
Dafür gehen wir eigentlich in die Oper. Im politischen Fernsehen wollen wir das nicht sehen. Das ist irgendwie nicht gut. Robert ist nicht gut.
Nee, das ist im höchsten Maße eigentlich eine Veralberung des Fernsehpublikums, wenn man sich das da gerade anfühlt.
Der Hapetismus gefällt mir nicht.
Nee.
Ich bin kein Fan.
Wir kommen gleich auf die jungen Grünen zu sprechen. Mir ist etwas anderes aufgefallen. Und zwar gibt es so eine Argumentationsweise jetzt bei den Grünen, dass immer der Kreml schuld ist. Und das ist meines Erachtens ein bisschen, sagen wir, unscharf. Also wir hören jetzt hier Kathrin Göring-Eckardt, die ist beim Deutschlandfunk telefonisch zugeschaltet.
Sowohl die Einflussnahme des Kreml, der ja inzwischen ist, das von ihren Kollegen recherchiert worden, sehr deutlich gesagt hat, Deutschland ist eine leichte Beute. Da ging es immer darum, die Grünen zu diffamieren. Da haben andere Parteien, auch demokratische Parteien mitgemacht, die Grünen zum Hauptgegner erklärt und stellen dann jetzt plötzlich fest, das ist ein bisschen ein Problem, weil am Schluss ist man auf das BSW, eine kremlfreundliche Partei zurückgeworfen. Und das muss man vor der Klammer, glaube ich, sagen.
Das ist eine eigenartige Argumentation. Deshalb, weil ich natürlich weiß und glaube, dass der Kreml in den Grünen einen Feind sieht und gern alles tun würde, um die Grünen zu verhindern. Nur das, was jetzt hier in Deutschland stattfindet, die Angriffe von BSW oder Union auf die Grünen, ist hausgemacht. Die fragen nicht vorher beim Kreml nach, die bekommen auch nicht eine halbe Million überwiesen, um das zu machen. Die sind so, die wollen das so machen. Also man muss nicht immer glauben, dass der alles feindliche Böse kommt von außen. Und hier drin sind wir leider so Opfer geworden von Kreml-Propaganda. Die gibt es natürlich im Internet und da gibt es Fake News und was weiß ich alles. Aber das, was da auf der politischen Bühne passiert, ist ja nicht gesteuert vom Kreml, sondern die können da ja auch selbst der Auffassung sein, dass die Grünen als die Schlimmsten ansehen oder sonst was. Dafür brauche ich ja den Kreml gar nicht für.
Ich frage mich auch, also Robert Halbeck hat ja Freunde wahrscheinlich, die ihm dann sagen, Robert ist mit dem Heizungsgesetz, sorry, also mein Beileid irgendwie, du musst jetzt kämpfen. Und ein Jahr später bekämpft er seine Parteiführung. Er ist irgendwo falsch abgebogen. Also klar muss man jetzt gegen den Kreml kämpfen, was auch immer. Ich finde, das ist dann mehr so ein Defizit auf journalistischer Seite, denn wenn der Kreml eine Medienarbeit macht, dann sollten wir doch eine Medienarbeit dagegen setzen. Also warum ist das jetzt auch noch Aufgabe der Parteien, irgendwie da Einhalt zu gebieten? Aber hier ist doch, also klar, die rufen jetzt den BSW aus und so. Und ja, der BSW, das ist ja wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, dass wir eigentlich, und das erkennt man ja schon in der Namensgebung. Wir haben verschiedene Fernsehsendungen, die sich mit Politik befassen. Die heißen dann Anne Will, Sandra Maischberger, Maybrit Illner. Und dann haben wir jetzt eine politische Partei, die heißt Sarah Wagenknecht, also eigentlich ein Medienbetrieb. Da liegt also eine Verwechslung, deswegen okay zugestanden. Sie kämpft jetzt gegen den BSW, aber ich finde, hier sollte der Journalismus mal ein bisschen, also man kann wirklich nicht Sarah Wagenknecht in 100 Talkshows einladen und dann den Grünen vorwerfen, dass sie sich nicht dagegen wehren konnten. Das ist absurd, aber gut, da sind die Grünen wirklich Opfer geworden. Nur wenn sie sagen, wir kämpfen gegen einen Medienbetrieb im Kreml, der uns den BSW beschert hat. Nee, der politische Kampf ist eigentlich leicht zu identifizieren. Also wer greift denn die Grünen die ganze Zeit an? Eine BSW, die überhaupt erst gegründet wurde und jetzt im Osten durch Sarah Wagenknecht ist da bekannt und beliebt. Keine Ahnung, so aus den 80 Leuten, die man hat, dann irgendwie Parlamentarier und jeder fragt sich, wer sind denn die? Oder ist es nicht doch eher so Markus Söder, der seit Jahren auf der Bühne steht und den Grünen fällt nichts dazu ein?
Da kommt gleich noch eine schöne Äußerung zu von Hofreiter, auch das sehr verquer. Wir hören noch mal, Göring-Eckardt war dann zu Gast im Wahlkreis Ostpodcast beim MDR.
Was Sarah Wagenknecht macht, also dieses Schlechtreden des Landes und ihr Ziel ist ja auch nicht, dass in Sachsen oder Thüringen eine stabile Regierung entsteht, sondern ihr Ziel ist ja, dass sie in den Bundestag wieder einzieht und dann eine Plattform hat für das, was sie tut. Und dass sie Verantwortung übernehmen will, ist ja nicht so. Sie geht dahin und geht dann auch gleich wieder weg. Und als treue Botschafterin russischer Interessen, kann man sagen, versucht sie, die Außenpolitik Deutschlands von Thüringen oder Sachsen aus zu beeinflussen.
Wagenknecht wird jetzt hier als Botschafterin des Kremls bezeichnet. Gut, das kann man als Politikerin machen, dass man sich so tituliert. Nur wird ja damit etwas verdeckt. Göring-Eckardt wie Wagenknecht vertreten die Interessen Deutschlands, nationalen Interessen. Nur sehen sie ihre Aufgaben woanders. Während jetzt Göring-Eckardt sagt, im Interesse Deutschlands ist es, eng mit den NATO-Partnern zusammenzuarbeiten, sagt Wagenknecht, im Interesse Deutschlands ist es, einen Frieden herzustellen und wieder russisches Gras herzuholen. Das sind ja beides nationale Blickweisen, nur dann unterschiedliche Interpretationen dessen, was tatsächlich Deutschland oder dem deutschen Volk am meisten dient. So muss man es doch angehen und dann kann man doch sich fragen, ist das, was Wagenknecht davor schlägt, sinnvoll? Hilft das tatsächlich weiter? Aber wenn man sagt, sie ist Botschafterin des Kremels, dann tut man so, als sei sie eigentlich vom Kreml finanziert oder der Kreml würde sein Interesse näher durchsetzen, sondern es sind verschiedene Auffassungen. Und dann vor allen Dingen schlägt das Ganze ja zurück. Also du kannst da ja ganz leicht die Argumentation draus machen. Catherine Göring-Eckardt ist die Botschafterin Washingtons. So, da kann ich dann auch sagen, ah ja, okay, da fließen ja tatsächlich gibt es ja so verschiedene Thinktanks und alles. Da kann ich ja viel stärker noch nachweisen, ah ja, da sind ja schon Gelder geflossen, sie besuchen die auch da und da sind auch schon welche rübergekommen. Ah ja, dann ist das wohl die Botschaft. Nein, das ist eine Politik, die sagt, das deutsche Interesse ist eine NATO-Partnerschaft, die stark ist und in enger Verbindung mit den USA. Und das ist ja völlig in Ordnung, das sozusagen. Und dann kann man sagen, ja, und die Wagenrechtsposition ist eine, die sagt, nein, Europa muss mehr eigenständig sein, Deutschland nochmal in ganz besonderer Weise. Und da gehört Russland und China genauso dazu. Und da macht das keinen Unterschied, ob die autokratisch sind oder nicht. Und das sei aber im Interesse der deutschen Autoindustrie und generell des deutschen Kapitals. Es sind nationale Blickweisen, die sich unterscheiden. Aber sich gegenseitig jetzt vorzuwerfen, man sei eigentlich so aus dem Ausland getrieben oder finanziert. Hilf doch nicht.
Ich finde das sowieso wahnsinnig interessant, wie man auf der einen Seite Sarah Wagenknecht, also du hast jetzt beide beschrieben, als die kämpfen auf nationaler Ebene über geopolitische Themen oder so, was man ja auch im Wahlkampf gesehen hat. Nur die ganze Wirkmacht und Traktion von Sarah Wagenknecht kommt ja durch den sehr gut gewählten Zeitpunkt der Parteigründung, alle überrumpeln in den Hoch. Das ist ja auch interessant in Amerika. Kann man die Kandidatin jetzt noch austauschen? Und dann stellt man fest, ja, kann man. Und man hat dann auch einen Hoch. Und dann sind es aber noch zwei Monate bis zur Wahl. Man dachte, man hat zu wenig Zeit. Dabei ist viel zu viel Zeit bis zur Wahl. Es trocknet schon wieder alles aus. Naja, und Sarah Wagenknecht macht es halt clever. Die gründet halt wirklich kurz vor knapp diese Partei und sagt dann in Thüringen, wir treten dort an mit, wer haben wir denn so, ach wir werben einfach mal so eine Bürgermeisterin einer Stadt, die jeder kennt, weil Wartburg und Luther und so ab. Das ist strategisch einfach klug und hat vor allem mit diesem, lass mir mal die große geopolitische, was auch immer mir da angedichtet, oder was ich selber sage, du machst hier Thüringen Wahlkampf. Also am Ende, während also alle so dastehen und sagen, was weiß ich, ich habe jetzt so im Ohr, weiß nicht mehr genau, wer hier heißt, da einer und Robin Alexander treffen sich natürlich in New York, um Brandenburg nachzubesprechen.
Natürlich.
Und die erste Frage ist schon die bundespolitische Bedeutung. Und nach zehn Minuten hat man keine Zeit mehr, weil New York Termine rufen und so. Also die stehen dann immer so von außen da und denken jetzt, nee, also die Ostdeutschen, die wollten alle irgendwie Frieden und Diesel. Und ja, also das Typische, er hat ja in einem Landtagswald nichts zu suchen. Und vielleicht haben die Thüringer einfach gedacht, eine Bürgermeisterin aus Eisenach, also das finde ich irgendwie okay. Und ich habe noch mal nachgeguckt, wer es für die Grünen in Erfurt angetreten. Madeleine Henfling. Ihre Karriere ist Vizepräsidentin des Thüringer Landtags, klar, über die Fraktionsproporze, parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin der Grünenfraktion im Landtag und Landessprecher der Thüringer Grünen. So, also wer von beiden hat jetzt da ein virtuelles Argument gemacht, wählt mich. Also einmal so aus dem Verwaltungsapparat Landtag, der sich durch Proporz ergibt oder halt jemand aus dem Leben. Und ich würde dann sagen, ja, da kann jetzt Katrin Göring-Eckardt gerne behaupten, dass der Krämel über den BSW und so weiter und so fort. Aber vielleicht ist die Stärke von der BSW einfach dadurch begründet, dass sie sehr taktisch und sehr clever Leute auf eine Kandidatenliste gebracht hatte, die dann auch wirklich gewählt wurden. Statt irgendwie so einen Pro-Panz da zu machen.
Hast du dir die Doku angesehen Inside BSW?
Nee, noch nicht.
Ich habe sie mir angesehen. Sie ist jetzt nicht übermäßig interessant. Was aber aufschlussreich war, war, dass immer wieder Leute zu Wort kamen, die BSW unterstützen wollen. Sie bekommen ja oft keine Mitgliedschaft, weil das ja sehr sehr selektiv ist, aus diversen Gründen. Zum Beispiel wird ja auch gezeigt, wie jemand versucht, sich dort einzuschleichen, der eigentlich in der AfD ist. Das will man dann verhindern. Aber es gibt dann zum Beispiel Frauen. Vier Frauen sind das, die alle sich als Unternehmerinnen bezeichnet. Ich vermute kleinere Unternehmen haben, die auf einem Marktplatz, obwohl sie noch keine Mitgliedschaft haben, Werbung für das BSW machen. Und die sagen dann, jetzt wissen wir mal wieder, wo es langgeht. Und das ist jetzt die Erneuerung. Die geben Floskeln von sich. Dann hörst du andere, die sagen auch, ja, ich mag Wagenknecht und das ist eine tolle Frau, die sagt, wo es langgeht. Es ist gar nicht so, dass diese Leute in dieser Ideologie, die Göring-Eckardt unterstellt, so tief drin sind. Die werden alle sagen, ja, das ist aber auch nicht so gut, dass die NATO so weit vorgerückt ist im Osten. Und die werden wohl auch sagen, es muss ein Frieden her. Aber in diesen Einzelheiten ist das für die gar nicht wichtig, sondern für sie ist die Performance von Wagenknecht entscheidend. Und wenn das noch verquickt wird, dann mit einer regionalen Stimme, mit einer Bürgermeisterin, die sie schon bewährt hat, dann reicht das für die vollkommen aus. Die lesen ja dann nicht was zur Geopolitik.
Ja, ich verstehe sowieso nicht. Ich meine, wir haben ja nun dieses Buch von Steffen M wirklich sehr gelobt. Ja. Und ich verstehe, dass normale Menschen sich so denken, ah, Soziologie, keine Ahnung, so lustiges Argument, irgendwas mit Arenen. Aber als politischer Wahlkämpfer muss man das doch ernst nehmen, was da drin steht.
Ja, der SZG hat das ja gemacht, der macht ja die Arena hier auf. Er sagt einfach Migration, das verbinden wir jetzt noch mit sozialer Kälte. Und dann haben wir da ein wunderbares Match. Also der könnte man ja auch argumentieren, hat Triggerpunkte gelesen, hat gesehen, dass da Leute sitzen, die selber eigentlich nicht viel haben, aber noch darauf schimpfen, dass Bürgergeldempfänger zu viel bekommen und Migranten ein Problem sind. Und dann funktioniert diese Vermischung von Arenen wunderbar und das kann man politisch ausschlachten. Das beschreibt ja Triggerpunkte sehr gut und Cem Özdemir wendet es jetzt hier an.
Ja, wenn man die Leute fragt, da gibt es sehr schöne Clips wieder zur Brandenburg-Wahl in den Tagesthemen heute schon, die sind ja dann vor Ort. Bei offenen Fragestellungen sagen die Leute, das ist ein ungerechtes Land. Ja. So, Katrin Göring-Eckardt, das ist mir egal, die ist von Kreml gesteuert.
Du gestattest mir, sie sagen nicht, das ist ein ungerechtes Land. Sie sagen, wir wollten belogen und betrogen.
Oder so.
Das ist der Satz.
Ganz so sagen sie es nicht mehr. Sie sagen, das Wort ungerecht können sie schon ganz gut im Osten sagen. Zurecht.
Oh Gott, das gibt jetzt wirklich Ärger hier.
Ich bin ja Ossi.
Ja, ich nicht. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich bin ein bisschen diese Reportagen light, wo die ganze Zeit nur Leute dastehen, offene Fragen gestellt bekommen und dann sagen sie, wir wurden belogen und betrogen. Ich hätte gerne da ein bisschen mehr, sowohl journalistisch als auch von den Leuten. Dann sag bitte mal betrogen und belogen. Reden wir jetzt von der Freira nur oder wollen wir was Neues besprechen?
Das ist jetzt unfair, weil du unterstellst ja, dass sie gesagt haben, wir wurden belogen und betrogen. Ich sage ja, sie sagen ungerecht. Also ich zitiere, sie sagen, das ist ein ungerechtes Land. Und ich würde sagen, es ist ein sehr ungerechtes Land. Der Genie-Koeffizient beim Vermögen ist 0,8. Das ist spektakuläres afrikanisches Bananenrepublikanisches Verhältnis. So, womit ich jetzt nicht, ich meine das Afrika des letzten Jahrhunderts. So, daran kann man politisch ansetzen. Wenn man allerdings wie Kathrin Göring-Eckardt, die durchaus die Leute kennt, weil sie kommt ja aus dem selben Wahlkreis wie Sarah Wagenknecht, das ist ja alles Dunstkreise, Jena Weimar und so. Wenn man dann einfach sagt, nee, ich spiele jetzt politische Bundesliga, ich gucke nur noch in die Geopolitik und nicht mehr und so. Ich komme aus dem Völkerrecht, wie Annalena Baerbock das sagt. Dann ist die Beeinflussung durch den Kremel, wie man ja auch in der Zeitung las, das sagt die dann den Journalisten nochmal. Wirklich das wichtigste Problem der Welt. Nur die Leute vor Ort, ja, wenn man die nach dem Krieg fragt, sagen die, ich finde schießen nicht so gut, ich hätte lieber Frieden. Aber wenn man sie offen fragt, sagen sie, das ist ein ungerechtes Land. Ja. Und wenn man das nicht nutzt als politische Partei, ist man halt nicht wichtig.
Das will ich auch zugestehen. Was mich nur stört, ist jetzt, dass man, egal was man thematisiert, und jede Ost-Reportage funktioniert, so oder jede zweite zumindest, dass man hingeht und dann nur nochmal sagt, die Leidensgeschichte der Aussies. Also es stimmt einfach.
Die leiden ja auch.
Es stimmt, ja.
Aber ich leide auch.
Es stimmt. Die leiden alle. Nur, glaube ich, kommt man jetzt nicht weiter, wenn man einfach nur behauptet, man wurde belogen und betrogen. Es gab genau das. Und die 90er-Jahre wären ja da der Zeitpunkt, wo man sich auch fragen kann, wer da regiert hat. Das waren zum Beispiel nicht die Grünen dann. Da müsste man ja mal ganz anders draufblicken. Aber dass man jetzt die ganze Zeit so sich darin suhlt, wie das in den 90er-Jahren war, das finde ich ein bisschen nervig irgendwann. Weil man auch sagen muss, da gibt es auch jetzt neue Generationen. Und da müsste man jetzt auch fragen, welche aktuellen Probleme sind da. Also man wird jetzt nicht die Probleme der Vergangenheit, die durch das westliche Gebaren ganz deutlich entstanden sind, natürlich, die wird man aber jetzt nicht lösen können mehr, rückblickend. Man kann daran noch mal erinnern und man sollte es auch nicht vergessen. Nur wenn ich jetzt meine ganze Politik so retrotopisch ausrichte, dass ich eigentlich auch noch mal für 1994 eine Entschädigung haben möchte, dann kommt man einfach nicht weiter.
Ich glaube, du hast einen Podcast gehört, in dem zwei junge Ostdeutsche noch mal wir wurden belogen und betrogen drei Stunden lang gesagt haben, aber ich habe jedenfalls einen im Ohr, den ich dir da unterstelle. Aber wenn man die Leute fragt, sagen die, es ist ein ungerechtes Land. Also so rückwärtsgewandt auf die Wände, die Treuhand oder so weiter, das ist gar nicht mehr.
Dass die Mehrheit das inzwischen sogar so sieht und sagt, eher ein ungerechtes Land und nicht belogen und betrogen, das glaube ich sehr. Nur ich habe aber einen Eindruck, dass Journalisten eigentlich gerne in den Osten reisen, um noch mal zu gucken, ob da jemand steht, um die 60 Jahre alt, der sagt, wir wurden belogen und betrogen.
So wie du das ja auch gerade ins Gespräch gebracht hast, weil du es gerne noch mal hören wolltest.
Nein, weil ich es 100 Mal ja jetzt schon wieder gesehen habe. Ich habe ja lauter Reportagen, alle schicken jemanden los mit dem kleinen Kameratin in den Osten und dann hört man das noch mal.
Fernsehen halt.
Und du bist ja selbst, der dann immer sagt, bitte keine Jammer aussiehst. Du hast diesen Begriff ja in den Mund genommen. Ich würde den ja nur mit Anführungszeichen verwenden. Wir hören jetzt noch mal Kathrin Göring-Eckardt im Podcast Wahlkreis Ost.
Aber es schlägt ja auch zurück. Es schlägt zurück, weil es geht schon um die Sicherheit bei uns auch, bei der Ukraine-Unterstützung. Und das, was Sarah Wagenknecht provoziert, ist, dass wir unsicherer werden, was sie auch provozieren will, weil das passt natürlich in das Bild. Es passt in, wir machen noch ein bisschen mehr Spaltung, wir machen noch mal ein bisschen mehr Verunsicherung, wir machen noch mal ein bisschen mehr Destruktivität. Und dann kann sie kommen und sagen, ist aber alles ganz schlimm und ich sage euch, ich mache es jetzt besser. Und das ist das Riesenproblem. Und deswegen muss ja wohl verhandelt werden. Das wird keine andere Möglichkeit geben. Aber ich kann alle nur davor warnen.
Sie meint jetzt aber nicht die Verhandlung Ukraine, Russland, sondern die Verhandlung muss man mit BSW und CDU irgendwas da zusammen machen.
Darauf einzugehen. Ich weiß, es ist sehr kretschend, weil das ja selber mehr oder weniger so sieht. Worauf einzugehen?
Auf die Wirklichkeit, eine Koalition zu werden?
Nee, das meine ich nicht. Sondern ich meine darauf einzugehen, dass die deutsche Außenpolitik in Dresden oder Erfurt auf Umwegen bestimmt wird und dann zurückschlägt im Sinne von eigener Unsicherheit in unserem Land. Das ist ja nicht weit weg. Das sind 1000 Kilometer bis Kiew.
Naja, also soweit ich das gehört habe, ist diese Präampel Vichy Vachy. Ja, es ist nur ein mediales Machtspiel darum. Wird am Ende und das werden wir dann auch sehen, noch jemand sagen, sorry, wir nehmen euch gerne auf in die Koalition, aber nur ohne das. Ja, und dann wird Sarah Wang nicht sagen, na gut. Ich glaube, dass das unsinnig ist.
Und ich finde auch, dass sehr unseriös jetzt mit dieser Angst zu spielen, wenn die Raketen hier nicht stationiert werden, dann, liebe Leute, ihr wisst, Kiew ist nur 1000 Kilometer weit, steht der Russe bald vor der Tür. Das ist auch nicht ein seriöser Umgang, ebenso wenig wie Habeck, das bei einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung wachte. Wir hören jetzt einen Ausschnitt aus einer Rede.
Niemand in der Bundesrepublik, meine Damen und Herren, machen wir das sicher, und wir schreiben uns schön, aber korrekt gekauft ist niemand, im Unterschied zu AfD und BSC. Sich Habeck für seine Meinung bezahlen zu lassen, im Internet Stimmen zu kaufen, tollen Armeen aufzubauen, eine Meinung gekauft zu bekommen, das ist wirrig, und das gehört sich nicht.
Gut, bei der AfD gibt es ja entsprechende Untersuchungen dazu. Beim BSC aber haben sich ja diese Anschuldigungen als falsch herausgestellt. Deshalb musste Habeck, soweit ich unterrichtet bin, eine Unterlassungserklärung unterschreiben, weil er das nicht mehr sagen darf. Ich verstehe auch die Argumentation deshalb nicht, weil wir doch Wagenknecht schon lange kennen und noch länger kennen wir Oskar Lafontaine. Der war immer auf einem starken Anti-NATO-Trip. Mit immer meine ich jetzt so die letzten 25 Jahre. Das ist ja nicht etwas, was der jetzt gerade macht, weil er Geld bekommt oder sonst irgendwas, sondern das ist seine Position dazu. Und die kommt aus dem Inneren, also die kommt von ihm. Und diese Position, die viele dann beim BSW haben, kommt von denen selbst. Also ich weiß gar nicht, dass man immer glaubt, das Volk ist irgendwie rein und wird aber von außen durch schlimme Ideologien bedroht. Nein, man kann doch auch selber auf Ideen kommen.
Ja, vor allem, was ich nicht verstehe, warum verkämpft man sich in solchen Sachen? Also die NATO stand doch nie so stark da wie jetzt. Ja. Lass doch die Leute sagen, wir brauchen die NATO nicht oder so. Ist doch völlig gegen den Zeitgeist.
Ja.
Finland soll wieder austreten oder welche Angst hat er da?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie man darauf kommen kann, dass Leute immer nur, wenn sie von außen indoktriniert wurden oder Gelder gesehen haben, dass sie dann Positionen vertreten, die einem nicht gefallen. Die AfD vertritt ja auch nicht die Positionen deshalb, weil sie Geld von Marine Le Pen bekommt. Und Söder spricht nicht so, weil er Geld von Viktor Urmann bekommt, sondern jeder spricht so, wie er sich das selbst auch denkt. Dass es mal Fälle gibt von Korruption oder so etwas, das muss ja dann auch nachgewiesen werden. Und es ist ja was anderes. Aber es gibt einfach schon Leute, die so denken.
Diese Korrumtionsfälle wurden ja der AfD wirklich nachgewiesen.
Ja.
Also da gab es ja Kandidaten und dann Chinesen und Russen und so weiter. Und es war ja wirklich belegt.
Und nicht mal das zündete. Also was glaubt habe jetzt, dass man das auf einer Bühne, in dem man Leuten so etwas zuruft, da irgendwelche Wirkungen entfalten?
Jetzt hören wir eine Landssendung. Hofreiter war da zu Gast und er diskutiert dort mit Martin Huber von der CSU. Und auch hier wieder dieses Kreml-Argument.
Wissen Sie, Herr Huber, was mir etwas Sorgen macht? Was Sie hier gerade aufführen und was Herr Söder aufführt, das können Sie nachlesen in Papieren, die aus dem Kreml stammen. Und da heißt die Hauptstrategie zum Umgang mit den Grünen, ist sie verächtlich machen und diffamieren. Und das ist das, was sie systematisch machen. Und damit folgen sie eins zu eins der Kreml-Strategie. Und das ist in diesen gefährlichen Zeiten ein Problem.
Also, ich finde es nicht verkehrt, das zu sagen. Die Frage ist nur, wie und wer. Denn Söder, also Söder zu unterstellen, dass er in Kreml, das finde ich schon witzig.
Es ist witzig, aber völlig irrsinnig.
Ja, aber es ist halt auch witzig.
Also der liest ja nicht in Kreml-Paper und sagt sich, ah, das ist immer eine gute Sache.
Ja, aber...
Da helfe ich auch meinem Freund Putin mit.
Ich fände es nicht verkehrt. Söder, also Söder hat jetzt die Grünen kurz und klein geschossen. So wenn man jetzt zum Gegenangriff übergeht und sagt, der wankelmütige Söder macht jeden Scheiß mit sogar das.
Jetzt argumentieren wir ja auf einer Ebene, welche Strategie wird hier angewendet. Aber wir müssen ja erkenntnisinteressiert sein. Und es ist ja jetzt einfach so, dass Söder die Grünen hasst, zumindest zeitweise. Und das hat aber nichts mit irgendwelchen Papieren aus dem Kreml zu tun.
Aber was wäre jetzt, wenn Hofreiter da säße? Ich sage gleich vorweg, ich finde es super witzig. Und auch wirksam, glaube ich. Wenn Hofreiter nicht so griesgrämig, sondern ein bisschen fröhlicher. Einfach sozusagen auf Augenhöhe, wie grün sind wir oder so. Also mit ein bisschen Selbstbehauptung. Nicht nur einfach abfeuert, sie machen das Drehbuch der AfD, sondern das Kreml, sondern sie sind so dumm und so faul, dass sie einfach nur die Grünen bashen wollen. Und dann nehmen sie sich sogar Talking Points des Kreml, weil ihnen wirklich nichts was heilig ist.
Aber das ist doch auch kein Talking Point. Also wenn da, ich kenne diese Paper ja nicht, aber wenn da steht, die Grünen verächtlich machen, ist eine Strategie, die wir begrüßen.
Ja, das muss man halt besser ausformulieren.
Dann kann ich doch sagen, ja, das ist so allgemein formuliert. Dann kann ich auch jedem Grünen vorwerfen, dass er die Paper des Pentagon in Deutschland in die Tat umsetzt, denn da steht auch drin, die Sicherheit der NATO-Staaten ist das Wichtigste. Oh, das sagen die Grünen auch. Das scheint ja Pentagon-Propaganda zu sein.
Also mir geht es spezifisch darum...
Jeder kommt doch selbst auf eine Idee. Also Söder hat jetzt aus politischen Erwägungen heraus gesagt, ich erkläre die Grünen zum Feind. Da spielt kein Kreml und kein Pentagon nun nix eine Rolle bei.
Mein Punkt ist doch, ja, Söder macht das von alleine. Aber auch Söder braucht Talking Points. Also eine kleine kognitive Leistung, wie man jetzt die Grünen basht.
Aber da liest er nicht ein russisches Paper.
Das würde ich ihm jetzt unterstellen. Wenn ich ein Grüner wäre, würde ich sagen, Herr Söder, wenn Sie wenigstens Ihre eigenen Argumente gegen die Grünen vorbringen, stattdessen lese ich Seite 17 von dem Paper des Kreml in Ihrer Rede. Fast wortwörtlich.
Ja, aber dafür ist es ja viel zu unspezifisch.
Und darüber würde ich mich dann lustig machen.
Es ist ja unspezifisch.
Wer das nicht kann, das ist ja das, das Hofreiter ist halt... Also ich finde ja, angenommen Habeck hat sie alle da rausgekekelt. Ich finde zu Recht. Weil die haben es nicht gebracht. Du hast doch hier Hofreiter gerade gehört. So kann man doch nicht bei Land sitzen.
Wir hören jetzt mal den Kaderland.
In den letzten Tagen gab es noch mal vermehrt Berichterstattungen, wo aufgedeckt wurde, wie russische Propaganda auch hier in Deutschland funktioniert. Und dabei gibt es drei ganz klare Ziele. Erstens, Parteien stärken, die Putin nahestehen, also insbesondere AfD und BSW. Zweitens, Parteien schwächen, die progressiv sind und die sich auch für die Ukraine engagieren, also insbesondere uns Grüne. Und drittens, Angst und Sorge verbreiten, einen Blick auf Chaos zu machen. Und auch dem müssen wir es entgegensetzen. Einmal, indem wir die Plattform viel härter regulieren. Es kann nicht sein, dass ganz viel von dieser Desinformation einfach stehen gelassen wird. Und zweitens, indem wir auch dieser Vorstellungen der Spaltung entgegensprechen, dass wir in einem Land leben, wo alles gespalten ist, niemand mehr miteinander reden kann. Ich erlebe ein Land, in dem ganz viele Menschen gleiche Erfahrungen machen, morgens zur Arbeit gehen, ihr Geld verdienen, besseres Leben für ihre Kinder wollen. Da müssen wir wieder ansetzen, auch um diese Angst entgegenzutreten.
Ja, ich leide, wenn ich sowas sehe. Wenn das meine Partei wäre und ich wäre allmächtig, aber deswegen halte ich mich aus sowas raus, ich hätte die auch rausgeeckelt. Weil so kann man keine Publikumsansprache machen. Man muss darauf hoffen, dass in der eigenen Partei irgendwer auftaucht, der als Kind auf dem Acker Fußball gespielt hat, dann am Kanzlerzaun gerüttelt hat, dann noch, wo man sich gar nicht vorstellen kann, das Jurastudium erfolgreich abgeschlossen hat und der dann auf der Debattenbühne steht, die Schwarzen tun immer so, als ob ihnen der Staat gehöre. Das muss die initiale Ansprache sein.
Es klingt nach Gerhard Schröder.
Es klingt nach Gerhard Schröder und ich werde umso mehr, wie auch im Büro, immer mal wieder alte Gerhard Schröder Reden hören, großer Fan dieser Zeit, in der einfach die Partei sich drauf geeinigt hat, wenn wir Ricarda Langes haben oder Franziska Brandners oder Toni Hofreiters, dann packen wir die auf die Posten, wo sie hingehören, dann machen die da diese inhaltliche Arbeit. Aber geredet wird vom Gerd und zwar nur, wenn großes Publikum da ist und nicht in jedem Scheiß. Sie haben mir eine Frage gestellt und ein Mikrofon hingehalten, dann sag ich mal kurz und dann kommt sowas bei raus. Das geht halt nicht. Also in der Ansicht sind die Leute schon Zeug gescheitert.
Man will doch eigentlich Leute wieder gewinnen. Und jetzt sagt man denen, ja, ihr seid ja alle fremdgesteuert von Kreml. Der Kreml hat das eigentlich vor mit euch und ihr seid da reingefallen. Da sagen die doch dann nicht, die das hören. Ach ja, stimmt. Genau. Meine Grünen-Kritik kommt aus dem Kreml. Sondern die muss man doch damit gewinnen, dass man ihnen sagt, wir machen Politik für euch. Und dann kann man mit Gerechtigkeit und all diesen Dingen operieren. Aber ich kann den Leuten doch nicht sagen, ja, ihr seid leider der ganze Zeit diesen Propagandanarrativen auf den Leim gegangen.
Robert Harde kämpft nicht gegen den politischen Gegner, sondern gegen seine eigene Partei. Ricardo Lang kämpft nicht um ihr Publikum, sondern es spielt über Dreifachbande. Ich weiß, ich erreiche dich nicht, aber so wie dich die anderen erreichen, das ist nicht gut, das was du gerade beschrieben hast. Und das ist doch alles Nonsens. Das ist doch alles Verschwendung von medialer Zeit. Sowas wirkt doch einfach nicht.
CSU, Martin Huber bei Lanz. Es geht darum, ob man mit den Grünen doch mal zusammenarbeiten könnte in Zukunft.
Schauen Sie, wir erleben es ja heute auch. Herr Huber, was ist ausgeschlossen?
Bei der Bundestagswahl.
Ist ausgeschlossen.
Ausgeschlossen.
Also lieber nicht regieren dann mit anderen Worten.
Schauen Sie, momentan ist doch die Situation ohnehin so, dass Schwarz-Grün überhaupt keine Mehrheit hat. Also ist doch schon mal die Frage, über was reden wir überhaupt. Die inhaltlichen Unterschiede mit den Grünen sind so riesengroß, dass es überhaupt nicht denkbar ist, da gemeinsam zu regieren. Und deswegen sagen wir auch klipp und klar, mit uns kein Schwarz-Grün, wir werden das verhindern.
Also Brandmauer heißt das?
Der Begriff ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen, den die da in die Diskussion schmeißen. Wir sagen ganz deutlich, die Grünen stehen in sämtlichen Politikbereich so diametral uns entgegen, dass da keine Zusammenarbeit geht.
Wenn die Grünen so aufgestellt wären, dass man schon ein Jahr vor der Bundestagswahl sagen könnte, Schwarz-Grün können wir uns durchaus vorstellen, das Wichtigste ist ja nur, dass wir 1000 Windräder bauen, egal wie, dann würde doch gar keine Rolle spielen, was Martin Huber als Generalsekretär der CSU in Bayern dazu sagt. Wenn aber die Ausgangslage ist, dass Martin Huber, den niemand kennt, bei Markus Lanz sagt, Schwarz-Grün ist ausgeschlossen. Ja, dann ist Schwarz-Grün ausgeschlossen.
Es ist natürlich nicht ausgeschlossen, weil man ja sieht, wie regiert wird in Deutschland. Melanie Ammann sitzt da und zählt auf.
Seit 2008 ist Schwarz-Grün politische Realität, muss man sagen. Es hat angefangen mit Ole von Beust in Hamburg, in Hessen. Wirklich kein liberaler CDU-Verband, traditionell. Die haben sie auch gerechnet. Ja, aber es gab eine lange, unter Roland Koch und später Volker Bouffier, eine lange schwarz-grüne Zusammenarbeit.
Boris Rhein hat ja auch im Wahlkampf schon angekündigt, dass er nicht zwingend auf die Fortsetzung kommt.
Im Ländle ist die CDU froh und dankbar, dass sie mitregieren darf mit den Grünen. In NRW funktioniert es auch gut und in Schleswig-Holstein sehr geräuschlos. Da hätte sogar auch Schwarz-Gelb funktioniert und Daniel Günther hat sich für Schwarz-Grün entschieden.
Die Realität ist also eine andere als die, die jetzt dargestellt wird. Im Bund. So. Und jetzt sagt er, weil sie sich in so vielen Themen so uneins sind, das geht überhaupt nicht zusammen. Und ich überlege gerade, welche Themen sind das denn da? Hofreiter hilft jetzt mal nach.
Zusammenarbeit zwischen den demokratischen Parteien im Bundestag oft viel, viel besser, als das auf den ersten Blick nach außen erscheint. Und das muss auch so sein. Denn wir haben große Herausforderungen. Wir haben zum Beispiel einen sehr guten Antrag zwischen den Regierungsparteien und der Union gemacht zur Unterstützung der Ukraine. Und wenn Sie immer sagen, Sie sind diametral anderer Ansicht, dann würde mich mal interessieren, sind Sie gegen die Unterstützung der Ukraine? Sind Sie gegen die Westbindung? Sind Sie dagegen, dass wir die NATO stärken? Sind Sie dagegen, dass wir mehr Geld in die Bundeswehr stecken? Also das würde mich einfach mal interessieren. Sie sagen, Sie sind in allen Punkten diametral anderer Ansicht. Dann wäre das schon mal interessant, das zu wissen.
Zum nächsten Mal finde ich die Punkte, die Sie aufführen, der ist bemerkenswert für einen früheren Ostermarschierer und jetzigen Rüstungsexperten, aber der ist nur am Rande.
Also der ist gar nicht an einer Argumentation interessiert.
Wer guckt sowas?
Aber du, ich habe es mir extra angesehen. Denn erstaunlich ist doch hier, dass eigentlich gar keine Unterschiede benannt werden können, von Huber nicht. Und Hofreiter sagt, da gibt es ja auch gar keine Unterschiede. Es geht also nur um Stilfragen. Und das ist das, was du Anfangs schon angesprochen hast.
Zu Recht geht es nur um Stilfragen.
Das will ich jetzt mal so dahingestellt lassen. Aber es geht um die Frage, ist die Ansprache, die die Grünen wählen, eine, die CDU-Wähler abschreckt? Ja oder nein? Die Antwort ist Ja für Söder und ganz viele andere. Und deswegen sind inhaltliche Fragen überhaupt nicht relevant. Denn was wäre denn inhaltlich das, was die beiden so unglaublich voneinander trennt? Bei der CDU glaubt doch auch niemand mehr wirklich daran, dass wir nochmal ein großes Atomzeitalter bekommen und wir ganz viele neue Werke errichten.
Ja, aber warum verkämpfen sich die Grünen da so? Ich meine, Robert Habeck ist schön und gut. Er kann das mit dem Atomkraftwerk alles erklären. Aber selbst als Wirtschaftsminister würde ich einfach sagen, ich habe gerade gehört, irgendwer fordert Atomkraftwerke, bauen sie einfach. Schlagen sie sich selber mit den Banken rum, wo sie die 20 Milliarden herkriegen. Klären sie, ob man jetzt den Atom will auf dem Gelände oder halt, wenn nicht auf dem Gelände, dann woanders. Also wir müssen wissen, wo. Wir bauen kein Atomkraftwerk ohne Endlager, Punkt. Mehr als dieser Halbsatz ist nicht notwendig in diesen Diskussionen. Und stattdessen kommt da nochmal, ich meine, einmal das gegen Söder Dreck zu machen, finde ich gut. Ja, aber es bei Lanz irgendwelchen Leuten nochmal zu erklären, finde ich nicht gut. Ja, da muss man einfach. Also man muss sich jetzt diese Kämpfe, die man führt, aussuchen. Nein, ich glaube, nicht gegen die eigene Partei. Bitte nicht bei Themen, wo jeder Zeitgeist auf der eigenen Seite ist.
Du hast so gesagt, das Ziel ist schwarz-grün. Ich glaube, dass die Grünen sich jetzt gerade dahingehend erneuern, dass sie eine konservative Partei werden und dass sie das mit aller Kraft versuchen. Und da werden noch einige Stilfragen zu klären sein. Und da wird manches Personal noch ausgetauscht werden. Aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass diese Partei irgendeine große ökologische Transformation noch anstrebt. Sondern man sagt sich eigentlich, wenn wir hier so zusammen regieren können und es springen noch ein paar Windräder bei raus, okay. Aber das reicht eigentlich schon. Und sonst sind wir bereit, den gesamten Kurs der CDU mitzutragen. Die CDU muss jetzt ja gerade, weil die Nähe zwischen den Grünen nie so groß war, so aggressiv die Unterschiede herausstellen und kann es nur in Stilfragen tun, kann sich auf Veggie Days und so ein Kram beziehen. Aber sie hat keine inhaltlichen Argumente mehr dagegen, weil sie eigentlich passkonform schon sind, die Grünen für eine Koalition mit der Union.
Wir haben doch über Inhalte gesprochen, haben ja gesagt, es spielt eigentlich keine Rolle mehr, außer wirklich im 1 zu 1. Und dann redet man mit GPT und lässt sich so ein paar Sachen erklären, die man von Egon am Gartenzaun nicht erfährt. Wenn die Grünen darunter leiden, dass die anderen Parteien immer kommen und sagen, ihr definiert hier einen Zeitgeist, den es gar nicht gibt. Die Leute wollen ihren Schnitzel und die wollen mit ihrem Penis, stolz als Männer durch die Welt laufen, wie auch immer. Dann ist doch die Antwort der Grünen nicht, wir kämpfen jetzt aber für die NATO und gegen die Atomkraft, oder was auch immer. Das sind doch alte Kämpfe. Atomkraft ist aussortiert. Die NATO ist so stark wie nie. Warum reden die da noch darüber? Ich will, dass sie jenseits dieser Inhaltsebene jetzt einfach sagen, ihr habt Recht, wir sind eine Zeitgeist-Partei. Ihr habt Unrecht, indem ihr sagt, wir setzen ihn, wir greifen ihn auf. Wir sind die Partei, die den Zeitgeist versteht. Und dann muss man der CDU sagen, schauen sie sich die Marketing-Budgets aller großen Unternehmen an. Die sind alle vogue. Die gehen alle auf das neue junge Publikum, weil sie wissen, die lehren aus ihren Eltern noch das Geld raus und wollen aber was anderes als die Elterngeneration und was auch immer. Und diese Selbstsicherheit, ich verstehe gar nicht, wie man die nicht haben kann. Das ist ja so, als würden wir uns von jedem Kommentar, den wir zu diesem Podcast bekommen, verunsichern lassen und dann sagen, die Rechten haben doch recht. Uns hat so ein rechter Kanal auf YouTube 18 Minuten lang geguckt. Ich glaube, die haben recht. Das ist doch bescheuert. Warum machen die Grünen das? Die Grünen haben doch wirklich die Einladung von allen Parteien bekommen. Ihr seid Zeitgeist. Aber weil wir den Zeitgeist nicht mögen und dann unsere Don-Krieg-Hott-Kämpfe gegen irgendwelche Mündenwühlen kämpfen, fokussieren wir uns auf die Grünen, weil die für diesen Zeitgeist stehen. Da muss man auch selbstsicher sagen, wir sind die Zukunft, wir sind der Zeitgeist, wir kämpfen nicht gegen den Zeitgeist, weil er unbeirrt einfach nach vorne schreitet, China macht, Amerika macht. Und wir machen jetzt Diesel? No, 30 Jahre weiter.
Vielleicht will aber die Grüne Spitze gar nicht mehr zeitgeistig sein.
Ja, aber dann brauchen wir sie auch nicht.
Denn es gibt eine sehr eigenartige Auffassung von Demokratie, wie ich doch finde, Katrin Göring-Eckardt nochmal.
Aber so dieses Gefühl, was habe ich eigentlich von der Demokratie und was liefert sie mir? Und kluge Wissenschaftler sagen, es gibt so die Erwartung einer Dienstleistungsgesellschaft. Demokratie ist aber mehr so eine Mitmachaktion. Und man möchte mal gerne, dass Politikerinnen oder Politiker das Problem, was man gerade hat oder was einem gerade am schwersten ist oder am wichtigsten ist, bitteschön jetzt löst. Und zwar genauso, wie man es gerne möchte. Das funktioniert aber nicht in der Demokratie. Das ist Politik auch nicht dafür da. Sie ist dafür da, einen Ausgleich zu finden, irgendwie, weil sie über die Bibel gesprochen haben, der Stadt Bestes zu suchen. Also nicht des Einzelnen, des Bewohner, sondern der Stadt Bestes zu suchen. Also für alle das Beste zu suchen.
Die Politik soll mir nicht in Anzug kürzen. Aber die Politik ist für mich eine Dienstleistung. Die sollen das machen. Die sollen Milliardäre besteuern, Punkt. Und das erwarte ich. Und das ist wie in einem Supermarkt. Da erwarte ich, dass das und das da ist. Und dann kaufe ich das. Und hier sage ich auch, ich kann euch wählen. Aber folgende Dienstleistung muss verrichtet werden. Besteuerung von Milliardären zum Beispiel. Jetzt zu sagen, ja, das ist was Partizipatives. Und dann machen wir alle mit. Und so sage ich, nee, ich wähle euch ja, damit ihr das macht. Ich will ja nicht mitmachen. Und ehrlich gesagt, ihr wollt doch auch nicht, dass ich mitmache. Ihr wollt das doch unter euch ausmachen. Ihr wollt auch das Habeck und fünf andere entscheiden, wer jetzt das Schiffchen lenkt.
Ja, ich meine, genau. Es ist doch zu mitmachen. Alle sind eingeladen. Und selbst der Parteichef wird rausgeschwissen. So was soll einfach vom Hofe ziehen. Gefällt uns nicht mehr. Also es ist wirklich das Paradoxin. Wenn am Ende so ein bisschen habt ihr beide recht. Also sie hat schon recht damit, wenn sie sagt, die Leute verstehen das immer so als Dienstleistung, weil, und dann komme ich jetzt auf den Jammer, Ossi, aber der nicht sagt, wir wurden belogen und betrogen, sondern dieses, mich fragt ja keiner. Die Leute stehen ja im Stau und sagen, die Straße ist zu voll, ich wähle jetzt AfD. Und hier, und wir haben es ja immer mal wieder betont, Gilda Sahebi, ich erinnere daran, Menschen haben Interessen und Belange. Um die muss sich jemand kümmern. Wenn man aber Belange klar identifiziert, für die die Mutter zuständig ist, dann kann eine Partei ganz selbstbewusst behaupten, sorry, Elgern, das machen wir nicht. Und das macht die CDU und die AfD, die machen das auch nicht. Bitte warte nicht auf den Zaubungsscheiß oder was auch immer, sondern das sind einfach rassistische oder populistische Belange. Dafür haben wir die Oper, Konzerte, geh gerne raus, mach Sport, was auch immer. Also wenn man den Katalog des eigenen Angebots klar definiert hat, dann kann man sowas differenzieren. Aber da es kein Katalog gibt, sondern wir plötzlich von den Grünen alles hören zum Thema NATO, Atomkraftwerk, Neubau, Kreml-Propaganda, weiß ich halt auch nicht genau, was ist jetzt in Dienstleistung, also was ist legitimerweise als Dienstleistung im Angebot und was nicht. Und dass die Leute dann sagen, keine Ahnung, ich verliere den Überblick, ich stehe im Stau, das finde ich nicht gut, macht mal was. Das verstehe ich dann schon so ein bisschen.
Ja, aber jetzt kommt etwas neues Zeit für was Neues. Die jungen Grünen vom Bundesvorstand sind nicht nur zurückgetreten, sondern haben ihr Parteibuch abgegeben. Das heißt ja etwas und viele Landesverbände sind dem nachgekommen.
Ja, auch der Schleswig-Holsteinische, also Habex, Nachwuchsorganisation.
Ja, wir hören jetzt in das Video mal rein Zeit für was Neues, dass dann diese neue Gruppierung, die sich da gründet abgespalten hat, von den jungen Grünen veröffentlicht hat.
Zur Rückweisung aller Asylbewerber.
Deshalb sparen wir eine Milliarde Euro beim Bürgergeld. Die kriegst du nicht, Alter.
So schmerzhaft Kompromisse sind, auch sehr zu gehen.
Dieses Sondervermögen einmalig mit 100 Milliarden Euro ausstattet.
Es braucht etwas Neues.
Inflation, Klimakrise, Rechtsruck.
Es gibt gerade keine politische Kraft, die dem wirklich etwas entgegensetzt. Immer mehr Menschen fühlen sich weder gesehen, noch vertreten, noch verstanden und wenden sich frustriert von der Politik ab. Wir alle sind in den letzten zehn Jahren bei den Grünen eingetreten, weil wir die Hoffnung hatten, mit ihnen die Welt zu einer besseren machen zu können.
Wir haben Aktionen und Demos organisiert, Anträge geschrieben, Wahlkampf gemacht, junge Menschen in Parlamente geschickt.
Wir haben versucht, uns dagegen zu wehren, dass sich unsere Partei an Aufrüstung, der Räumung von Lützerath, Sparpolitik und Asylrechtsverschärfungen beteiligt.
Wir konnten es nicht verhindern.
Wir wollten, dass die Grünen eine Partei werden, die sich mit den Interessen der Konzerne, der Reichen und der Mächtigen anlegt.
Es war nicht durchsetzbar. Wir sind nicht länger bereit, unseren Kopf für eine Politik hinzuhalten, die wir falsch finden. Wir halten es nicht länger aus, dass immer mehr Menschen so frustriert sind, dass sie sich den Rechten zuwenden.
Wir machen mal hier kurz Stopp. Hat dich das überrascht, dass der Vorstand zurückgetreten ist und das Parteibuch abgegeben hat? Mich hat es nicht wahnsinnig überrascht. Also auf den ersten Blick dachte ich, das ist ja allerhand. Da müssen wir unbedingt drüber sprechen im Podcast. Und dann habe ich aber ein bisschen die Begegnungen Revue passieren lassen, die ich so in den vergangenen Monaten hatte. Und zwar bei irgendwelchen aktivistischen Festivals. Ich war beispielsweise in Lübeck bei La Rage. Ich war bei Podiumsdiskussionen zu allen möglichen Themen rund um Kapitalismus, Klimatransformation.
Sie sind nur Rundbürger gesehen.
Nein, ich habe da ja vor allem ein sehr junges Publikum erlebt und dort auch sehr viele erlebt, die bei der Grünen Jugend sind oder ihr nahestehen oder auch Jusus zum Teil erlebt, aber vor allem waren es doch immer grüne Jugend. Viel vertreten hatte ich den Eindruck. Also nicht diese erste Riege, die wir jetzt da sehen. Ich kenne ja auch Sarah D. Heinrich nicht persönlich. Wir haben zweimal miteinander oder dreimal miteinander gesprochen, aber ich kenne sie ja nicht. Aber ich habe so aus der Basis natürlich viele erlebt und da war nicht nur ein großer Unmut darüber, wie das mit der Ampelkoalition läuft, sondern da war ein regelrechter Zorn darauf, wie sich die Grünen als Partei entwickeln und welche Schritte sie bereit sind, mitzugehen. Und nicht nur im Sinne von, da musste mal ein Kompromiss her, sondern im Ganzen, dass es diesen konservativen Rollback gibt oder dass es eigentlich so eine konservative neue Identität bei den Grünen gibt. Und das war etwas, was interessanterweise auch besonders von Leuten vorgetragen wurde, denen das Soziale ganz wichtig ist. Also wir sprechen jetzt nicht davon, dass ich jetzt mit Berlin-Mittegrüne, will ich sie mal nennen, zusammensaß, die alles vorm Vollende gendern und alles richtig machen, was diese ganzen Dinge anbelangt. Nee, das trifft man natürlich auch an. Aber für die war immer entscheidend, wie geht es den Menschen, die nicht viel haben, wie ist es mit der Besteuerung von Reichen und wie kann es eigentlich sein, dass Aufrüstung jetzt das Mantra ist, der es alle unterschreiben müssen. Hinzu kommt noch, meistens aber dann hinter vorgehaltener Hand eher vorgetragen, ein großer Unmut darüber, wie die Grünen sich im Konflikt, im Nahostkonflikt verhalten. Dieser Krieg gegen Gaza, der so viele Zivilisten Tode fordert, ist etwas, was für einen ganz großen Unmut bei diesen jungen Leuten auch sorgt. Und dass das alles überhaupt nicht mehr nach oben weitergegeben werden konnte, dass das sich oben abgedichtet hat, das habe ich bei diesen sehr zufälligen Begegnungen sehr stark gespürt. Und deshalb hat es mich dann im Ganzen doch nicht so überrascht. Ich bin überrascht von der Konsequenz und auch von der Radikalität, weil man ja auch selbst sich politische Karrieren dadurch zerstört, dass man also dazu bereit ist. Das imponiert mir. Aber im Ganzen finde ich es dann nicht so überraschend, weil ich würde sagen, wenn man so ein bisschen sich mit jungen Leuten, die sich politisch engagieren, unterhalten hat, dann war eigentlich abzusehen, dass das nicht mehr zusammengeht mit Habeckismus, mit Toni Hofreiter und all den anderen.
Also wir haben ja hier ein Buch gelesen von Kansin Köktürk, die ja auch eine Grüne, ich bin in der Partei gescheitert und so weiter. Das ist alles, also damit, hier hat auch niemand eine Karriere vor sich oder so. Es sei denn, man ist relativ früh schon so ein alter Habeck, dann hat man eine Karriere. Ich sehe das ja nicht sozusagen aus dieser aktivistischen Richtung. Also ich bin ja häufiger da, weil ich mich nicht so oft einladen lasse von den, oder sozusagen die schon angekommenen sind, sondern jetzt so über die Schulklassen und so weiter, wo ich da einen Einblick habe, verschiedene Vereine, wo ich habe es ja schon mal beschrieben, einfach die Leute mittlerweile offen sagen, dass sie arm sind, weil sie es nicht mehr verstecken. Warum auch? Die Hälfte der Klasse braucht halt eine Unterstützung für jeden Scheiß. Also Klassenkasse, will irgendwie 30 Euro und dann fragen die, fragt die Hälfte der Klasse, ob man das so in drei Monatsetappen bezahlen kann. Weil mehr als 10 Euro im Monat einfach nicht drin sind. So, da liegt ja nun eine mobilisierbare Jugendbewegung, bei der ich denke, klar, Land sitzt in seiner Sendung und kommt dann irgendwie so ganz staatstragend daher mit dem Argument, kein Wunder, dass die jungen Leute alle AfD wählen, die sehen ja aus nächster Nähe, was ist, wenn zu viele Ausländer da sind. So, während ich denke, nee, diese Ausländer, das sind schon die Freunde der jungen Leute, nur die sehen halt diesen Alarm, also mit denen ist halt nichts anzufangen. Ein paar davon schaffen es dann irgendwie später in so einem Berufsalltag. Oder dann sagst du, okay, komm, wir treffen uns Samstag, wir gehen ins Café, dann spielen wir da Karten und bestellen nur ein Kaffee. Weil drei Stunden, 5,80 Euro, muss reichen. Unterhaltung ist Karten spielen. So, und diese Leute, diese jungen Leute, von denen auf der Webseite ja ein Bild mit zwölf Leuten ist, neun davon weiblich, da würde ich mal sagen, also ich habe jetzt kein anderes politisches Bild vor Augen. Der Bundestag macht Rückschritte beim Thema Anteil von Weiblichkeit. Vorstände sind immer noch so bei 20 Prozent in Deutschland, also politische Kremien in Unternehmen und so weiter. Eigentlich ist das doch sehr untypisch. So, und jetzt wieder das große Bild vom Anfang. Interstellar ist jetzt hier unser Film. Man hat ein Ziel vor Augen und man muss da irgendwie hin. Also was braucht man? Ein schwarzes Loch, das man so als Schwungmasse nutzt. Wir wollen nicht zu dem schwarzen Loch, sondern so drum rum. So wie man auch mit Satelliten erst mal so dreimal um den Mond fliegt. Also man holt so Schwung über die Gravitation der anderen. Wer sind die anderen? Na ja, Schwarz-Grün. Schwarz-Grün droht jetzt. Wir können alle nichts dagegen tun. BlackRock wird Bundeskanzler. Es wird einen großen Ausverkauf von Deutschland geben. Nur, wenn man das halt klug, klug, also sehr klug, publizistisch begleitet. Wenn man jetzt den Sarah-Wank-Nicht-Move macht und sagt, wir verstehen uns als politische Bewegung, aber wir haben vor allem erst mal TikTok-Accounts. So, dann kriegt man ja vielleicht durchaus was auf die Beine.
Und man sollte sich nicht zu sehr jetzt gleich in die nächste Partei flüchten. Also jetzt da jetzt darauf zu hoffen, dass man bei den Linken sofort unterkommt und da alles gut macht. Wenn man das auf regionaler Ebene macht und da Kooperation macht, glaube ich, kann das sinnvoll sein. Aber sonst ist da ja auch erst mal so viel zu tun. Also die Linke muss ja erst mal an den Punkt kommen, wo man sagt, Dietmar Bartsch darf nie mehr ein Interview geben. Oder wie wird man eigentlich Carola Rakete wieder los? Also bis diese Fragen nicht geklärt sind, sollte man da wirklich tunlichstes Vermeiden, sich zu sehr anzudocken.
Nein, also das wird sich schon finden. Politische Kräfte landen irgendwann im Parlament, wenn die Zeit dafür reif ist. Man kann sich wenn dann zu früh organisieren, aber nicht zu spät. Also da die Mobilisierung kann man schon nutzen. Und jetzt erstmal ist wichtig, programmatisch wie was ist deren Initialzündung? Und dieser Text auf dieser Webseite Zeit für was Neues, 4.2024.de. Ich lese mal nur die Highlights vor, die jetzt für mich interessant sind. Also schon ganz oben Krankenhauskonzerne, Gewinne, Rücken der Beschäftigten, Milliardengeschäft, Zerstörung der Natur, letzter Cent aus ihren Mietern herauspressen, Milliardäre immer reicher. Das sind so die Hashtags. Wir haben Konflikte. Wer sich weigert, die Reichen zur Kasse zu bitten, lässt im Ergebnis die breite Bevölkerung bezahlen. Genau, das kriegt man dann auch noch. Also dafür Argumente zu finden, die die Leute wirklich interessieren. Ich will noch mal daran erinnern, allein auszurechnen, wie viel Vermögen man braucht, um auf dreifaches durchschnittliches Monatsgehalt netto zu kommen. Und dann ist die Antwort zwei Millionen Euro. Also sowas schockiert Leute, wenn sie es hören. Genau, sowas schockiert einfach, dass man mit zwei Millionen schon dreifach über dem Netto einkommen liegt, ohne jemals wieder arbeiten zu müssen. Also mit solchen Inhalten kann man glaube ich TikTok gut füttern. Das wird der Algorithmus sehr kutieren. Wir haben doch alle ein Recht auf ein gutes, selbstbestimmtes Leben, frei von Abschiedsängsten und Armut. Genau, dass ich gegen ein System zu wehren, das immer wieder Gewinne und Verlierer produziert, die Gleichheit der Menschen systematisch untergräbt und uns mit voller Wucht in die Klimakrise katapultiert, finden sich die Grünen zunehmend damit ab, den Status quo zu verwalten. Wir merken von Tag zu Tag deutlicher, dass es dringend eine politische Kraft braucht, die Schluss damit macht, wie aktuell Politik gemacht wird. Nun ist es so, immer wenn jemand kommt und gegen Superreiche argumentiert, hat man sofort so eine Karin Prim, die irgendwie bei Land sitzt und sagt, naja, der Porsche und so. Ja, also es wird so belächelt. Und dann würde ich sagen, lasst euch mal belächeln, denn es lachen ja und lächeln nur die Leute, die die Millionen haben. Alle anderen so, what, echt, wirklich? Krass, wusste ich gar nicht. Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Dann fragt man so Siri, zwei Milliarden Euro durch vier Prozent Rendite, 6.000 Euro im Monat? Krass. Ja, also ich würde jetzt sagen, all das, was bisher als, so kommt man nie ins Parlament, ihr werdet ja belächelt und so weiter. Nein, das ist jetzt die Schwungmasse. Immer wenn jemand daneben sitzt und über euch lächelt, ist das Futter. Dann wird der Tank gerade aufgefüllt. Weil Martin Huber kann zwar irgendwie im Fernsehen sitzen und lächeln, aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass Leute, die Lanz Sendungen gucken, wenn sie abends und so weiter auch lächeln, sondern diese Autosuggestion kann man ja Martin Huber und alle einfach durchgehen lassen.
Und das gilt auch gegenüber den verbliebenen Parteikollegen, die dann keine Parteikollegen mehr sind. Ich will hier mal vorlesen, jemand, der in den Bundestag gekommen ist, Max Lux heißt er, der ist auch so ein Shooting Star der Grünen und der hat sich dann bei Instagram dazu geäußert, dass die jungen Grünen jetzt den Abgang machen. Heute sind zu viele junge Menschen von der Politik der Ampelkoalition enttäuscht und an mancher Stelle sind sie das auch zu Recht. Aber ich frage mich, brauchen wir nicht gerade diese Gefühle, Analysen und Stimmen als kritisches Korrektiv? Lebt Politik und Partei nicht von Unterschiedlichkeit und auch von Streit? Die Grüne Jugend ist ein unabhängiger linker Verband und der Jugendverband von Bündnis 90 die Grünen. Das ist natürlich ein Spagat, aber ein Spagat, den wir mehr denn je mit Debatten, Kritik und Zusammenhalt füllen müssen. Darum habe ich Verständnis für den Unmut des grünen Jugendvorstandes, aber nicht für den Weg der grünen Jugend den Rücken zu kehren. Es braucht mehr denn je eine starke grüne Jugend, eine, die uns im Parlament auch kritisiert. Eine, die junge Menschen begeistert, eine, die junge Menschen befähigt, selbst zu denken und ihnen nicht jeden Satz vorkaut. Er will eigentlich nur eine Feigenblatt-Organisation haben, die auch mal böse guckt, mal ein Selfie aufnimmt und den Zeigefinger erhoben hat. So geht es aber eigentlich mit der Flüchtlingspolitik nicht. Aber sonst wollen wir in unserer professionellen Arbeit nicht gestört werden. Und es ist interessant, wie man dann die Kommentare darunter hat stehen lassen. Da ist dann jemand, der heißt OswaldsAlterEgo. Der ist wohl mit ihm befreundet gewesen. Er hat auch ein reales Profil da bei Instagram, habe ich mir angesehen. Und der schreibt dann darunter, an mancher Stelle sind sie das auch zu Recht. Also er zitiert das nochmal. Schon mal darüber nachgedacht, dass es diese unglaubliche Arroganz ist, die die Leute von euch wegtreibt. Ich kenne dich jetzt auch schon fast zehn Jahre und habe miterlebt, wie aus dem politisch ungebildeten, aber idealistischen Mäxchen ein stromlinienförmiger Bundestagskarrierist wurde, der Grund für Augen verdrehen und Spott hinter vorgehaltene Hand für die eigene lokale Parteijugend wurde. Und genau diese Stimmung, die hier geschildert wurde, also dass man hinter vorgehaltene Hand, und mit mir sprechen ja Leute hinter vorgehaltene Hand, weil ich ja keine Kontakte zu wichtigen Leuten habe. Aber genau das ist es eigentlich, was so fundamental da ist. Und weißt du, was ich mir eigentlich wünsche? Dass jetzt, nachdem so viele Landesverbände und so weiter sich dem angeschlossen haben, dass jetzt diese Disruption bei den Jusos stattfindet.
Auf die kommen wir gleich zu sprechen. Die haben nämlich auch Briefe geschrieben. Vorher will ich auch noch ein bisschen vorlesen. Wen hattest du eben vorgelesen? Ich lese Lukas Weber, Landesschatzmeister und Sprecher LAG Bildung Grüne, Baden-Württemberg, den Heidelberg. Macht so ein Ja, der Parteiaustritt, der Bundesvorstand, der Grünen Jugend, bla bla bla. Die Bundespitze der Grünen Jugend hatte nicht mehr im Blick, Praktika-Belösungen für die Sorgen und Fragen junger Menschen wie Rente, Klima, Ausbildung und bezahlbares Wohnen zu formulieren. Sie hat sich in abstrakter Systemkritik und abstruser Klassenkampf-Rhetorik verloren.
Ist mir nicht einmal aufgefallen. Ich hatte diesen Kommentar auch gelesen und dachte nochmal, ja, ich bin ja bei so Festivals oder bei Vorträgen und spreche dann selbstverständlich oft abstrakt über gewisse Themen, zum Beispiel Kapitalismus. Aber wenn man mit den Leuten spricht, die zum Beispiel bei der Grünen Jugend organisiert sind oder die zumindest dem Sympathie nahestehen, dann sind das alles Leute, die so sehr mit beiden Beinen auf dem Boden stehen. Das sind Leute, die sich engagieren ehrenamtlich. Das sind Leute, die entweder selbst schon arbeiten oder bald arbeiten werden müssen und die nicht in irgendeiner Weise sagen, ich lebe im Elfenbeinturm und gebe mich der kritischen Theorie hin und mach sonst nix. Das sind alles Leute, die sehr genau wissen, wie man auch organisiert. Denn diese Festivals oder was es da gibt, die werden auch Camping-Ausflüge, da bin ich jetzt nicht vertreten, aber das wird ja alles von diesen Leuten organisiert. Das heißt, das sind Leute, die wissen ganz genau, wie irgendwas ist und die stehen nicht da und sagen, ich muss jetzt noch Lukas und Marx heute lesen, ich kann mich um sonst nichts kümmern. Aber die lesen auch vielleicht Lukas und Marx. Das ist ein intellektueller Vorteil, den sie gegenüber diesen Leuten, die sich da äußern, haben.
Du hast ja auch eine sehr nette Replik geschrieben. Renate Künast hat ja auf die Meldung, auch die grüne Jugend tritt da jetzt aus.
Du hast da Clips, oder?
Ich habe gleich Clips. Sie hat ja diesen Tweet, am Eingang der Humboldt-Uni steht ein Zitat von Karl Marx, die Philosophen haben die Welt nur unterschiedlich interpretiert, es kommt darauf an, sie zu verändern.
Das war ihr Kommentar jetzt zu der grünen Jugend.
Da hast du ja drüber geschrieben, na Karl Marx wollte einfach nur Werbung für Renate Künast machen.
Ja und zwar in der Humboldt-Uni. Also ich finde allein das so toll, dass sie, man gibt ja beim Zitat eine Quelle an, dann würde man ja eigentlich sagen, Marx Feuerbach-Thesen, da wo es steht. Sie gibt einfach das an, als hätte Marx das höchstpersönlich in die Humboldt-Uni geschrieben.
In jeder steht das auch an der Uni. Ich brauche da keine weitere Quelle. Gibt es da einen Kontext?
Also ich finde es wunderbar.
Nein, Künast wurde dann noch so ein bisschen gefragt. Jetzt hast du ja eben schon die Reaktionen bei Twitter auf den einen. Ja, ich habe dich zehn Jahre beobachtet, du bist durchgeschliffen. Renate Künast ist ja nun seit einem Jahrhundert in diesem Betrieb. Und das Ausmaß, in dem man dann doch sagen muss, dass Richard David Brecht hatte recht. Man kommt da rein, alles waren Maxisten. Olaf Scholz, der hat ja Texte geschrieben. 40 Jahre später ruft der Banker an, will seine 10 Millionen und du weißt deine Staatsverwaltung an, das Geld jetzt zu überweisen. Also am Ende werden alles runde, durchgeschliffene Kieselsteine, die natürlich super toll ins Flussbett passen, so dass einfach das Kapital da einmal drüber rutschen kann. Und Renate Kühner ist wirklich am Ende ihrer Kräfte, sage ich jetzt mal so, gerade noch im Bundestag, die eigene Ministerkarriere schon 20 Jahre zurück. Denkt jetzt, nee, ich muss die auch noch mal provozieren. Ich will jetzt nicht schweigen, ich muss jetzt auch noch mal draufhauen. Die Grünen Jugend gehen, ich lasse das nicht den Söder machen, ich mache das selbst. So und dann hören wir nur drei kurze Ausschnitte. Sie möchte sich jetzt auf die Probleme der Menschen konzentrieren.
Ich glaube, viel stärker als in der Vergangenheit wird es und muss es jetzt um den Punkt gehen, dass wir tatsächlich uns angucken, was sind die Sorgen der Menschen und darauf gehen. Und ich sage von der Situation der Kinder bis zur Sicherung von Jobs oder Schaffung der neuen Jobs.
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, wann sie angerufen wurde und vielleicht war sie auch krank, aber diese brüchige Stimme und sie sagt dann, ich will mich jetzt irgendwie... Die Menschen stehen gerade da, deine eigenen, und sagen dir, was ihre Probleme sind. Und das wirst du vom Tisch, weil du dich jetzt um die Probleme der Menschen kümmern willst.
Welcher Menschen? Welch, meinst du, sie geht zum Gartenzaun jetzt und fragt, na?
Sie hat auch jetzt seit 20 Jahren nur bewirtete Termine und so weiter. Sie weiß offenbar nicht, was die Probleme der Menschen sind. Menschen sagen es ihr.
Die haben es ja aufgeschrieben. Die Grüne Jugend hat es ja. Also diese neue Organisation hat es ja aufgeschrieben.
Das ist wirklich grotesk.
Sie haben bei den jungen Leuten gerade in den letzten Wahlen, sie haben es selber angesprochen, kaum noch einen Bein an den Boden bekommen. Und jetzt tritt auch noch ihre Grüne Jugend sogar aus, aus der Partei. Ich hätte da gerne noch mal ein, zwei konkrete Vorschläge von Ihnen, wie Sie da wieder Boden gewinnen wollen.
Na ja, das mit dem Vorstand der Grüne Jugend, erst mal treten nur die aus, ist, glaube ich, auf einem ganz anderen Blatt geschrieben. Die haben wir in der letzten Zeit öfter erlebt. Für meine Begriffe, dass sie nicht reaktivitätstauglich sind und irgendwie so ein Klassensystem Sozialismus aufbauen wollen, da wundere ich mich nicht drüber und da weine ich jetzt auch nicht. Und ich glaube, dass es viele junge Menschen in und um die Partei rumgeht, die sich jetzt vielleicht freier engagieren können bei den Grünen, um wirklich gestalten wollen, muss ich so sagen.
Ein Klassensystem Sozialismus? Ich dachte immer, Sozialismus ist ohne Klassen.
Ja, egal. Marx hat gesagt. Der Genie-Koeffizient für ein Vermögen ist in Deutschland 0,8. Das heißt, es lodert, egal in welcher empirischen Ausprägung. Das ist wie das Mittelmeer hat die Temperatur von 38 Grad. Da fängt man nicht an, irgendwie mit der Alge zu verhandeln oder so was. Oder irgendeine spezifische Beobachtung einer Koralle oder so. Sondern, nein, das Meer ist einfach 38 Grad und das verdunstet dann. Und dann zieht das 100 Kilometer und dann regnet das halt runter. Dann wird einfach Hochwasser in Österreich und so. Also diese Idee von die Jungen, ah ja, keine Ahnung, die sollen mal weg und so weiter. Ich weiß, wo es langgeht. Und die machen ja nur irgendeinen sozialistischen Klassenkampf oder wie auch immer. Ich verstehe einfach gar nicht. Also klar, wir machen auch immer die Witze. Oder sehr viele junge Männer machen die Witze. Das warnt mich davor, wenn ich ein alter, weiser Mann werde und so. Offenbar scheint es wirklich, selbst wenn du Politikerin bist, dein Leben lang und sie aber nun wirklich in jedem Hof kennt, die bäuerlichen Schicksale und so weiter und so fort. Und trotzdem, zack, wird einfach ausgeblendet. Das verstehe ich nicht. Also ich habe dafür kein Verständnis. Das kann natürlich sein. Wir haben ja Rüdger Brechmann, der uns sagte, in diesem Spitzenamt kommt man überhaupt nur an, wenn man ganz früh schon zeigt, dass man keine Rücksicht nimmt auf die Sozialität, in der man ist, weil man sofort das mediale abstrahierte Spiel Ich will ja Größeres.
Ja, man muss ja dieses Statement, was ich da eben von Max Lux vorgelesen habe, so verstehen, dass er jetzt der Führungsspitze signalisiert. Noch ist es wohl zu früh, aber irgendwann, wenn ihr jemanden braucht, ich bin derjenige, der über die eigenen Leute drüber steigt und sagt, aber warum liegt ihr auch hier rum und werdet das tun, was zu tun ist. Der signalisiert das jetzt schon in jungen Jahren und wird dann auch in 30 Jahren da sitzen und nochmal andere beschimpfen, wenn es erforderlich ist, wie die Künast das jetzt macht.
Was ja nur bedeutet, in dem Moment, wo wir junge Menschen sehen, die widerstehen, ist das doch die beste Auszeichnung dafür, denen jetzt das Schicksal aller in die Hand zu legen.
Eigentlich schon.
Also wäre noch niemand, wäre es besser geeignet.
Lass uns mal nochmal gerade den Clip zu Ende hören.
Wir können nicht länger hinnehmen, dass es gerade keine relevante linke Partei in Deutschland gibt, die den Menschen wieder Hoffnung macht.
Deshalb haben wir uns als Bundesvorstand der Grünen Jugend entschieden, nicht erneut zu kandidieren und bei den Grünen auszutreten.
Wir beginnen etwas Neues. Wir werden jetzt das tun, was notwendig ist.
Wir machen uns auf, weil wir mutige Politik machen wollen, die immer auf der Seite der Menschen steht. Eine starke linke Kraft, die Armut und Ausgrenzung ernst nimmt und sich dagegen organisiert. Die wollen wir aufbauen.
Wir hören nicht auf, Politik zu machen. Wir fangen jetzt erst richtig an.
Bist du dabei?
Armut und Ausgrenzung sind die Themen. Ich würde sagen, man muss auch noch mal über die Armut hinausgehen, über all die sprechen, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen und nicht besonders gut verdienen, die nicht direkt als arm zu bezeichnen sind, aber die nun auch ein Schicksal haben, dass sie irgendwo ihre Miete abdrücken müssen und dann fast nichts mehr für den Monat haben, wo all diese Spaßfaktoren, die das Leben auch zu bieten haben, einfach wegfallen, weil man es sich nicht mehr leisten kann. Und auch diese Perspektivlosigkeit, die man hat, ob man jetzt Azubi ist oder Student ist, sei mal dahingestellt, das muss auch nochmal richtig adressiert werden, glaube ich. Und auch nochmal diese Verzweiflung der jungen Männer, die ja definitiv da ist, dass die auch nochmal in einer Weise aufgegriffen wird, dass es progressiv ist und nicht so wie bei der AfD dann ist, dass man auch da ein gutes Angebot macht, das für alle dann sehr einladend ist. Und dann, glaube ich, ist da eigentlich ein sehr, sehr großes Potenzial da. Und die Demografie spielt ihnen ja irgendwann zu, sagen wir mal.
Ja, also ich, genau, das ist der Zeitgeist, den wir da gehört haben. Wir haben ihn auch noch gesehen, also das Video kann man sich ja ansehen. Er widerspricht so ein bisschen den Sehgewohnheiten. Sehr viele Leute werden es sehr einfach fallen, auf Twitter und so weiter darüber zu lachen. Da werden sich auch große Ansammlungen von wem auch immer finden, die dann sagen, ja, das ist alles lächerlich. Nur, es ist halt trotzdem der Zeitgeist. In dem Fall würde ich sagen, man muss ihn nicht mal besonders betonen, sondern ja, so sehen halt junge Menschen aus.
Die müssen auch nicht 60-Jährigen gefallen. Also das ist ja auch noch mal klar zu machen. Man muss ja nicht diesen Konsens immer herstellen, wenn man Jugendorganisation jetzt ist, sondern sie sind ja, die sind ja nicht in irgendeiner Weise verbohrt. Verbohrt sind ja die Leute, die in irgendwelchen Talkshows sitzen und gerne wollen, dass Politiker immer genauso aussehen, wie sie aussahen oder sowas.
Alles, was jetzt aus der Sehgewohnheit ausbricht, ist gut. Denn wir sind satt gesehen.
Lass mich noch ein Beispiel bringen, nämlich das war doch sehr erstaunlich, wie Hofreiter sich dazu geäußert hat.
Ihren Rücktritt nimmt man in der Grünen Fraktion in Berlin betont gelassen.
Es treten ein paar Menschen aus der Grünen Jugend aus. Wir werden dadurch einen neuen Bundesvorstand bei der Grünen Jugend bekommen. Ich freue mich auf die Zusammenarbeit mit dem neuen Grünen Bundesvorstand. Ich bin mir sicher, dass sich da gute Leute finden werden.
Es treten ein paar Leute aus, als sei das irrelevant, dass das der Vorstand war.
Er sitzt bei Lanz und regt sich darüber auf, dass er von der CSU Feuer kriegt. Und wundert sich jetzt, warum es vielleicht von uns z.B. blöd gefunden wird, wenn er selber derjenige mit der Knarre ist, der das Feuer auf seine eigenen Leute schießt.
Ich bin ehrlich gesagt ganz froh, dass er nicht gesagt hat, die jungen Grünen, die da jetzt ausgetreten sind, verbreiten Kreml-Propaganda. Das wäre noch das nächste, was kommen kann. Was eine sehr interessante Personalie ist bei diesen Austritten, ist, dass ja, wie es hier mit Leuten zu tun haben, die zwar gewisse Ämter hatten, aber nicht Mandate im Bundestag, die jetzt da wegfallen. Also man muss nicht jetzt jemand auf 10.000 Euro verzichten. Aber hier, das ist ein erstaunlicher Fall. Ivi-Mai Müller hat sich dem auch angeschlossen. Wir hören jetzt mal in ihr Vorstellungsvideo rein.
Ich hatte richtig Hoffnung. 2020 bin ich als eine der jüngsten Abgeordneten in den Hamburger Landtag eingezogen. Ich wollte die Hoffnung meiner Generation ins Parlament tragen. Wir wollten unsere Zukunft selbst in die Hand nehmen. Wir wollten alles verändern. Heute, viereinhalb Jahre später, hat meine Generation im großen Stil die Hoffnung verloren. Inflation, Rechtsdruck und Klima. Eine Krise jagt die andere. Das ist kein Zufall, das ist politisches Versagen. Es braucht eine Politik, die Abstiegsängste nimmt und Gerechtigkeit schafft. Eine Politik, die nicht immer wieder Kompromisse mit den Reichen und Konzernen macht.
Ja, mal bis dahin. Und dann geht das noch eine Weile so weiter. Also hier ist auch jemand, die sagt, ich könnte jetzt eine weitere Karriere machen. Sie will es aber nicht, weil sie mit anderen Vorstellungen da reingegangen ist und dachte tatsächlich, sie könne etwas bewegen. Und das finde ich ein sehr, sehr gutes Beispiel dafür, wie es sicherlich vielen geht. Und man kann nur hoffen, dass sich da einige dem anschließen.
Unter der Domain Eintreten für würde.de gibt es ein ähnlich, also ein sehr konkretes Anliegen in der SPD. Denn dieser Asylkompromiss geht ja nicht nur den jungen Grünen zu weit, sondern auch der SPD. 10.000 Unterstützer bislang, Tenor. Erinnerung noch mal an die Grundwerte der Menschenwürde. Solidarität, Freiheit, Gerechtigkeit, Grundgesetz, europäische Integration. Denn nicht nur richtet sich das ja konkret gegen Menschen, sondern man baut ja auch Europa zurück. Junge Leute hätten gerne ein Europa, das funktioniert. Wenn Islamismus bekämpft werden soll, wofür alle sind, dann bitte richtig. Zielgerichte nicht mit der Gießkanne. Wir müssen eigentlich auch diese Argumente mal zurückgeben. Beim Bürgergeld, Gießkanne und so. Anders müsste man hier eigentlich auch keine Gießkanne. Wir können jetzt nicht alle 20 Millionen...
Alle Kräften zu machen, das ist ja eine Gießkannenpolitik.
Völlig bescheuert, genau. Kritik an der SPD-Führung ganz konkret wegen Grenzkontrollen, Zurückweisungen, Inhaftierungen, den ganzen Kram. Dann wurde Olaf Scholz gefragt, was er davon hält. Hatte er das schon mitbekommen? Er lässt sich dann wie folgt zitieren. T-Online schreibt, Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz sieht in dem offenen Brief, der die Wahrung der Menschenwürde in der Migrationspolitik fordert, keinen Widerspruch zu seinem Handeln. Der Bundeskanzler fühle sich viel mehr, Zitat, in seinem Kurs bestätigt, sagte Regierungssprecher Steffen Hebestreit.
Das ist die Arroganz der Macht.
So, woraufhin Lili Blautz Zun, wir kennen sie ja. Sie ist ja im Grunde die Sperrspitze der Internetaktivität, was auch immer. Sie schreibt dann, das ist so frech. Wir bestärken nicht in Großbuchstaben den eingeschlagenen Kurs, sondern appellieren mit unserem Brief eindringlich an unsere SPD-Spitze. Verlasst diesen Kurs. So, man kann sich nicht gegen alle anlegen. Also man kann einfach nicht in Kampf gegen alle führen. Das ist völlig bescheuert. Ich würde auch sagen, Jusos, nehmt euch ein Herz. Da wartet doch was auf euch.
Ich denke auch.
Die Schulterschlüsse müssen jetzt sein. Das ist ja wirklich grotesk.
Denn gruselig ist, wie sich das alles entwickelt. Und ich will einen letzten Clip spielen. Boris Palma hatte man schon ein bisschen vergessen, länger Zeit nichts gehört. War aber jetzt doch wieder häufiger im Interview und hat beim Bayerischen Rundfunk gesprochen. Gerade nachdem Nouripour und Ricarda Lang zurückgetreten waren. Und wir hören jetzt mal diesen Tonfall. Wir kennen ihn. Der poltert los. Der ist aus der Partei ausgetreten, weil er das alles nicht mehr aushalten kann. Dann sind alle viel zu vogue und was auch immer.
Die Spitze zieht sich zurück. Treten Sie jetzt wieder ein?
Na, ich bin ja nicht ausgetreten wegen eines Streits mit Nouripour. Im Gegenteil, das ist ein langjähriger Freund von mir. Aber sehen Sie mal bitte nach, dass ich diese aktuellen Entwicklungen auch nicht kommentieren möchte. Das wäre einfach schlechter still. Wenn man austritt, dann sollte man nachher nicht von der Seitenauslinie gute Ratschläge haben. Das gehört sich nicht.
Ziemlich versöhnlich. Wir hören noch weiter.
Ich glaube, es ist gar nicht so aktuell. Was müsste denn sich inhaltlich ändern bei den Grünen, damit sie einen Eintritt zumindest wieder erwägen?
Na gut, ich bin im Herzen Gröner, weil ich Ökologe bin. Und das bleibe ich auch für meine Begriffe. Allerdings sind da in den letzten zehn Jahren ganz neue Setzungen, Haltungen, Auffassungen hinzugekommen, die ich gar nicht kannte. Als ich begonnen habe, Politik zu machen. Die werden gewöhnlich mit dem Begriff Editätspolitik umschrieben. Und mir würde es schon reichen, wenn man die diskutieren könnte. Wenn das nicht dogmatisch gehandhabt würde, so wenn da abweichende Auffassungen in der Partei willkommen wären. Das war zuletzt nicht mehr der Fall. Der Streit darüber hat letztlich dazu geführt, dass ich gesagt habe, da gehöre ich nicht mehr hin. Seither bin ich politisch heimatlos. Ich bedauere das. Aber ich wäre eigentlich gerne für ökologische Anliegen in einer Partei. Und da bin ich überzeugt, dass die Grünen da für die Richtigen sind.
Mit anderen Worten, er will zurück und jetzt versuchen die Grünen nicht, ihn davon abzuhalten.
Also der Habeckismus wird da nicht im Weg stehen.
Nein.
Die Kompromisse und die pragmatischen Herangehensweisen werden alle.
Ja, und die haben ja jetzt freie Bahn, weil die, die sie kritisieren, werden ja entweder kalt gestellt oder haben selbstständig das Schiff verlassen. Und jetzt kann er kommen.
Ich würde sagen, wir schließen daran mal an, mit dem schwarzen Loch, das jetzt kommt, dass man als Schwungmasse nehmen muss, in deren Sicht nicht dagegen ankämpfen, also ja klar gegen März ankämpfen und so weiter, aber nicht im Gemütszustand, sondern sich schon mal, ja das kommt jetzt, wir müssen es gleich spielerisch sehen. Da liegen Chancen drin, wir werden Memes produzieren, ohne Ende so ungefähr müsste man jetzt als junger Mensch daran. Denn wir haben ja Berichte bekommen, dass es nicht gut steht um Europa, alle machen sich Sorgen. Die EU-Kommission hat Mario Draghi beauftragt und er ist ja nun als ehemaliger Regierungschef von Italien, sehr großes, wichtiges Land, Chefe der EZB, der Europäischen Zentralbank, gute Einblicke würde ich sagen, gute Kontakte, wenn er sagt, ich schreibe hier so einen Bericht, hat er alle Gesprächspartner, die er braucht und er hat mal ein Preisschild an sein, wir werden ihn nur punktuell kurz lesen, an sein Draghi-Report gehängt.
Bei den Zukunftstechnologien sind die USA vorne. Sie haben die großen Internetfirmen. Bei der künstlichen Intelligenz investieren sie und China mehr. Und dann schwächelt der Motor Europas Deutschland. Exemplarisch die Automobilindustrie, die von China bei der Elektromobilität abgehängt wird. Der Bericht ist voll von solchen bitteren Wahrheiten. Europa hat über seine Verhältnisse gelebt, dazu kommt die Energiekrise. Jährliche Investitionen von rund 800 Milliarden Euro brauche es jetzt, um Tech-Industrien zu fördern, eine europäische Verteidigungsindustrie aufzubauen und die digitale Infrastruktur zu verbessern. Nur so werde Europa wieder wettbewerbsfähig.
So 800 Milliarden und es ist nicht Adam Tewes, der hier was fordert, sondern es ist Draghi, der sagt, ich habe es ausgerechnet. Und ich bin der beste Finanzmathematiker dieses Kontinents.
Und der ja auch aufzeigt in diesem Bericht, dass diese tolle Wettbewerbspolitik in Europa dazu geführt hat, dass viele Dinge zu günstig sind, dass man also gar nicht richtig Profit daraus schlagen kann, dass die sich eher gegenseitig kaputt machen, wie wir das auch schon mal bei Kampf der Nationen gelesen haben. Patrick hat es geschrieben. Draghi bestätigt es jetzt mit seinem Report nochmal, dass das wahnsinnig kontraproduktiv ist, wenn man eine EU hat, in der sich die eigenen Leute, also die eigenen Mitgliedstaaten, nochmal im Konkurrenzkampf richtig fertig machen sollen. Das schildert er jetzt alles klar.
Hier sind so ein paar Sachen fehlspezifiziert. Und jetzt könnte man wieder punktuell so reingehen und sagen, die Autoindustrie, die neue Energie, die Atomkraftwerke, was auch immer. Wo knarrt es denn da?
Oder, und das ist nur ein kleiner Spruch noch von seiner Pressekonferenz, Europas Werte sind Wohlstand, Gleichheit, Freiheit, Frieden und Demokratie. Wenn Europa diese Werte nicht mehr erhalten kann, dann hat es seine Existenzberechtigung verloren.
Also die Existenzberechtigung Europas am Ende ist alles nur noch Kampf der Nationen. Alle Parteien kämpfen so gegeneinander. Es gibt gar nicht so das Deutsche, nee, lieber substanzielle Schädigungen von allem. Hauptsache wir kriegen hier so einen kleinen Ministerposten oder sowas. Und Europa eben auch. Also die Daseinsberechtigung steht so ein bisschen in Frage in diesem Bericht. Ich bin jetzt nur diesen Punkt nachgegangen. 800 Milliarden, wo kriegen wir die her? Der Draghi-Bericht sagt private Ersparnisse, also das kennen wir ja von März. Die Leute haben doch Geld, sollen sie doch zur Bank bringen, damit die Aktien kaufen und so weiter. Das finanziert dann die Unternehmen. Kapitalmarkt Union kann man ja mal vervollständigen, sodass dann der grenzüberschreitende Investitionskram gemacht werden darf. Also das ist ein großes Entgegenkommen für die Leute, die sehr viel Geld haben. Pensionsfonds extra gründen, die es bisher noch nicht gibt. Deswegen ja auch dieses ganzen deutschen Ansinnen, dieses Geld, das die Leute irgendwann mal brauchen, jetzt schnell der Wirtschaft schon mal zu geben. Dann hat er so einen Punkt wie der Belebung der Verbriefung. Da denke ich mir natürlich, warte mal, was haben wir nicht diese Regularien gegen Verbriefung eingeführt, weil wir das irgendwann nicht mehr durchschaut hatten, was da passiert und dann gab es so einen Wasserkopf an Finanzprodukten und so weiter. Nein, soll jetzt wieder erleichtert werden. Ja, auch unter ferner liefen läuft dann gemeinsame Schuldenemissionen, so wie das ja bei Next Generation EU schon mal war. Und als letztes öffentliche private Partnerschaften. Ich habe dann Claude nochmal gefragt, ich habe dann Claude nochmal gefragt, ließ nochmal alles für mich. Private Vermögen und Superreichtum kann man den nicht vereinnahmen, sodass man dann öffentlich finanziert, was ja an Bedarfen offenkundig bei 800 Milliarden klar geworden ist. Claude sagt mir, der Bericht konzentriert sich nicht spezifisch auf die Besteuerung oder Nutzung von sehr großem Privatvermögen oder Superreichtum zur Finanzierung der vorgeschlagenen Investitionen. Der Fokus liegt eher darauf, die allgemeinen Ersparnisse der Haushalte und institutionelle Investoren wie Pensionsfonds usw. zu nutzen. Also jeder behält sein privates Vermögen, aber Vermögensverwalter investieren das in eine gewisse Richtung. Großes Problem, weil dann baut man und finanziert nur das, was dann auch private Rendite. Würde ich jetzt sagen, bei der öffentlichen Infrastruktur, Investitionsbedarfen in solchen Größenordnungen, also ja, hier finden auch sehr viele industrielle Investitionen sind von Nöten. Die kann man natürlich dann so privat wie wir es bisher machten. Aber es gibt ja so ein paar öffentliche, keine Ahnung, warum muss jetzt die Mobilität 9 Euro mehr kosten pro Monat, also ein 58 Euro Ticket statt ein 9 Euro Ticket. Das wäre ja irgendwie alles cooler. Daraufhin, und ich will noch kurz anmerken, das war Anfang des Monats 800 Milliarden stehen im Raum. Ende des Monats, man hört nichts davon. Also es war so ein Eintages Nachrichten Thema, dass Draghi gesagt hat, die Daseinsberechtigung der Europäischen Union ist nicht mehr gegeben. Hat ein Preisscheld, können wir nicht bezahlen. Also wird Clemens Fuest gefragt vom IFO-Institut, was sollen wir jetzt aus diesem Draghi-Report herauslesen für uns? Und dann haben wir schon gehört, was ist die Kernaufgabe?
Die Kernaufgabe ist hier nicht mehr Geld bereitzustellen, sondern die Kernaufgabe ist Binnenmarkt vertiefen und Bürokratie abbauen.
Glauben Sie, das wird gelingen?
Das muss gelingen.
Das ist auch sehr gut, ne? Er sagt, die Kernaufgabe ist Bürokratie abbauen, sodass die Menschen, die Geld haben, ungehindert auf dem Markt auftreten können und nicht der Staat noch irgendwie kommt und sagt, erwerten ja so Wünsche. Daraufhin ist Ingo Zambaronis Rückfrage nicht. Hören Sie mal.
Ist das sinnvoll?
Ja, macht das Sinn. Kommen wir dadurch wieder zur Daseitsberechtigung der Europäischen Union, sondern nein, die Rückfrage lautet natürlich Binnenmarkt vertiefen und Bürokratie abbauen.
Glauben Sie, das wird gelingen?
Das muss gelingen. Ich glaube, das wird nicht gelingen, wenn man das Pferd jetzt von hinten aufzürmt und beim Geld beginnt. Viele Leute, die mehr Geld wollen, die mehr Schulden wollen, werden jetzt sagen, schau mal, Mario Draghi hat mehr Schulden empfohlen. Das wäre ganz falsch, denn dann würde man sich um diese beiden, aus meiner Sicht, wichtigen Aufgaben, Bürokratie, Abbau und Vertiefung des europäischen Binnenmarktes, Nutzung unserer Wachstumsmaschine, die wir hier zum Glück haben in Europa, auch mehr handeln mit Mittländern. Das würde man dann vernachlässigen. Dann würde man nur darüber streiten, wer bekommt das Geld?
Ja, das wäre ja noch schlimmer.
Das ist das Rätsel des Juganauten.
Wenn man noch streiten würde, wer das Geld bekommt, dass das nicht Deutschland alleine dann bekommt oder so. Das wäre natürlich ganz dramatisch. Es ist so verrückt, dass man auch glaubt, dass allein Bürokratie, Abbau, Geld in einer Weise zur Verfügung stellt, damit die Wirtschaft angekurbelt wird. Das ist ja nicht der Fall.
Ich will ausdrücklich sagen, bei den Geschichten, die ich so höre zum Thema Bürokratie, würde ich auch sagen, alles abbauen. Nur, das ist hier nicht gemeint.
Ja, das interessante ist ja auch, dass diese Leute durchaus für Bürokratie zu haben sind, wenn sie ihnen nutzt. Es ist ja nicht ein Kapitalinteresse, dass es da gibt, das einfach sagt, möglichst wenig Bürokratie, sondern die sind ja sofort dabei, wenn eine bürokratische Hürde den Konkurrenten in die Knie zwingt und sie selbst davon profitieren können.
Genau, da wird der Markt geschlossen und ich finde, das Bürokratieabbauargument kann man sowieso nicht gelten lassen, wenn dieselben Leute, die das fordern, alle Bundespolizisten an die Grenze beordern, damit man durchzählt, wie viele Migranten zwischen Dänemark und Deutschland hin und her reisen. Ja. Also das ist Bürokratie und da bin ich auch dafür, die sofort abzubauen. Clemens Fuest hat noch so einen zweiten Punkt zum Thema Geld.
Das ist für ihn jetzt nicht die zentrale Rolle, haben wir ja gehört, aber trotzdem will er noch was zum Geld sagen, denn die Gefahr ist schon, dass die Politik sich jetzt auf die Schulden konzentriert und sagt, wir brauchen mehr Geld auf europäischer Ebene und da werden die Mitgliedsstaaten sagen Nein, das möchten wir nicht.
Ich würde jetzt ja neuerdings sagen, die Gefahr ist nicht, dass die Politik sofort den Schulden geht, sondern dass ich es von den Superreichen holen will. Wir sind sozusagen eine Stufe zu weit weg. Ich finde, Clemens Fuest sollte dann schon Butter bei die Fische, weil er gefragt wurde, müssen jetzt die Superreichen endlich bezahlen, immerhin gehörte ihnen die Hälfte von allem. Wollen wir das weiter dem demokratischen Prozess entziehen? Nein, die Gefahr ist, dass wir vielleicht Schulden machen, also immer noch Staatsgeld benutzen, statt dieses Superreichevermögen.
Dass die Politik sich jetzt auf die Schulden konzentriert und sagt, wir brauchen mehr Geld auf europäischer Ebene und da werden die Mitgliedstaaten sagen, nein, das möchten wir nicht. Herr Lindner hat ja sich schon skeptisch geäußert. Deshalb könnte man vielleicht zu einer Übereinkunft kommen und sagen, wenn die EU zeigt, Lindner hat sich auch schon skeptisch geäußert, deswegen geht das nicht, ausgeschlossen.
Das ist der eigentliche Tenor, Deutschland will nicht, Schluss.
Dass sie es schafft, Bürokratie abzubauen und ihren Job zu machen.
Das ist so gut, das ist wirklich so dumm. Die EU muss jetzt erstmal in Vorleistung gehen. Die Bevölkerung und die Politik gehen den Superreichen aus dem Weg, bauen die Bürokratie ab, alle Hürden werden beseitigt.
Dann zeigt, dass sie es schafft, Bürokratie abzubauen und ihren Job zu machen, ihre Hausaufgaben zu machen, nämlich den Binnmarkt zu vertiefen. Ich glaube, dann kann man auch über mehr Geld reden. Aber die Investitionsbedarfe sind so hoch, dass das nicht allein mit öffentlichem Geld klappt. Wir müssen private Investoren überzeugen. Die werden wir nicht überzeugen, wenn wir die Bürokratie nicht abbauen. Das kann man durch Geld nicht ersetzen. Insofern...
Ich glaube, er will die Bürokratie abbauen, oder?
Also wir müssen die Superreichen überzeugen, dass sie ihr Geld auch zur Verfügung stellen. Und wir überzeugen sie, indem wir ihnen sagen, wir gehen aus dem Weg, wir bauen die Bürokratie ab, ihr könnt machen, was ihr wollt.
Ja, was ja bedeutet, man muss den Superreichen die Möglichkeit geben, dass sie noch mehr Rendite machen können, dass sie noch mehr passives Einkommen generieren können. Und das funktioniert nur, wenn man gewisse Hürden abbaut. Und dadurch dann, wenn die dann alle angelockt werden, dann hat man bewiesen, dass man erfolgreich arbeitet, die Hausaufgaben gemacht hat. Und dann kann man sogar noch mal Staatsgeld zufließen lassen, wenn sowieso schon alles super läuft.
Ja, wir hören mal hier noch zu Ende.
Das ist Bürokratieabbau und Vertiefung des Binnenmarktes zuerst. Dann sollte man nicht ausschließen, dass man auch über mehr gemeinsame Schulden redet.
Ja, um später dann. Da ich diesen Monat selber mit einem Milliardär über die Oper sprach, erzähl mal. Habe jetzt Kampf gegen die Superreichen.
Du hast einen Milliardär getroffen.
Es gab in einem Museum im Foyer eine Einladung an einen Milliardär, doch an einem Gespräch mit dem Bürgermeister teilzunehmen. Wir alle wissen, die Veranstaltung fand natürlich statt, weil der Milliardär sie wollte. Er ließ sich rufen und hat gesagt, was kann ich Ihnen noch über Stadtplanungen erzählen? Also die Oper ist zu teuer.
Wirklich?
80 Millionen Euro für 1300 Leute. Ich habe ihm dann im direkten Gespräch gesagt, dass das nicht für 8.000, 4.300 Leute ist, sondern das ist das Einzugsgebiet der Welt, was Publikum und Künstler angeht. Hier in Frankfurt ist das Epizentrum dieser Art von Kunst. Mit dieser Art meine ich gestaltende Kunst, Bühnenbild, Musik, nicht nur Bewahrung, sondern auch wirklich es auf die Bühne bringen. Schauspiel, Gesang, alles. Nein, im Vortrag Apfelweinkultur ist auch Kultur. Frankfurt sollte sich mal um die Identität der Stadt kümmern. Dazu gehört eine Pflege der Apfelweinkultur. Mike Joseph hat dann namentlich die Läden genannt, in denen man Apfelwein trinken kann, die in Liegenschaften der Stadt sind. Woraufhin deutlich wurde in dem Gespräch, er hätte gerne eine Subventionierung seiner Olympiade. Ich bin der beste Gastronom der Stadt.
Also es ist jemand, der aus der Privatwirtschaft kommt, aber gerne noch mal ein bisschen mehr Geld hätte von der Stadt.
Das Prinzip ist ja ganz anders.
Weil es noch nicht reicht.
So wie ich das verstanden habe an dem Abend, ist es wie folgt. Superreiche haben zu viel Geld, aber in Deutschland ist ja nichts los. Deswegen kaufen alle einfach nur Immobilien. Die Immobilien hatten lange eine Wertsteigerung. Der Total Return war gut. Sie wussten genau, ich gehe niemals an meine Substanz. Ich bezahle alles aus meiner Rendite. Und meine Rendite, die ich neu investiere, sorgt ihrerseits für Rendite, weil Gebäude werden ja immer teurer. Das war also das perfekte, man sagt dann, Flywheel dazu oder Firewheel oder irgend sowas. Also ein völlig selbstlaufendes System. Man wusste niemals an die Substanz. Dann kam aber der Moment, wo es ausgereizt war. 50% der Stadt bezahlen 50% ihres verfügbaren Honasteinkommens für Miete. Es sind keine höheren Mieten zu erwarten, keine weiteren Käufer, alle sind ausgepresst, Zinswände und so weiter. Gebäude werden in der Finanzierung teurer. Also die Superreichen, die ihre Gebäude cash bezahlen, also von Finanzierungsunkosten befreit sind, können sich nur noch gegenseitig die Gebäude verkaufen. Da liegt aber keine Wertsteigerung drin, denn keiner gönnt ja irgend wem irgendwas. Also Superreiche verkaufen nur an Leute, die es brauchen, teuer, aber nicht untereinander. Da werden die Deals gemacht. So, das heißt, man hat jetzt keinen tollen Total Return mehr, man hat jetzt nur noch die Netto-Mietrendite. Die armen Superreichen sind leider zurückgeworfen bei der Rendite auf das, was Leute mit ihrer Miete leisten können.
Und da muss der Staat jetzt mal helfen.
Und da wir arm sind, ist das nicht viel. Genau. Also muss der Staat jetzt helfen. Wo kommt dieses Geld her? Also die Stadt Frankfurt hat ja ein Kulturbudget von so 230 bis 250 Millionen. Da fällt alles drunter. Sportförderung, hier diese ganzen Konzerte, die so stattfinden und so. Und immer, wenn jemand einen kleinen Bedarf hat und dann hier mal 1000, damit 5000 Euro und so. Aber 80 Millionen für die Oper, für die Schaue, also für die städtischen Bühnen, alle. So und dann mal seine Meinung. Das braucht niemand. Er war dann auch so mutig, mir zu sagen, er hätte eine Oper gesehen und in der Hälfte rausgegangen. Er fand sie belanglos. Und muss das denn sein? Kann man nicht sagen, die Stadt Frankfurt sollte auch mal in die Apfelweinkultur. Apfelweinkultur? Also die Apfelweinkultur ist Gastronomie, das ist Business, das ist nicht Kultur, sondern wenn man Apfelwein trinken will in Frankfurt, geht das. Es gibt Liegenschaften der Stadt, wo günstig vermietet wird und dann sind die Wirt da und servieren dir Apfelwein.
Ja, schlimm genug, wenn das jemand trinken will.
Nicht hier in Frankfurt. Ich bin jetzt auch kein großer Fan, aber es gehört dazu.
Also ich möchte es in meinem Leben nicht mehr trinken müssen.
Naja, und dann war völlig klar, diesen Termin gab es, um an diesem Kulturbudget herumzudoktern.
Na ja, interessant.
Und dann war ich so ein bisschen außer mir, gerade weil ich ja Luja Friedrichs Buch noch im Hinterkopf hatte. Ja. Und die Argumentation, die da so liefen, fand ich nicht nur nicht überzeugend, sondern die aggressive Arroganz, in der es vorgetragen wurde, fand ich auch betrüblich. Denn da sind Leute, die wissen so ein bisschen, was Kultur bedeutet. Die lassen sich nämlich dann vorstellen, fünf Minuten lang, also jetzt ohne Quatsch, da wurde drei Minuten 37 lang vorgestellt, so lange ging die Vorstellungsrunde, wo er da promoviert, welches afrikanische Land wird von ihm verzaubert und was auch immer. Dass da einfach Milliardenerbe dahintersteht, spielt keine Rolle. Das wird einfach vorausgesetzt, dass die Leute im Raum das wissen. Und ehrlicherweise wissen sie es auch, denn in diesem Raum saß mehr Kapital als die Stadt Frankfurt Jahresbudget hat. Also es sind wirklich Zustände, wenn man sie vor Ort sieht, die sind erschütternd. Weshalb ich sehr dafür bin, dass man diese Kämpfe jetzt führt. Aber, wie eben schon besprochen, geduldsam. Hier kämpft nicht die CDU gegen die Grünen, sondern hier kämpfen die Superreichen gegen einen Zeitgeist, der zu mobilisieren ist. Wir haben ihn eben schon beschrieben. Der Zeitgeist ist da, man muss ihn jetzt nur rauskratzen, dass sich irgendwie anlächeln zu lassen von Martin Huber oder Karin Prim bei Lanz.
Es bestätigt ja nochmal meine These von der Hochkultur als neuer Subkultur.
Ich habe eben gesagt, Hochkultur, die Oper ist Subkultur. Ich gehe doch da nicht hin und sehe lauter, also woran erkenne ich denn Hochkultur? Ich weiß, woran ich Subkultur erkenne. Leute kommen mit einem Jutebeutel, weil sie sich dafür interessieren, wie das jetzt auf Russisch gesungen wird.
Ja.
So, das ist Subkultur, aber Hochkultur? Also bei Wagner vielleicht oder so.
Die eigentliche Kultur der Herrschenden, das ist die Apple-Voy-Kultur und das ist, wir machen noch irgendeinen Public-Fueling für 50 Millionen und wir sorgen für noch drei weitere Superstars und wenn ich noch einen vierten will, dann zahle ich noch aus eigener Tasche. Das ist eigentlich jetzt das Dominante. Dieses Kapital regiert die Kultur und man kann es ja am Kino sehr gut sehen, welche Filme dann produziert werden. Wir sehen das hier bei dieser komischen MET-Gala, die es da immer gibt, welche Geschmacklosigkeiten da auf dem roten Teppich aufgeführt werden. Wer da alles präsent ist und wer da fehlt, nämlich tatsächlich Künstler, sind da rar gesät. Es ist diese Kultur der Superreichen, die jetzt uns allen das aufprägt.
Der Wiener Opernball ist Hochkultur.
Ja, in dem Sinne, diese Hochkultur ist einfach die Kultur des Status quo. Für die macht es am Ende auch keinen Unterschied, ob die eine neue Louis Vuitton-Handtasche von irgendeinem Hip-Hopper designt kaufen oder ein neues Gemälde kaufen. Das ist bei denen alles dekorativ. Deswegen sind sie gegen das, was wir Kunst nennen. Deshalb ist die Kunst eigentlich heute die Subkultur und auch besonders gefährdet. Dadurch, dass früher noch das Kapital ein gewisses Interesse an dieser Hochkultur hatte und es dazugehörte. Inzwischen aber, dass für die nicht mehr relevant ist. Du kannst heute vielleicht damit angeben, wenn du sagst, ich war bei Beyoncé Backstage, weil ich es mir leisten kann. Aber du kannst nicht mehr damit angeben, dass du sagst, ich sehe mir 10 Opern im Jahr in Frankfurt an. Das ist jetzt dieser Paradigmenwechsel, der stattgefunden hat und der führt dazu, dass es die Kunst so schwer hat. Und deswegen geht ja auch alles auf so eine Eventisierung hinaus. Man kann das jetzt zum Beispiel auch in Berlin jetzt mit dem neuen Kulturstadtsekretär sehen, dass der auch eigentlich Kultur als großes Event verkauft. Und ja, wahrscheinlich könnten die zusammenarbeiten, der Milliardär und er. Und dann machen die auch noch eine Apple-Voy-Kultur in Berlin. Und irgendjemand darf vielleicht noch ein Instrument dazu spielen.
Das Problem mit der Oper für die Superreichen ist, man kann sie nicht kaufen, sondern man ist halt einen Abend da. Und wenn man im letzten Ton ist, ist es verklungen.
Man kann sich ja auch nicht irgendwie verbessern. Man kann die teuerste Karte kaufen, aber dann sitzt man auch immer noch zwischen Leuten, die 3000 Netto verdienen und man selbst ist aber Milliardär. Und jetzt kann ich mich nicht noch mal von denen absentieren, denn es gibt nur die Reihe 1, da kann man sitzen. Aber die haben jetzt auch alle die 100 Euro ausgegeben.
Es gibt keinen Haken für Rendite bei der Oper. Was für mich bedeutet, ist jetzt wirklich meine neue Lieblingskunst. Es ist ein bisschen wie bei Twitter damals. Elon Musk dachte ja, er könnte da Profite rausziehen und wir alle aufgeklärten, haben schon vor zehn Jahren verstanden, aus Twitter gibt es nichts rauszuziehen. Das sind einfach nur Leute, die Tweets schreiben und deswegen ist es ja auch nie gelungen. Und dann kam er mit, ich kaufe das jetzt für 40 Milliarden und jetzt ist es halt sieben wert. Also der Ansicht hat die da auch mal schön dezimiert. Aber Opa kann man nicht kaufen, sondern man steht einfach als Superreicher daneben, wie die Stadt das beste Grundstück, das es hat, mit 1,3 Milliarden bespielt. So weg ist es. Dann hat man keine Hoheit mehr drüber. Also in der Ansicht verstehe ich so ein bisschen die Leiden, aber ich muss wirklich, ich habe mich jetzt auch noch ein bisschen eingelesen, es ist jetzt nicht nur, dass ich den einen kennengelernt habe, sondern auch so grundsätzlich, insbesondere in Deutschland haben die Superreichen, die wissen nicht wohin mit ihrer Kohle. Wer nachher, Mark Zuckerberg, der hat irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, da macht er dann irgendwie so Hightech mit irgendwelchen Kühen und so ein Scheiß. Wo ich sage, ok, das sind zumindest noch Projekte. Die deutschen Superreichen, und bitte zeig mir anderes, aber die deutschen Superreichen haben sich in ihrem Immobiliengeschäft verfangen, veranstalten dort, weil es so eine Laufkundschafts-Erdgeschossebene gibt, so eine Olympiade der besten Gastronomie. Und es ist einfach erbärmlich, das zu sehen. Da macht der eine Milliardär ein Restaurant auf, und dann sagen alle anderen Milliardäre, das ist ein cooles Restaurant, und dann sagt der, ich kriege ein besseres hin. Man denkt sich so, das ist kein Lebenssinn, das ist doch bescheuert. Und da ist dann auch, also klar, man hört dann immer, ja, die hängen dann immer mit allen rum, und die fahren auch ganz viel in Silicon Valley, und die Milliardäre verstehen sich ja und so. Dann sind die alle so begeistert von, keine Ahnung, Peter Thiel, weil der ja auch wirklich was macht und so. Da hängt er dann drin, also da kommt dann so neben der Finanziellen auch so diese operative Macht, und das finden die ganz fasziniert, und kommen selber zurück nach Frankfurt, und schlagen sich dann doch nur mit dem Bürgermeister rum und irgendwelche Liegenschaften, und kann man nicht hier nochmal 10 Millionen rausholen, weil ich will nicht an die Substanz, ich will nur an die Rendite und so. Also es ist wirklich lächerlich, das zu sehen. Man muss wirklich heute sagen, wer Spaß an der Oper hat, kann sich wirklich glücklich schätzen, weil er kriegt, wenn man eine Opernkarte dazu kauft für 70, 80 Euro, immer genau das, was nicht besser geht. Das ist ein bisschen wie dieses iPhone Phänomen. Es ist egal, wie viel Geld du hast, für 1000 Euro kriegst du das beste verfügbare Smartphone der Welt. Und das Smartphone ist das Tor zur Welt. Für Drittklässler schon.
Die geben vielleicht nicht 1000 Euro aus.
Ja, manche eben schon. Aber du hast kein Distinktionsmerkmal mit Drittklässlern. Ich verstehe auch, man will doch gerne mit den Milliarden was machen. Aber ich will mir noch zwei Clips spielen. Denn jetzt, wo wir uns ja fragen, wenn Black Rock jetzt regiert, das große schwarze Loch, also das schwarze Loch, demnächst Deutschland bestürmt und hier ein riesiger Ausverkauf von allen möglichen stattfindet, denkt da noch jemand an die kleinen Leute? Frau Seehofer sagt, ja.
Ich habe ja in verschiedenen Interviews, nicht in sehr vielen, aber doch den einen oder anderen, schon seit einigen Monaten zu Baustruck gebracht, dass ich den Friedrich Merz für absolut geeignet halte. Ich bilde mir einen Urteil aus der Zusammenarbeit mit ihm. Ich war ja auch Stellvertreter von ihm in der Bundestagsfraktion. Ich kenne sein Denken, seine Grundüberzeugungen und habe auch erlebt, dass er durchaus die sozialen Fragen unserer Zeit so beantwortet und löst, wie ich mir das auch für die kleinen Leute vorstelle. Er ist keiner, der nur die Wirtschaftspolitik im Blick hat und alles andere um sich herum vergisst. Nein, er sucht passend zu einer Volkspartei immer den Ausgleich zwischen den wirtschaftlichen Notwendigkeiten und auch der sozialen Balance in unserem Land. Also Gerechtigkeit mit Friedrich Merz zu realisieren, dürfte nach meiner Überzeugung kein Problem darstellen.
Kommentieren?
Spielend möglich. Ist nicht Seehofer derjenige gewesen, der noch mal, wie wir bei Julia Friedrichs nachlesen konnten, es ermöglicht hat, dass die Superreichen das weiterhin steuerfrei vererben können?
Als wir 2016 alle die Turnhallen voll hatten, weil die Flüchtlinge Deutschland überfordern, hat er ein Gesetz mitverantwortet, in dem die GroKo sagte, ja, die Superreichen dürfen bei uns durchaus mal eine Notiz dalassen, dass sie gerade gar kein Cash auf dem Konto haben, und dann dürfen sie auch 7 Milliarden einfach so erben, ohne Steuer.
Wir müssen das nochmal kurz erklären für die, die das im Salon nicht gehört haben. Also wir haben im Salon ja sehr ausführlich über das Buch von Julia Friedrichs Crazy Rich diskutiert. Und dort gibt es so eine interessante Passage, dass es eigentlich so aussah, als würden doch die Superreichen, wenn sie denn vererben an die nächste Generation, dass sie da doch eine Erbschaftssteuer entrichten müssen. Und jetzt hat man bei diesen Betriebsvermögen ja immer gesagt, ja, aber was ist, wenn die das jetzt gar nicht haben? Das Geld und so weiter.
Steckt noch in den Arbeitsplätzen.
Jetzt hat man damals einen Trick dann politisch auf den Weg gebracht, dass, wenn das fällig ist, der Betrag, man einfach als Superreicher das Geld jemandem anders überweisen kann, so lange, also man parkt das woanders, zum Beispiel bei seinen Kindern. Und dann sagt man ja, ich bin gar nicht in der Lage, jetzt die Erbschaftssteuer zu zahlen.
Ich hab nichts flüssig.
Ich hab nichts flüssig. Ich kann ja jetzt nicht hier meine Werke verkaufen oder so. Oder die ganzen Wohnungen klein machen. Deswegen geht das nicht. Also man muss sich das wirklich so vorstellen.
Sie haben es schonungsbedarfsprüfung genannt.
Ja.
Milliardärsschonungsbedarfsprüfung.
Und Seehofer hat das ganz entscheidend auf den Weg gebracht. Und ich will diesen Vergleich nochmal machen. Es wäre so, wie wenn ich meine Einkommenssteuererklärung bekomme. Da steht, sie müssen jetzt 10.000 Euro zahlen. Und ich sage, ich überweis mal mein gesammeltes Geld auf dem Konto. Stefan, der soll das mal da verwahren. Und ich gebe dann an, ist nichts drauf geworden, kann ich zahlen? Tut mir leid. Und dann gibst du mir das Geld wieder zurück.
Jetzt ratet mal, wer sich erinnerte, dass wir 2016 über den Familiennachzug diskutierten. Und wer dann sagt, ja, die GroKo hat durchaus gezeigt, oder die Politik allgemein, dass sie Familienpolitik machen kann. Denn es gibt keine bessere, erfolgreichere familienpolitische Maßnahme als diese. Die Schonungsbedarfsprüfung für Milliardärserben. Ja, das ist wirklich grotesk.
Damit diese Familien zusammenhalten.
So, einen Clip gucken wir uns noch an. Ich will eine Premiere ankündigen. Ich habe diesen Clip das erste Mal nicht selbst ausgewählt, sondern ich habe einfach durchgesehen, was das geht, eine Stunde. Also ich wollte das Gespräch von Friedrich Merz bei Mario Horn vom Spiegel auf dem roten Sofa, wo auch immer. Kulisse ist Illustre. Und ich habe dann Turboscribe gesagt, mach mir einen Transkript. Da kriegt man Zeitmarken dazu. Dann habe ich Claude gesagt, schneide mir, also gib mir die Auszüge und achte darauf, dass die Zeitmarken noch dranstehen.
Ich stelle mir gerade vor, wie ich das alles in die Wege leite. In der Zeit hätte ich das Video wahrscheinlich dreimal geguckt.
Ja, dann habe ich die Zeitmarken einfach in Ultraschall importiert. Ich habe die Zeitmarken kurz zusammengeschnitten. Du hättest wahrscheinlich in einfacher Geschwindigkeit das Video in einer Stunde geguckt. Das weiß ich gerade in zugegebener Maßen lange ausgeführt. Aber es ist tatsächlich nur drei Minuten. Wir gucken also jetzt von Claude ausgewählt, drei Minuten neunundzwanzig. Friedrich Merz im O-Ton. Sozialpolitik, wir haben es ja gerade gehört. Das ist das neue Schwarze Loch. BlackRock wird jetzt Bundeskanzler. Und so sieht die Regierungszeit dann aus.
Gehen wir einmal in die Wirtschaft. Also was würde sich für Unternehmer oder für die Wirtschaft ändern?
Ich nenne immer vier Themen. Das eine ist, wir müssen den Arbeitsmarkt wieder in Ordnung bringen. Dazu gehört das Arbeitszeitgesetz, das völlig überholt ist. Dazu gehört dieses sogenannte Bürgergeld, das den völlig falschen Anreiz gibt.
So genannte Bürgergeld.
Wir haben ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen. So wird es ja verstanden, auch wenn die Regierung es ständig bestreitet. Wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass die Menschen, die etwas leisten, in diesem Land wieder Respekt und Anerkennung bekommen. Das heißt auch im Klartext, die Abgabenbelastung darf nicht weiter steigen, die Steuerbelastung darf nicht weiter steigen. Und das setzt voraus, dass wir auf der Ausgabenseite korrigieren. Also einfach wieder ein bisschen bessere Stimmung, auch durch Anerkennung derjenigen, die etwas leisten, und den Menschen die Perspektive zu geben und zu sagen, wir kommen aus dieser Krise raus. Davon bin ich auch fest überzeugt, dass das geht. Die Substanz unseres Landes ist nach wie vor dafür da.
Müssen wir auch wieder mehr arbeiten?
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Ich sage in den Versammlungen jetzt immer, was ist eigentlich Arbeit für uns? Ich stelle diese rhetorische Frage, um auch den Zuhörern das Gefühl zu geben, dass wir über diese Frage diskutieren müssen. Ist das eigentlich eine unangenehme Unterbrechung unserer Freizeit? Oder ist das ein Teil unserer Lebenserfüllung? Je nachdem, wie wir die Frage beantworten, sind wir auf dem Weg oder auf dem Weg.
So, also Kurzunterbrechung gehört nicht nur seiner Antworten, sondern sie lacht sich schlapp. Und er möchte aber den Ernst der Situation gewahrt wissen.
Ja, Marion Horn ist ja so eine hyper-neoliberale, die sich nicht sehnlich erwünscht, als dass Friedrich Merz und Christian Lindner zusammen ein Kind zeugen.
Das würde er sich auch sofort akzeptieren, den Griff.
Das ist so erstaunlich, dass man diese Interviews hat und er aber immer noch so darauf geht, ah ja, das ist ein guter Punkt. So, als seien sie sich nicht sowieso von 100 Prozent in allen Dingen einig.
Er sitzt ja auch so mit verschränkten Armen. Ich muss das wirklich noch mal sagen.
Wenn es eine unangenehme Unterbrechung unserer Freizeit bleibt, dann können wir den Weg weitergehen, aber der führt in einen massiven Wohlstandsverlust. Wenn wir sagen, es ist ein Textstück unserer Lebenszeit.
Das ist so interessant. Diese Argumentation haben wir ja laufend.
Ja, wessen Wohlstand?
Das hatten wir auch beim Live-Salon mit Gen Z und den Boomern dieser Sendung aus dem ZDF, die wir dort gemeinsam diskutiert haben. Dass man es hier mit Leuten zu tun hat, die haben ihren Hobby zum Beruf gemacht. Der wollte immer im Rampenlicht stehen Politiker sein, und dann macht er das, bis es nicht mehr geht. Wie sein Kollege Schäuble am liebsten. Dass man im Bundestag stirbt. Das ist das große Ziel. Marion Horn wird wahrscheinlich mit ihrer sensationellen Publizistik uns auch noch Jahrzehnte begleiten, weil die das so großartig finden. Desiree Nick missversteht sich als Kaparitistin, wie wir da gesehen haben in dieser Sendung. Sie wird natürlich bis zum Schluss auf der Bühne stehen. Das hat nur nichts zu tun mit den Leuten, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen. Und irgendwo in der Bäckerei Brötchen einpacken und das acht Stunden am Tag tun. Und vielleicht doch mal mit 64 oder 65 in die Rente wollen.
Ich dachte, du willst noch einen Punkt zu hören.
Ein Teil unserer Lebenserfüllung. Je nachdem, wie wir die Frage beantworten, sind wir auf dem Weg oder auf dem Weg. Wenn es eine unangenehme Unterbrechung unserer Freizeit bleibt, dann können wir den Weg weitergehen. Aber der führt in einen massiven Wohlstandsverlust.
Wessen Wohlstand geht verloren? Ja, wenn die Leute nicht mehr zur Arbeit gehen. Sicherlich nicht der Wohlstand der Arbeitnehmer. Welcher Wohlstand? Also 50 Prozent der Leute haben genau Null. Da gibt es kein Vermögen, das bedroht ist oder so. Also das ist wirklich absurd.
Wenn wir sagen, es ist ein Stück unserer Lebenserfüllung, ein Stück unserer Selbstverwirklichung, wir haben sogar vielleicht Freude an unserer Arbeit. Ich habe sie, ich vermute sie auch. Dann können wir doch mal vorurteilsfrei die Frage stellen, warum leisten wir heute eigentlich mit 45 Millionen Erwerbstätigen nicht mehr Arbeitsstunden als vor 30 Jahren, da hatten wir 7 Millionen Erwerbstätige weniger.
Wenn Josef Hader das 1 zu 1 einfach nachspricht, ist das das beste Josef Hader Programm, das wir jemals gehört haben. Noch besser als der im Buhmerlbeck.
Die Arbeitszeit pro Kopf der Bevölkerung nimmt kontinuierlich ab in Deutschland. Und über diese Entwicklung müssen wir sprechen. Es ist schön, es ist bequem, aber für unseren Wohlstand ist es nicht ausreichend.
Mich nervt das wirklich persönlich, dass man in diesem Land nicht einfach sagen kann, ich habe mir das selbst erarbeitet, ich freue mich drüber, ich fahre das gerne.
Das habe ich ein paar Mal gesagt, das habe ich ein paar Mal gesagt, wiederhol es auch gerne nochmal hier. Ich freue mich darüber, es ist nicht vom Himmel gefallen, ich habe dafür gearbeitet.
Das ist die beste journalistische Frage überhaupt. Bitte wiederholen Sie das doch hier nochmal.
Oder? Oder, oder, oder? Ich habe vielleicht auch mehr gearbeitet als acht Stunden am Tag. Ich habe es gerne gemacht und ich habe auch Glück gehabt. So und ich sage jetzt mal aus dieser Position heraus, das motiviert mich jetzt auch heute noch mal ein politisches Amt auszufüllen und ein weiteres anzustreben, zu sagen, ich möchte diese Botschaft gerne auch dem Land geben. Es muss ein Land sein und das habe ich in Amerika immer sehr geschätzt, ein Land sein, das Erfolg nicht diskreditiert, sondern sagt, da nehmen wir mal uns ein Beispiel und ich will die, ich möchte ein bisschen unsere Mentalität ändern. Das ist glaube ich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt für Deutschland.
Ganz kurz, Marion Horn, man kann ja über Julian Reichelt sagen, was man will, aber selbst der hätte das ja intelligenter angelegt.
Ja, das ist ja schlaunig.
Hat sie eine Schülerzeitung oder die Bildzeitung?
Das ist wirklich Schülerzeitung.
Wir sind ja nicht zur emotionalen Mittellage in der Lage.
Ich weiß ja, das ist eine Schülerzeitung, das ist LeFloid im Merkel-Interview, der sich noch bedankt für die, jetzt habe ich es eigentlich mal verstanden, was sie für die Politik machen.
Entweder sind wir hoch, Himmel hoch, jaust und zu Tode betrübt dazwischen, gibt selten was. Also, der wirtschaftliche Erfolg gehört dazu, den darf man auch, muss nicht protzen, kann man auch zeigen, darf man selbstbewusst sagen, und dann kann man auch andere ermutigen und ermuntern und sagen, macht es nach.
Ich finde, das ist ein gutes Schlusswort.
Wenn Sie wollen, gerne.
Ja, tatsächlich. Vielen Dank dafür. Und wenn Sie auch das tatsächlich gedreht kriegen, fände ich das wunderbar. Wir können nämlich ein bisschen gute Laune gebrauchen.
Stimmt. Ich habe Sie.
Ich finde eigentlich schade, dass sie nicht noch zum Schluss sagt, Herr Merz, es war meine Freude, schade, dass Sie schon verheiratet sind.
Darf ich Ihnen trotzdem noch mal schnell einen Antrag machen? Sie können ja nein sagen. Also es ist wirklich brutal. Und ich will noch mal zu diesem Arbeitsbegriff, der hier drin steckt. Und aus meiner sehr intensiven Beschäftigung mit Superreichen, soweit die da liegen. Ich weiß nicht genau, was ich im Salon alles lese. Könnte sein, dass dieses kühne Ding von Vinnie T. Fair auch noch mal in diese Kerbe schlägt. Aber die Superreichen arbeiten nicht. Sie delegieren alles. Sie setzen einen Fuß vor den anderen und reden. Das war's. Sie kochen ihr Essen nicht. Sie waschen ihre Wäsche. Sie machen gar nichts. Wie man ein so unerfülltes Leben führen kann, weiß ich nicht. Aber kommen wir fliegen nach Afrika und retten dort die Welt im eigenen Flugzeug, im eigenen Auto. Der ganze Entourage verlässt die Yacht, um schon mal zu gucken, ob der Restauranttisch schon fertig ist. Das ist einfach wer da noch sagt, er arbeitet einfach grotesk. Das ist nicht Arbeit. Das ist delegieren.
Sie haben so viel Geld, dass sie selbst ihr Geld nicht mehr verwalten müssen. Da haben sie die Family Offices.
Es ist ganz grotesk. Also es ist wirklich ganz grotesk. Wir können das nicht länger dulden. Das muss den weggenommen werden. Es darf keine Milliardäre geben.
Das ist ein gutes Stichwort, um auf den Salon hinzuweisen. Wir sprechen über gutes Geld, Wege zu einer gerechten und nachhaltigen Gesellschaft von Philippa Siegel Klöckner. Sie ist eine Ökonomin, die mittlerweile sehr viel rezipiert wird. Sie legt hier ein Buch vor, das sich auch mit Ungleichheit und Reichtum auseinandersetzt, aber auch darüber hinaus fragt, wo muss dann eigentlich der Staat Geld einsetzen, damit etwas geschieht? Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf. Michael Hüther empfiehlt dieses Buch. Er schreibt dazu, der Staat als Unsicherheitenreduzierer. Darum geht es bei der Autorin. Unsicherheitenreduzierer ist schon ein ganz gutes Wort.
Michael Hüther sollte man jetzt in alle Podcasts einladen und ihm dort immer ganz wohlgesonnen sein. Er ist nicht klem ins Fuß.
Genau.
Man muss nicht so langsam.
Ja, ich denke auch. Also das ist das Buch, über das wir reden werden. Und jetzt kannst du noch sagen, wie man in den Salon kommt.
Man kommt in den Salon, in dem man auf neu20er.de geht und dort auf den goldenen Button klickt, der direkt zur Steady führt. Das ist der einfachste, also für alle Beteiligten, einfachste Weg, weil da ist einfach das ganze Archiv. Das sind alle Kapitelmarken, da kann man alles konsumieren. Das ist ein RSS Feed. Wenn man es ein bisschen einfacher für manche haben will, in der Apple Podcast App, also wenn man da unseren Podcast hört, tauchen die Salonfolgen da eh mit auf, kosten aber 3,50 Euro oder so. Ich glaube 3,50 Euro, das ist ein bisschen teurer als der Salon. Salon mit 3 Euro ist das billigste, kann man sich bei Steady merken. Oder wenn man schon einen Patreon-Account hat, kann man auch bei Patreon uns suchen und finden, dann weiß man ja, wie das funktioniert. Wenn man ganz neu ist, Steady. Steady ist die Einflugsschneise.
Und es gibt dann auch die Möglichkeit, alle alten Folgen zu hören, zum Beispiel auch unseren Live-Salon, den hatten wir ja vor zwei Wochen etwa in Frankfurt. Da haben wir über diese merkwürdige ARD-Sendung gesprochen, die 100, auch ein Live-Bürgerat zum Thema AfD.
Aber keinen Fernsehpreis bekommen.
Keinen Fernsehpreis bekommen. Ich glaube, wir legen auch nahe, warum das schon ganz richtig ist, dass das nicht noch preisprämiert ist. Und dann haben wir gesprochen über eine ZDF-Sendung Gen Z gegen Boomer und haben darüber hinaus noch mal die großen Diskurse aufgerufen, wie das so ist mit dem Öko-Emanzipatorischen Projekt etc. Das werden wir heute nicht tun. Dann kann man aber alles dort noch mal nachlesen. Das war, wie ich finde, ein sehr heitere und dichter Abend.
Yes, alles im Salon. Mark Zuckerberg hat eine neue Idee. Wir alle sollen Brillen tragen.
Ja.
Die Leute sind nicht so ganz bereit dafür. Google hat uns ja auch schon vor über zehn Jahren eine Brille hingelegt. Die Leute sagten so, ne, keine Ahnung. Die neue Idee ist, die Brille hat ein ganz dickes Gestell und kostet 10.000 Euro.
Das soll angenehm sein auf der Nase.
Ein ganzer Computer auf der Nase. Bist du überzeugt?
Nicht so ganz.
Niemand ist überzeugt. Max Zuckerberg auch nicht. Er hat gesagt, es wird nur ein Prototyp nicht geben. Aber ich wollte euch mal zeigen, was ich cooles kann. Und daraufhin...
Ich meine, diese Apple-Brille war ja schon ein ziemlicher Rohrkrepierer.
Ja, und die hat auch noch die Stromversorgung extern und so.
Ja.
Also eh schwieriges Geschäft. Aber wir wissen ja, er möchte gerne Hoheit über seine Software haben. Die hat er nicht, wenn er nicht Hoheit über die Hardware hat. Da ist er Apple und Google ausgeliefert mit den Smartphones. Und im Zuge dessen gab es jetzt so eine Diskussion, wenn wir jetzt mehr Zeit hätten, wäre es super amüsant, nachzuvollziehen, wie alle möglichen, auch bei Bits und so, diese Fragen. Können das andere Unternehmen auch? Und dann stellt man so fest, ne, Google hat keine Brille vorgestellt. Und Snapchat hat so eine, aber da ist nur eine Kamera eingebaut. Und dann alle so, ja, das ist wirklich beeindruckend, was der Mark Zuckerberg da kann. Und der hat wohl auch beschrieben, wie er so die Kristalle züchtet. Und ich denke mir dann, ja, vielleicht solltet ihr nicht im selikenten Valley nachfragen, ob jemand eine Brille gebaut hat, sondern so bei Brillenherstellern.
Aber es gibt ja die Kooperation mit Ray-Ban.
Ja, also klar. Das Brillengestell eignet sich ja dafür auch eine super kleine, also, dass Kameras klein sind, wissen wir. Wenn wir den Laptop aufklappen, wie klein die Kamera ist, dass man die auch in eine Brille einbauen kann. Ja, nur die Frage ist, kriegt man eine Art Bildschirm in die Brillengläser? Kann man da Sachen rein projizieren?
Und will man das auch?
Ja gut, die Frage kann man ja ausgeblendet lassen, denn angebotsorientiert, wenn die Milliardäre sagen, das ist cool, gehen die Leute los und kaufen es.
Ich frage mich halt immer, inwieweit das eine Technologie ist, die vielleicht umsetzbar ist, die aber nicht gewollt ist. Wenn ich jetzt an das Smartphone denke, dann ist das ja deshalb auch so erfolgreich geworden, weil es so wunderbar bedienbar ist. Es ist tatsächlich eine Erweiterung meines Körpers, ohne dass mein Körper dadurch beeinträchtigt ist. Sondern es ist eine Erweiterung, es ist nicht eine Beeinträchtigung. Ich kann das mit einem Daumen bedienen, ich kann das wunderbar nach oben und unten wischen, was ich da sehen will.
Und wegstecken vor allem.
Und wieder wegstecken. Während ich eine Brille zwar auch dann temporär nur anziehen könnte, weil ich gerade etwas machen will, aber die Idee ist ja doch eigentlich, dass man mit dieser Brille unterwegs ist. Nun werden fast alle Brillenträger klagen darüber, dass sie laufende Brille tragen müssen. Denn manchmal ist das ziemlich blöd. Zum Beispiel...
Ja, blästern sich die Augen für Tausende Euro. Obwohl doch die Brille laut Max Zuckerberg das coole Ding ist.
Wenn es draußen sehr kalt ist, die Brille beschleckt, wenn man irgendwo reinkommt. All das ist dann nicht besonders angenehm. Außerdem hat man die ganze Zeit etwas auf der Nase. Wenn jetzt noch hinzukommt, dass wir Menschen uns ja doch, wenn wir mal uns ehrlich befragen, gerne ansehen und nicht so gerne eine Brille davor haben, die noch etwas verschließt. Also eine normale Brille verschließt ja nichts. Bei einer Sonnenbrille haben wir ja schon unsere Probleme. Wenn ich jetzt hier dir mit der Sonnenbrille gegenüber sitzen würde, dann wäre das für dich wahrscheinlich eher unangenehm. Bei einer solchen Brille könnte das noch einen ganz anderen Effekt haben. Und dann kommt ja auch hinzu, wollen wir nicht, wenn wir sehen, unmittelbar sehen. Also wir sehen uns etwas an oder wir konzentrieren uns auf einen Bildschirm oder auf eine Leinwand. Aber wenn wir jetzt so eine weitere See-Ebene drin haben, dass wir also einmal die Wirklichkeit haben und dann nochmal das, was die Brille uns anzeigt, dann ist das so konträr zu dem, was wir intuitives Sehen nennen können, dass ich meine Zweifel habe, dass sich das tatsächlich durchsetzt, außer jetzt in speziellen Bereichen, wo man sagt, im Gaming, wenn ich dann gerade spiele, mache ich das, wie auch Leute sich eine Motorrad-Kluft anziehen, wenn sie Motorrad fahren, aber sie würden ja jetzt auch nicht so damit rumsetzen.
Also ich für mich kann es ausschließen, ich bin ein sehr technikaffiner Mensch, aber schon Schwimmbrillen, die ein bisschen zu straff auf der Nase liegen, schwierig. Beim Schwimmen würde ich nicht darauf verzichten. Das sind also echte Vorteile. In der echten Welt werde ich niemals freiwillig eine Brille tragen, außer Sonnenbrille, wenn ich Fahrrad fahre, weil das Wind und Licht betrifft. So, da hat es einen rein funktionalen Charakter. Ich kann mir durchaus Szenerien vorstellen, in der ich dann mal eine Brille gezielt aufsetze, aber es käme nie über das Smartphone hinaus oder die Kopfhörer, dass ich sie im sichtbaren Bereich oder drinnen lasse, obwohl ich sie nicht brauche. Das ist das ganze Paradekmal, finde ich, quatschig und besonders amüsant fand ich, dass diese jungen Technikjournalisten nicht in der Lage sind, so einen Schritt weiter zu denken. Gibt es in der Medizintechnik Kristalle, auf die man Informationen projiziert oder Miniaturkameras, mit denen man durch die Blutader nähert? Natürlich. Also der Formfaktor, wir haben jetzt einen Computer, in dem ein kleines Brillengestell eingebaut ist, kein Applaus wert. Das ist irgendwie völlig absurd, was stattfand jetzt im September. Nur weil Mark Zuckerberg dachte, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was Cooles. Also wirklich lächerlich. Wir interessieren uns also für die Rahmenbedingungen dessen, nämlich ein Milliardär wollte uns zeigen, was so viel Spielzeug für die Welt ist und so. Und meine Einflugschneise ist natürlich immer der Hard Fork Podcast. Wir hören also hier in zwei Ausführungen Casey Newton und Kevin Ruse, die darüber reden, wie sich Mark Zuckerberg verhält.
Und wie wir wissen, ist er ein Mensch, der sich mit dem Roman Empire besitzt. Das ist einfach etwas, was wir seit einiger Zeit über Zuckerberg kennen. Ja, er ist sehr für Konqueste. Er liebt Konqueste. Sein Lieblingsspiel ist die Zivilisation. Dieser Mann liebt ein Schirm über Konqueste. Zuckerberg geht am Tag auf der Strasse und trägt ein Shirt, das sagt, Out, Zuck, Out, Nihil. Und was das Shirt offenbar bedeutet, Kevin, ich spreche nicht Latin. Sprechest du Latin? Das kann offenbar in ein paar Ways verwendet werden. Er hat selbst durch alle Anerkennungen durchgeführt, in einer Art, die ich wirklich aus dem Gefühl habe, er wollte die Message verkaufen, ich runne diese Firma und ich bin die Willy Wonka von Metta. Und nicht vergessen. Ja, es ist nichts oder nichts. Ja, was ich wirklich aggressiv, wehrt und offensiv fand. Es wäre weh, wenn Tim Cook die ganze Apple-Präsentation gemacht hätte.
Wehrt, aggressiv, offensiv. Und ich denke mir so, der Typ hat 300 Milliarden Euro oder so. Dollar. Er kann halt machen, was er will. Er hat, wenn eine Beschränkung, dann in Sachen Zeit, aber das ist auch das einzige. Bei allem anderen lebt er sich einfach aus. Und was bedeutet das? Wenn man jetzt so nachgeht, ich habe mir dann so ein paar Sachen angeschaut. Er war wirklich sehr vielen Podcast zu Gast oder, wie man es richtig bezeichnen muss, sehr viele Podcaster waren bei ihm zu Gast. Denn die Podcasts, die mit ihm stattfanden, fanden immer in seinem an seinem Podcast-Tisch statt. Die Leute kamen dann, durften ihre Kamera oder haben sogar das fertige Ding dann gekriegt. Keine Ahnung. Also es war wirklich absurd, das so zu sehen. Und ich will zwei Sachen betonen. Zum einen ganz allgemein. Wie ist es so seine politische Sicht der Dinge? Er hat ja einige Kontroversen mitgemacht. Insbesondere 2016 die Wahl folgende Jahre. Und was steht jetzt eigentlich an? Also die Smartphones sind ja wirklich in die Kritik geraten. Und zwar nicht die Smartphones allgemein, sondern schon sehr wegen TikTok, Instagram und so weiter. Es scheint ja doch Generationen zu zerstören. Und wir beginnen mal mit diesem politischen Zuschnitt. Mark Zuckerbergs neues Politikverständnis.
Ich denke, die letzten acht Jahre unserer Erfahrung sind, dass das politische Diskurs schwierig ist. Auf der einen Seite ist es natürlich eine sehr wichtige Sache in der Gesellschaft und auf der anderen Seite.
Also Politik ist schon eine wichtige Sache in der Gesellschaft, aber es macht auch schlechte Laune. Es ist irgendwie tricky. Was will ich jetzt eigentlich? Also vielleicht hat er ja auch ein bisschen Bitschuld oder so. Kann ja durchaus sein. Also die New York Times hatte jetzt so ein Text. Mark Zuckerberg ist done with politics. Woraufhin dann Mother Jones? Nee, nee, nee, nee, das stimmt nicht ganz. Er macht nur andere Politik. Und ich hänge sehr der Haltung nach, es ist jetzt andere Politik. Denn wenn man dem hier nachgeht, das ist wirklich, es ist wirklich absurd. Also das war jetzt ein Auszug von seinem Gespräch mit The Verge. Da erklärt er auch nochmal, das ist ihm alles zu polarisiert jetzt.
You know, culture changes over time. Maybe the stuff will be like a little bit less polarized and anger inducing at some point. And maybe it'll be possible to have more of that while also at the same time having a product where we're proud of how it feels. But until then, I think we just want to design a product that people can get the things that they want. But fundamentally, I care a lot about how people feel coming away from the products.
Also er bestimmt natürlich, was die Leute sehen sollen und nicht was sie sehen wollen. Und wenn er jetzt beschließt, dass das Politische zu aufgeheizt ist, dann liefert er ihnen andere Inhalte, die natürlich politischer Natur sind.
Nur wer hat es so aufgeheizt?
Nur du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel auch... Ja, ja, also erst mal ist ja klar, dass das eng zusammenhängt. Also Facebook hat ja Subjekte hervorgebracht. Die sind ja nicht da reingekommen und konnten dann das machen, was sie immer machen wollten.
Die ganze Rapid-Hole-Thematik und so.
Das ist ja dort entstanden. Also die haben das produziert wie in den 70er Jahren das Fernsehen gewisse Subjektivitäten hervorgebracht hat. Da ist das bei den sozialen Medien jetzt auch der Fall. Nur interessant ist ja, dass er ja damit generell das Politische als so ein Schlecht-Laune-Macher und so was Polarisierendes darstellt. Da muss man ja erst mal sagen, ja generell ist die Gesellschaft eine Polarisierte, wenn der Genie-Koeffizienz so ist, wie er ist. Da ist eine Polarisierung da. Wenn ich natürlich jetzt sage, ach das Politische, das soll jetzt mal lieber nicht stattfinden, bedeutet das natürlich auch, dass deine Aufrufe hier Superreiche und so zu besteuern, eher dazu führen, dass du schlechte Laune verbreitest. Und das bedeutet wiederum, dass du gar nicht mehr vorkommst bei Instagram und Facebook.
Die Leute wollen dort nur, ja was will man eigentlich bei Instagram sehen?
Na ja, es ist ja schon so, dass man mit politischen Inhalten, und das ist ja das, was ich vorwiegend bei Instagram so mache, oder verweise auf politische Inhalte, auf Zeitungsartikel oder auf die eigenen Podcasts, dass das etwas ist, was schlechter gerankt wird. So sehen viele Leute dann meine Story gar nicht, obwohl sie mir folgen.
Genau, bei TikTok gab es ja schon Gegenbewegungen, dass man dann während des Schminkvideos politische Inhalte einfach erzählt. Aber es geht weiter um die körperlichen Attraktionen, die da gut funktionieren. Ich würde hier schon mal einen Clip vorweggreifen. Wir hören ihn aber erst später. Also Scott Galloway ist da ganz bestimmt. Instagrams Geschäftsmodell. Wenn er jetzt sagt, ich will, dass da keine Politik stattfindet, dann ist es nur noch per Version. Junge Frauen, die sich einfach aufreizend zeigen, in jeder anderen Lebenssituation und egal, wem man fragt, würde sagen, ne, das machen wir nicht. Instagram hat das zum zentralen Geschäftsmodell erklärt. Ja. Ja, das führt dann zu guter Laune. Also wenn so alte Männer, die junge Frauen sehen, die nichts anhaben, so ein bisschen spitz sind und die neuesten Tänze sehen, dann ist das gute Laune. Aber wenn man sich um seine Angelegenheit kümmert und vielleicht mal ein kontroverses Argument macht, schlechte Laune, nicht gut. Also da ist er ganz bestimmt, seine Firma und er, wir halten uns jetzt raus.
Ich habe die Entscheidung gemacht.
Wir sind nicht korrupt und ich kenne sie wirklich alle. Man kann es ja eigentlich oft genug betonen, wie dumm das alles ist. Aber Mark Zuckerberg ist jetzt nicht mehr politisch. Er hat keinen Lobby-Apparat mehr, der irgendwelche politischen Angelegenheiten klärt. Er hangelt sich auch nicht mehr beim Kongress raus mit irgendwelchen politischen Argumentationen, warum das doch alles nicht so schlimm ist, was er da trägt.
Ne, er trägt jetzt lustige T-Shirts und hat eine Wuschelforsur.
Ja, er steht jetzt drüber, macht irgendwelche Kämpfe und was auch immer. Ja, nun erinnern wir uns, er war 2016 noch einiges los und er ist jetzt hier auf einer Bühne, eine Bühne mit zwei Typen, die ihn einfach super geil finden.
Das wollte ich sowieso mal fragen. Ich habe seit Jahren kein Zuckerberg-Interview gesehen mit einem Journalisten, der konfrontativ vorgeht.
Also der Wirtschmann hier hat ihn sehr gut reden lassen. Ich kenne ihn auch nicht, es ist keiner der ansonsten im Wirtsch-Cast oder so eine große Rolle spielt, sondern die haben so ein kleines Department für was weiß ich. Und er lässt ihn einfach sehr gut reden. Weshalb ich diese Clips, die wir die drei jetzt einfach herausragend finde, dafür, dass man mal einen Milliardär hat.
Das finde ich auch gut, nur finde ich interessant, dass so gar nichts Konfrontatives entsteht.
Nee, das ist alles Mario Hornes. Mario Hornes und Merz ist der neue Standard für das politische Gespräch.
Ja, das wäre dann mein Traum noch. Mario Hornes interviewt Mark Zuckerberg. Vielleicht noch Peter Thiel dabei.
Sie geben ihm aber einen Preis, damit er kommen muss. Und er sagt dann, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich Ihnen jetzt noch sagen kann, aber vielen Dank für den Preis. Also wir sehen ihn jetzt auf dieser Bühne, was bedeutet, er lässt sich so ein bisschen hinreißen. Er ist jetzt, also hier in seinem Studio, total kontrolliert. Er geht wahrscheinlich auch aus so einer Yoga-Situation in diese Gespräche, um ihn einfach eine Stunde gut über die Bühne zu bringen. Und es ist auf jeden Fall interessant, wie präsent er sein möchte. Also er möchte jetzt überall einfach reden. Dieses Studio hat er wirklich nur dafür eingerichtet, dass Leute kommen und ihn Fragen stellen. Das ist so das Audienzzimmer irgendwie. Und auf der Bühne rekapituliert er nochmal. Es war ja sehr turbulent nach 2016, als der Kongress ihm unterstellte. Hätten sie das nicht sehen können, dass da irgendwie Werbung für Trump in Rubel bezahlt wurde? Und er so, nee, haben wir nicht darauf geachtet.
Ich denke, wir haben verstanden, dass wir eine Technologie-Kompanie sind, und dass du eine Technologie-Kompanie musst, um so etwas zu bauen. Ich denke, wir haben verstanden, dass wir keine sozialen Netzwerke-Kompanien sind, wir sind eine Menschenkommunikation-Kompanie, und das wird in verschiedenen Formen über Zeit nehmen. Ich denke, ich habe keine viel Verwundung im politischen Umfeld.
Ich glaube, ich habe es nicht so gut so gestimmt, als sie mir sagten, dass ich den einen oder anderen Fehler mache. Das ist ja genial, oder?
Das sollte man sich so einprogrammieren und dann sagen, na?
Ich bin jetzt in einer weiterführenden Schule. Ab jetzt bereue ich nicht mehr. Denn das, was du mir sagst, muss nicht grundsätzlich richtig sein. Vater!
Ja, das ist richtig gut.
Ja.
So, was ja bedeutet, er kann jetzt langfristig denken. Ja, es war turbulent in der Vergangenheit. In den Rufpräsidentschaften vielleicht, die man so überleben kann, wie so ein König. Die Queen stirbt und ja, sie hat 17 Premierminister mitgemacht oder so was. Ja, heißt es dann. In deren Sicht, das ist schon, also wir haben jetzt hier so ein Tenor.
Aber so sieht er sich ja. Er sagt ja, die anderen kommen und gehen, aber ich werde ja da bleiben. Und von daher ist für ihn das eine ganz langfristige Perspektive. Da sind zehn Jahre nichts.
Genau, also wir haben jetzt bislang gehört. Er kümmert sich nicht mehr um die Politik. Aber warum auch, wenn du hundert Milliarden hast, ist es ja egal, wer regiert. Also kostet manches ein bisschen mehr Geld, aber der Lobbyismus funktioniert ja immer. Polarisierung, damit hat er nichts zu tun. Er steht jetzt drüber. Er bereut nicht mehr irgendwelche Fehler, die ihm eingeredet werden. Jetzt braucht er eine Immunisierungsstrategie. Also diese 1000 Jahre, die er jetzt regieren möchte, ist er nicht mehr so alt, wie er sich das in seinem Kopf schön denkt. Er erinnert sich noch mal, wir hatten ja damals Exit-Angebote bekommen, irgendwer hat Geld geboten, Facebook zu übernehmen. Ich habe widerstanden und daraus gelernt.
Ja, wer kommt hierher? Viele Leute denken, dass alle ihre Start-up-Dreams wahr sind. Lernen durch Schmerz.
Wie Putin und Xi das auch gemacht haben, wie kann man es verhindern, dass man von den eigenen Leuten abgesägt wird? Na ja, da muss man ein paar Dinge mal regeln.
Und dann nennt man sich auf Lebenszeit selbst. Und damit ist er jetzt maximal immunisiert. Fehlen nur noch das Alltagsgeschäft. Irgendwer hat irgendwelche Anliegen, wenn man sie einfach so vorträgt, okay, muss man ja nicht darauf reagieren. Wenn jemand ihnen rechtsweg einschlägt...
Eine der Reasons, warum ich die Zuhöre von Zuhörenden verbreite, ist, dass es die Leute ein Signal gibt, dass sie eine Firma sind, die Zuhörende verbreitet. Vielleicht können wir sie zahlen und sie werden Zuhörende verbreitet.
Du würdest also keine Blankkarte für die Regierung schreiben, wie Google es für die Antifrashilfe gemacht hat?
Ich habe noch mit Gott unterhält, wenn er mal einen Rat braucht. Diese neue Person hier ist ganz unverändert, aber es kommt jetzt so etwas hinzu, dass er durch diese ganzen Stürme, die wir erlebt haben, eine Weisheit gefunden hat. Das ist ja so, was er ausstrahlt. Das ist jemand nach einem Selbstfindungstrip, der bei sich angekommen ist. Dass es aber eigentlich darum geht, jetzt dieses Unternehmen auf ein nächstes Level zu heben. Vergisst man fast so darunter, weil er es tatsächlich schafft, so als diese Neugeburt, die er da jetzt hartechnisch erlebt hat und mit einem großen T-Shirt ausgestattet, diese Neugeburt zu feiern.
Ja, vor allem so explizit über Rechtsstreitigkeiten zu reden und zu sagen, ich gehe niemals eine Schlichtung nach. Wer mich verklagt, wird ausverhandelt, bis ein Urteil steht.
Aber er sagt das ja genau nicht in dem Tonfall, wie du das sagst.
So ganz locker, ne?
So eine ganz, ganz...
Das Problem ist, das Rechtssystem ist immer auf deiner Seite, wenn du unendliches Budget hast. Die Anne-Prohr-Hilke, die jetzt für die Finanzwende mitarbeitet, die ja in NRW, diese ganzen Cum-Ex-Geschäfte und so, da von Seiten des Staates Geld zurückfordern, Leute anklagen und so, die da einfach aufgegeben hat. Die beschreibt das im Podcast Logbuch Netzpolitik 500 eine Stunde lang auf der Bühne. Das kann man sich, ich habe jetzt keinen Clip, mal anhören. Denn sie sagt einfach, in dem Moment, wo wir als Staat irgendwo klingeln und sagen, wir würden jetzt gerne Razzia machen, haben wir alles gegen uns. Schon allein, weil wir gar keine Ahnung davon haben, wo ist jetzt hier welcher Raum. Das sind riesige Bankentürme, wie auch immer. Und sie hat festgestellt, man klingelt dann da und sagt, wir machen jetzt hier Razzia. Dann steht man da mit 50 Polizisten. Dann haben die aber so eine App auf ihrem Smartphone, so ungefähr wurde das beschrieben, wo die einfach so ein Notfallding aktivieren und dann tauchen 300 Anwälte auf. Die einfach sagen, hallo, ich bin Professor Doktor so und so, was möchten Sie denn hier? So, dann muss man das mit denen klären. Woraufhin sie dann sehr heroisch, finde ich auch sehr gut, beschreiben kann. Ja, Razzia bedeutet, ich komme da irgendwo an als Ermittlungsleiterin und dann rufen mich die ganze Zeit meine eigenen Leute an und sagen, ja, die lassen uns hier gerade nicht rein. Die wollen hier nochmal einen Zettel sehen, die machen da nochmal und so weiter. Und sie dann einfach, nee, ihr geht da jetzt rein. So, weißt du, dann kommt sie einfach als kleine, schmächtige Frau und sagt, machen sie jetzt die Tür auf, wir gehen jetzt hier rein. So, und solange dann keiner sagt, wir gehen jetzt hier mal rein, machen sie die Tür auf. So, passiert einfach nichts. Und selbst wenn, jetzt hatten wir ja auch wieder dieses Problem, Cum Ex verjährt zwar nicht zu schnell, aber nach acht Jahren dürfen die Akten vernichtet werden. So, also du findest gar nichts mehr bei Narazia für diese Fälle. So, und wenn ich sowas hier höre, wie er einfach sagt, ich leg keinen Streit bei, wenn ein Urteil kommt, gibt es halt eine nächste Instanz. Ich hab ja hier so eine App mit 500 Anwälten, die dann die ganze Zeit meine Anliegen klären. Das ist ja, also bei ihm, das ist so viel Geld, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Er könnte jeden Anwalt Amerikas dauerhaft beschäftigen. Da bleiben gar keine anderen mehr übrig für die Gegenseite. Der Staat ist ihm sowieso ausgeliefert, muss in Rechtsstaat halt so lange gezogen werden, bis die Regierung wechselt und so. Also es ist völlig absurd, dass hier jemand das Immunsystem der Gesellschaft, das Rechtssystem, wie es in der Systemtheorie beschrieben wird, es einfach zu seinem eigenen Immunsystem erklärt. Und sagt, egal welche Ansprüche ihr habt, ich settele hier nichts, keine Vergleiche, keine irgendwas. Hier gibt es nur Urteile und Urteile nur nachdem tausend Anwälte auf meiner Seite gesagt haben, okay, hier ist wirklich gar nichts mehr zu machen. Und diese Situation gibt es halt nicht. Also in der Ansicht, wirklich hochgradig problematisch, was wir bis hierhin gehört haben. Und der nächste große Kampf, den er führen will, mit dieser Rigorosität, der steht ja jetzt erst aus.
Es fühlt sich an, dass die mentalen Gesundheit und die jüngeren mentalen Gesundheit.
Die Politik hat er sich unterworfen. Das Rechtssystem hat er sich unterworfen. Jetzt erklärt er uns, wie er sich den akademischen Betrieb da unterwirft. Wenn Studien gebraucht werden, gibt es Studien. So, vor allem Mental Health, das ist der nächste große Kampf, den ich führe. Also er geht da gleich, er ist hier so, also das ist ja nicht ohne Grund, dass er jetzt so ein Boxer geworden ist und so. Er geht da jetzt wirklich all in.
Und natürlich braucht man dann nur noch eins und eins zusammenzuzählen und weiß, dass das viele Leute unter Druck setzt. Und man sieht es ja auch dann an den empirischen Studien, wie das Jungs und Mädchen betrifft, wie das Mädchen noch mal stärker betrifft. All das ist ja nicht jetzt irgendwas herbeifantasiert. Das ist ja nicht mal ein schnell geschriebener Essay, sondern das ist alles belegt von den eigenen Leuten, die dann irgendwann als Whistleblower in Erscheinung getreten sind. Und er will jetzt eigentlich, und er spricht ja davon Narrativ, das ist interessant, er will das Narrativ jetzt einfach völlig umdrehen. Und er wird am Ende die Plattform sein, die allen Menschen hilft zu sehen, dank der Brille, richtig zu fühlen, weil die Politik fernab ist.
Ja, also wir gehen heute noch gar nicht darauf ein, seine neue Idee von Kommunikation. Man redet ja jetzt nur noch mit AI-Agenten. Man hat ja dadurch, dass die Leute, und es ist ja auch wirklich sehr traurig, ich sag dann in diesen Interviews, dass die Leute nur noch so einen richtigen Freund haben in ihrem Leben. Und sie haben aber trotzdem Bedarfe und Fragen. Und dann können sie doch einfach mit AI-Chat.
Ja, ich würde da wieder unterstellen, für ihn macht das auch keinen Unterschied.
Für ihn macht es wirklich, also ja.
Ich meine, das, was er schon damals zum Metaverse gesagt hat, da war ja auch immer so die Frage, ja, aber wer will sich da mit einer bunten Figur, die jetzt sagt, ich bin Stefan, unterhalten, wenn ich einen richtigen Menschen treffen kann? Und für ihn macht das aber gar keinen Unterschied.
Genau, ich will es nicht zu platt machen jetzt, aber so wie ich das mitbekomme, haben Superreiche keine Widerstände in ihrem Leben. Also Umfelder, also Leute, die sie kennen und mit denen zu tun haben, sagen immer, die kriegen immer alles, was sie wollen. Also diese diese Wortschöpfung von Willionär scheint genau richtig zu sein. Sie können alles delegieren, wenn irgendwer nicht mitmacht, wird einfach ausgetauscht, kommt der Nächste so. Und das ist ja ein artificielles und vor allem einseitiges Verhältnis deiner sozialen Landkarte zu dir, die nicht zum einen gesund ist und zum anderen wirklich kaum zu unterscheiden ist von diesen neuen Agenten. Also wir lachen ja so ein bisschen über GPT, dass sie sich ganze Zeit entschuldigt und der ganze Kram. Das ist die Kommunikation mit Superreichen und zwar auch innerhalb der Familien. Also da kommen ja auch die Kinder als Bittsteller die ganze Zeit zu dir, sobald sie ein gewisses Lebensalter überschritten haben. Also es ist wirklich gruselig, was man so liest. Es scheint auch zum Selbstschutz jetzt ange- ja über eine Milliarde darf nicht sein. So es muss dann anders verwaltet werden.
Du bist jetzt der Mental Health Beauftragte für die Superreichen.
Ja also Mental Health ist wirklich der nächste große Kampf für die Superreichen, aber anders als sie dachten. Sie müssen geschützt werden vor sich selbst. Er selbst sagt jetzt hier, ja also diese Forschung wird es dann schon geben. Die sagt, ich hatte recht, da gibt es keinen Link. Achso in meinen eigenen Häusern, das blenden wir hier aus. Er macht dazu folgenden Punkt.
At the same time, you guys have acknowledged there's affordances in the product, like the teen rollout with Instagram recently. You can make the product a better experience for young people.
So, er reagiert jetzt auf diese Frage. Dann sagt er zuerst etwas Ungeheuerliches. Und man denkt sich, krass, das muss ich erst mal prozisieren. Meint er das wirklich? Und in dem Moment sagt er aber schon das nächste Ungeheuerliche. Also, es könnte sein, dass wir diese 18 Sekunden, die dieser Clip noch lange ist, man denkt so, 18 Sekunden, was soll schon passieren? Könnte sein, dass wir es zweimal hören.
Make the product a better experience for young people.
Yeah, and I think this is an interesting part of the balance, is you can play a role in trying to make something better, even if the thing wasn't caused by you in the first place. Like, there's no doubt that being a parent is really hard.
Das ist so grotesk neben der Spur, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen. Ich kann ja Sachen besser machen, auch wenn ich sie selber nicht verschlimmert habe, sagt er zum Thema und so weiter.
Da sich dieses Netzwerk evolutionär entwickelt hat, da hat er offenbar nichts mit zu tun gehabt.
Das hat noch nie geschah. Und er versteht gut, dass Eltern sein schon hart ist. Ja.
Und du weißt ja, was er jetzt macht. Also Instagram, diese Einschränkung, die jetzt da ist. Also die Parental Controls.
Wir hören das gleich. Er hat dazu eine Sichtweise.
Okay, sag nur mal, was die jetzt machen.
Du musst deinen Instagram-Account, wenn du unter 16 bist, zwingend an einen Erwachsenen koppeln. Und das kann aber auch nur einer sein. Es kann jetzt nicht einer der Obmann für unendlich viele sein, sodass so eine 1 zu 1-Betreuungsschaffung...
Das soll eigentlich mit den Eltern dann auch passieren.
Genau, das soll eigentlich die Idee sein.
Und sonst kann man zwar, also man kann dennoch Instagram verwenden, nur dann ist das alles wahnsinnig eingeschränkt.
Es ist nicht wahnsinnig eingeschränkt, sondern es ist das, was er schon vor zehn Jahren bei Facebook gemacht hat. Der Ausgangsmodus ist, du publizierst nicht an die ganze Welt, sondern nur deine Freunde können das sehen.
Richtig, und wenn du aber möchtest, dass das alle sehen können, dann musst du von deinen Eltern jemanden haben, der dann so diese Parenting macht. Das interessante ist nun aber, du musst ja selbst einen Instagram-Account als Elternteil haben, damit das geht. Weil das wurde jetzt so schön verkauft, wie ja, jetzt tun die was dagegen. Nee, eigentlich akquirieren die noch mal ein neues Publikum, weil die Kinder jetzt ihren Eltern in den Ohren legen und sagen, du musst dich bei Instagram anmelden, damit du meinen Account verifizieren kannst, damit ich da mehr machen kann. Das heißt, eigentlich hat er jetzt eine Strategie geschaffen, bei der er signalisiert, ich tue was für die Minderjährigen. Sogleich bedeutet das aber, dass er noch mehr auf seine Plattform holt, weil die müssen dort sein. Du kannst nicht sagen, die Eltern schreiben eine E-Mail, verifizieren irgendetwas, das wäre ja alles möglich. Die Eltern müssten ja nicht dafür extra einen Account haben. Aber genau das wird jetzt hier gemacht. Ich glaube, beim Fitnessstudio ist das auch so, dass bis zu einem gewissen Alter müssen die Eltern das unterzeichnen, dass man dort ist. Aber das heißt ja dann nicht, dass man auch als Elternteilmitglied in dem Fitnessstudio werden muss. Hier ist es aber der Fall. Der hat jetzt bald noch mal viele viele Accounts einfach nur deshalb bekommen, weil die Eltern sich da melden und vielleicht kommen die dann auch auf den Geschmack. Und dann hat er eine wunderbare Kundenakquise betrieben.
Vor allem diese Wende zu, die kommunizieren jetzt nur noch mit ihren Freunden. Ja, das ist der Zeitgeist seit fünf Jahren. Diese jungen Leute wollen nicht mit der Öffentlichkeit kommunizieren, sondern mit ihren Freunden. Da stellen die dann so ein, ob er das jetzt mit die Ford macht oder nicht.
Ich würde auch sagen, bei meinen Followern bei Instagram, ich habe, glaube ich, so knapp 30.000. Ich habe jetzt nicht alle Profile mir angesehen. Ich sehe nur, wenn neue Leute dazukommen, dass dann manchmal das bestimmt 80 Prozent derjenigen ein privates Profil haben, das man nur sehen kann, wenn man mit denen befreundet ist.
Also es ist alles, was wir hören von Mark Zuckerberg, ist absurd. Und dem muss man auch publizistisch entsprechend begegnen. Das macht hier Scott Galloway. Ich habe es schon angesprochen. Er kommt ja immer wieder drauf zu sprechen. Er macht es dann immer gut. Wir hören uns das jetzt knapp zwei Minuten an. Was ist das Geschäftsmodell von Facebook? So, wir wissen, er möchte gerne, dass das Meta heißt, damit wir nicht mehr an Facebook denken. Facebook spielt auch immer eine kleinere Rolle. Es ist vor allem Instagram, was jetzt so und dann seine komischen Technik-Spielereien, in der er hofft, irgendwann in 20 Jahren gibt es dann ein neues Technik-Paradigmata. Also es ist nicht mehr ein Smartphone oder was auch immer.
Sehr bescheuert.
Und Scott Galloway beschreibt jetzt mal das Zentrale und wie ich finde, auch einzige ihn reich machende Geschäftsmodell, das Facebook, Meta, Instagram wie auch immer darstellt.
Und das ist, lass mich empfangen, lass mich Algorithmen kreieren, so dass Frauen unter 18 Jahren, Minoren, sich selbst sexualisieren. Und dann lass ich ihre Pferde und seltsame Männer aus der ganzen Welt kommentieren. Okay, diese Speziale Retailer sind nur in der Arbeit, um Teenagerinnen wie Schlotten zu dressen. Und es gab eine, die Mütter gingen verrückt, und der Congressman gingen verrückt. Was ist Instagram für 15-jährige? Es ist Wohlfahnen. Es ist alles Wohlfahnen. Es ist weder Wohlfahnen, oder eigentliche Wohlfahnen. Oder Cinemax. Und ich war nicht erlaubt, den Exorzisten zu sehen, als ich 17 war. Ich meine, wir haben wieder einmal entschieden, es gibt einen ganz anderen Set von Standards.
Das ist das P-Diddy-Business, was hier abläuft.
Ja.
Aber 100 Milliarden. Zuckerberg beschreibt jetzt, wir sind nicht schuld daran, dass Instagram so freizügig benutzt wird. Da haben auch die Smartphone-Hersteller eine Mitschuld.
Aber ich denke nicht, dass das primär eine Social Media-Tasche ist. Auch die Tecnologie-Aktivitäten.
Da müssen jetzt jenseits der unternehmerischen Verantwortung der genannten Unternehmen noch mal Apple und Google irgendwas machen. So, sondern da fühle ich mich gut aufgehoben. Nur Instagram verwandelt die ganze Welt in so einen Nacktheits-Zombie-Zirkus.
Ja, deshalb findet ja auch all die Akquise von OnlyFans-Profile über Instagram oder TikTok statt. Und da geht es ja nicht um SEO, also um Suchmaschinenoptimierung. Die Profile sind ja gar nicht auffindbar per Suchmaschine, weil OnlyFans so angelegt ist, dass man es gar nicht finden kann.
Ja, also das ist wirklich grotesk. Und jetzt redet er sich auch nochmal raus beim Thema Mental Health.
Ich sage nicht, dass es alle Fäden falsch sind. Ich würde sagen, dass die Möglichkeit, Notifikationen zu bekommen und zu verabschieden, aus meiner Sicht, ist ein viel größerer Kontributor zu mentalen Gesundheitsproblemen.
Als wenn man mit Elon Musk in einen Ring steigen kann.
Wir haben das deutsche Phänomen jetzt bei Stefan Raab gesehen, der immens reich ist und dann nichts besseres weiß für ein Comeback, als sich nochmal zu verkloppen. Also da merkt man doch schon, dass diese sehr reichen Leute überhaupt keinen Horizont haben, um etwas Schönes und Intelligentes zu tun.
Irgendetwas stimmt mit diesen Leuten nicht. Grundsätzlich. Also wir haben das in der Politik.
Rutger Brechmann.
Und wir haben das hier auch. Und es scheint mir aber, das ist jetzt nur exemplarisch. Alles, was ich lese über Superreiche oder was ich erlebe, wenn sie reden, ist dasselbe. Die wissen nicht weiter, denken, sie können sich alles unterordnen, erfüllen sich alle ihre Wünsche und stehen danach trotzdem. Wir würden nicht sagen, dass er jetzt ein super glücklicher Mensch ist, sondern er stellt sich die ganze Zeit ein, also er verwandelt sich eigentlich so ein Kämpfer gegen die ganze Welt. Das ist ja gar nicht nötig. Er könnte ja genauso gut einfach jeder amerikanischen Uni in den Schwimmbad hinstellen und sagen, die nächsten Olympiasiege in 20 Jahren sind auch meine. Das ganze Land würde sagen, zu Recht. Und dann gäbe es großen Applaus und man würde ihn nie wieder vergessen. Stattdessen, nee, er muss jetzt Instagram durchprügeln. So, das ist jetzt sein biografisches Schicksal. Instagram, die nächsten 20 Jahre davon zu befreien, dass man da schlecht drüber redet. Es ist wirklich, es ist grotesk.
Wir sprechen jetzt über Fake News. Denn es gab einen Bürgerrat, mal wieder.
Aber ich habe ihn nicht mitbekommen. So ein Bundesregierungsthema.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass dieses Bürgerratsthema uns so verfolgt.
Beteiligung, Beteiligung, Mitbestimmung, Mitbestimmung.
Bürgerrat mit dem Titel Forum gegen Fakes. Ja, wie gehen wir dieses Thema an? Vielleicht hören wir erst mal den Leuten zu, die das mit organisiert haben von der Bertelsmann Stiftung. Zum Beispiel Dominik Hirlemann, der äußert sich jetzt mal zu diesem Thema Demokratie. Was muss eigentlich jetzt gemacht werden gegen all die Fake News?
Demokratie ist ja zum globalen Kampffeld geworden. Und dahingehend, dass nichtdemokratische Akteure, Länder ein großes Interesse haben, ja gezielt unsere Demokratie zu destabilisieren. Und ihr habt es genannt, Desinformation ist hier das große Schlagwort. Insgesamt glaube ich aber schon, dass wir etwas vorsichtiger sein müssen, wenn wir über die Demokratie reden. Ja, wir dürfen sie nicht schlecht reden. Allzu schnell kann das eine selbst erfüllende Prophezeiung werden. Also wenn man die ganze Zeit motzt, dann muss man sich nicht wundern, wenn die Leute am Ende des Tages andere Systeme gut finden.
Und deshalb hat man sich gesagt, wir losen aus oder casten 120 Leute. Sie sollten verschieden alt sein, verschiedene Berufe ausführen. Wir kennen das alles. Sie sollen dann aber repräsentativ für das Land stehen. Und diese 120 Leute tun sich an mehreren Tagen zusammen und sprechen dann darüber, wie man gegen Fake News vorgehen kann. Wie kriegen wir wieder die Wahrheit mitten in unsere Gesellschaft? Wir hören jetzt die Kollegin von Hirlemann, Kathleen Berger, die sagt Folgendes.
Eine Herausforderung, die wir uns im demokratischen System stellen müssen, ist vor allem auch die digitale Transformation, die uns alle betrifft. Und ich glaube, wenn wir das übereinander legen, was passiert eigentlich technisch und wo findet der Diskurs, der Austausch von Demokratie statt, wie passiert das? Und was ich wahrnehme oder was ich in meiner Forschung wirklich immer wieder sehe, ist, dass wir leben in einer Zeit von Polykrisen. Also jeder ist irgendwie mit seinem Alltag quasi überfordert, weil man ja hat die Klimakrise, man muss mit wirtschaftlichen Zwängen reden, wir hatten eine Pandemie, es gibt Kriege überall in der Welt, es ist eine große Unsicherheit. Und gerade zu Wahlzeiten ist es ja Aufgabe der Demokratien, Ideen anzubieten, Visionen zu liefern. Wie wollen wir mit diesen komplexen Themen umgehen? Was wollen wir machen? Und das wird quasi angegriffen durch Manipulationskampagnen, in dem man simple Lösungen für etwas liefert, was eigentlich wirklich eine Kaskade von vielen Menschen braucht. Und gerade im digitalen...
Ich mache mal gerade Stopp hier, wir haben jetzt eben diesen wunderbaren Zusammenschnitt des März-Interviews gehört. Bietet der simple Lösung auf komplexe Fragen an?
Ja.
Sind das hilfreiche Lösungen? Nein. Ist das Fake News? Nein. Also nicht in dieser Definitionsweise. Aber man müsste sich da sowieso schon mal fragen, was ist eigentlich mit Fake News gemeint? Wir hören mal weiter.
Das Kurs, um diese Komponente reinzubringen. Die sozialen Plattformen, die uns ja letzten Endes erst seit 15, 20 Jahren beschäftigen, ist ja nicht so, als ob die immer da waren, haben einerseits eine Demokratisierung unseres Diskurses gebracht, weil jeder mitreden kann und zwar sichtbar für alle, global über Grenzen hinweg. Das ist fantastisch. Gleichzeitig gibt es dadurch keine redaktionelle Aufsicht mehr. Journalistische Inhalte werden quasi gleichgestellt mit meiner Meinung. Was einerseits bereichernd wirken kann, aber in solchen Situationen, wo es darum geht, ist das ein Fakt oder lügt hier einfach nur jemand? Das ist, glaube ich, auch eine wichtige Unterscheidung. Desinformationskampagnen sind Lügen. Es ist keine Idee, kein neues Konzept, was man eigentlich hat, sondern es geht darum, wirklich zu manipulieren. Diese Balance, was macht es mit unserem Diskurs, dass das gleichgestellt ist, mit den Konsequenzen leben wir jetzt gerade. Und damit haben wir uns auseinandergesetzt.
Ich will ja nicht kleinreden, dass verschiedene Akteure, zum Beispiel auch autoritäre Staaten, sich darüber freuen, wenn sie Fake News in deutschen Kanälen verbreiten können.
Das ist ja so.
Nur habe ich so ein bisschen den Verdacht, und das zeigte sich auch eben schon an dieser Kreml-Propaganda, die die ganze Zeit dem BSW und anderen unterstellt wurde, dass man glaubt, das sei immer etwas von außen so da ist. Man kann ja über die Algorithmen sprechen, wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass gewisse Inhalte derart gepusht werden, oder wie kann es sein, dass Nacktheit siegt bei Instagram. Genauso kann man das auch für einige politische Inhalte sagen. Nur diese Sache mit den Fake-Kampagnen ist ja immer die Frage, welche Wahrheit ist denn jetzt die richtige Wahrheit? Ich will jetzt nicht in so einen Radikalkonstruktivismus verfallen. Nur gerade, wenn wir jetzt über die Besteuerung von Vermögen sprechen, dann gibt es da sehr unterschiedliche Ansichten. Und wir haben hier selbst schon, so Clips gehört aus einem Presseclub, da sitzt dann von der Rheinischen Post eine Dame, die sagt, nein, das Problem sind eigentlich die Bürgergeldempfänger. Ja, ist das Fake News?
Verstehe ich das richtig, dass hier schon Ergebnisse verkündet wurden? Also die haben schon getagt.
Oh ja, jetzt kommt es gleich. Wir bekommen jetzt erstmal nochmal ein Klip, wie das mit dem Bürgerrat so war.
Lass mich nur kurz auf deinen Einband, das kommt ja immer von innen und so. Ich will nur daran erinnern, es wurden jetzt diese Fernsehpreise verliehen. Wir haben also Sandra Maischberger's Fragen, du hast sie uns ja mitgebracht, ohne Antwort und Kontext. Einfach nur, was wird da so gefragt.
Und jetzt hat sie den Fernsehpreis.
Sie hat jetzt den Fernsehpreis gewonnen. Und jetzt können wir uns natürlich zu lustig machen. Sollten wir auch. Also es ist einfach absurd. Aber in der Diskussion, wie sie gerade vorbereitet wird, in der uns gleich Ergebnisse von diskursiven Auseinandersetzungen verkündet werden, steht Sandra Maischberger auf der guten, der hellen und relevanten Seite dessen, wogegen man hier kämpft. Und ich würde sagen, naja, aber ihr müsst doch gegen Sandra Maischberger kämpfen.
Richtig. Das ist genau der Punkt. Und die sagen nämlich, es gibt die Medien, die machen alle keine Fake News, die machen alle das, die verkünden die Wahrheit, Pluralvielfältigkeit, etc.
Dingo informiert uns doch nur.
Ja. Die anderen, da ist Fake News. Und wir wissen ja, du hast ja eben das Wagenknecht Beispiel genannt, 100 Talkshows im Jahr oder was auch immer, ja. Wir wissen ja, ihr Erfolg liegt doch nicht daran, dass da 100.000 Euro in Russland ausgegeben werden, um ein paar Fake-Memes zu produzieren, sondern ihr Erfolg liegt doch daran, dass sie jeden Abend vor einem Millionenpublikum da sitzen kann und sagen kann, also diese Ampel ist die dümmste Regierung der Welt.
Ja, der Karl-Rudolf Korte, der ja mal wieder Wahlergebnisse einschätzt, hat beide an dem Thüringen Sachsen-Wochenende gemeint, Sarah Wagenknechts Erfolg ist durch nichts zu erklären, außer durch ihr Talkshow-Mandat und kein Journalist. Und der ist ja dann selber in den Medien, um das zu sagen, knüpft daran an. Ja, das wird einfach ausgeblendet. Ach so, sie hatten Talkshow-Mandat von uns oder was? Oh ja, das wird einfach nicht thematisiert.
Ich habe übrigens, weil du das gerade nochmal sagst, mit dem Talkshow-Mandat nochmal darüber nachgedacht, mit Franziska Brandner, wenn sie das jetzt wird, also die neue Parteispitze der Grünen. Und da ist noch Andreas Outridge zum Beispiel auch im Gespräch. Das sind ja alles keine Talkshow-Leute. Und ich habe den Verdacht, dass Habeck genau das will, damit er eingeladen wird. Denn Likada Lang sitzt gerne in Talkshows, Noripur sitzt gerne in Talkshows, Habeck sitzt aber auch sehr gern dort. Und die Leute werden nicht die Brandner einladen und den Outridge wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Also einladen werden sie sich schon.
Ja, mal. Aber für die Show lädt man dann doch lieber den Habeck.
Genau. Das Problem ist so ein bisschen, Franziska Brandner kennt sich mit allen Themen sehr gut aus.
Ja.
Nur Inhalte, also glauben sie noch dran, Inhalte spielen halt in Talkshows keine Rolle. Sie hat genau die Qualifikation, die sie nicht geeignet macht für eine Talkshow. Und auch nicht für den Parteivorsitz, weil das Parteivorsitzmandat ist ein Talkshowmandat.
Es sei denn, man will gar nicht, dass die anderen da so groß vorkommen.
Genau. Wenn Robert Habeck sich als Zampano noch mal oben drüber steht und den Parteivorsitz schon als erste Arbeitsebene, nur das muss er dann ernsthaft erfinden. Da reicht es nicht, das Personal so zu strukturieren, sondern das muss er dann wirklich, ich weiß nicht.
Helemann stellt uns jetzt den Bürgerrat vor.
Das Bewusstsein für Desinformation nimmt zu. Also in einer unserer Studien konnten wir zeigen, dass 81 Prozent der Deutschen sagen, ja, das ist eine Gefahr für unsere Demokratie und den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt. Und deshalb haben wir das vor Umgang.
Also man stellt diese Frage auch in der Marktforschung. Finden Sie Werbung sehr manipulativ? Ja, Werbung manipuliert immer. Haben Sie sich schon mal von Werbung manipulieren lassen? Nein, nein, nein, nein, noch nie. Ich durchschaue das immer. So ist das hier auch. Das ist völlig bescheuert....
gegen Fakes initiiert, weil wir der Meinung sind, dass wir bei großen gesellschaftlichen Fragen und Herausforderungen ja auch große Prozesse brauchen, wo sich Menschen beteiligen können. Also wenn Bürger nur das Gefühl haben, dass Politik sie überfällt, dann ziehen sie sich zurück.
Ich verstehe dieses Argument nicht. Ich habe es jetzt aber auch von allen Ecken gehört. Dieses Bürgerrat-Ding ist ja nicht nur bei Steffen Mau jetzt auch Katrin Göring-Eckardt hat auch lang und breit vom Bürgerrat erzählt. Dann heißt es immer ja, den Menschen das Gefühl geben und all das. Ich glaube ja sogar, dass das den 120 Leuten, die dann dort auserkoren wurden, so geht. Nur mir als Bürger geht es ja dadurch nicht besser, dass ich weiß, da haben 120 Leute an drei Wochenenden zusammengesessen.
Deutschland ist groß, man sieht das immer wieder. Vor allem diese Abkehr der Inhalte muss man hier besonders ernst nehmen. Die Leute wollen nicht politisch mitmachen, sondern sie wollen mitmachen. Sie wollen da, wo es ihnen wichtig ist, dass es Einflugsschneisen gibt und auch eine Hoheit über ein Budget. Also Vereinsleben, Nachbarschaft, Gestalten. Nur wenn jeder mal kommt mit, da haben wir leider kein Geld. Das geht leider nicht. Nee, die T-Shirts müssen die Kinder selber bezahlen. Ihr wollt Pokale? Nee, wir haben kein Geld für Pokale. Also wenn das, dann ist man halt resigniert. Das ist aber längst vor der Politik, dass man dann auch noch von Politik resigniert ist. Ja, oh Wunder. Aber gleich mit Politik einsteigen. Ich meine, kann man den Leuten nicht erstmal ihren Alltag zugestehen? Die haben doch konkrete und echte Sachen zu regeln. So und da wird ihnen schon jede Handlungsmöglichkeit genommen. Da braucht man gar nicht mit Politik kommen.
Bei großen Fragen, große Bürgerbeteiligungsprozesse. Und die Fragen, die wir da versuchen zu beantworten, sind also wie wir uns schützen vor Desinformation, wie wir unsere Meinungsfreiheit gleichzeitig schützen, wie wir mit dem Einfluss fremder Mächte umgehen.
Eine der größten Schicksalsfragen, der wir uns gerade stellen, ist doch VW. Bleiben VW, 100.000 Arbeitsplätze, unendlich viel Stiftungskapital, der Vereinssport wird da unterstützt, der ganze Kram. Ich würde jetzt mal sagen, an dem Schicksal von VW ist wirklich jeder beteiligt, der ein Auto kauft. Mehr beteiligen kann man die Leute gar nicht, als zu sagen, es ist sogar für dich eine Frage, ob du das Cash bezahlen kannst oder noch mal ein Kredit brauchst, ob du jemanden anpumpst und so weiter. Mehr involvieren kann man jemand gar nicht, als über sein kleines Kapital, dass man so als normaler Mensch damit reinbringt. Und trotzdem kann VW diese Sache gerade nicht mit der Bevölkerung dem Volkswagen-Käufer klären. Brauchen wir also mehr Beteiligung oder einfach ein Management und eine Politik, die im Kleinen einfach mal jetzt einen Markt gestalten, statt einfach irgendwelche Diskussionen zu führen, weil irgendwer sagt, ne, ein Verbrenner wäre schon cool und so. Ja, also dieses Beteiligungsargument geht relativ schnell, einfach fehl. Das ist überhaupt nicht richtig, in diese Richtung zu gehen.
Ich habe auch noch selten jemanden getroffen, der sagt, ich würde so gerne beteiligt sein. Also im Sinne von, ich würde mal gerne irgendwo sitzen und das ausdiskutieren.
Stell dir mal vor, du gehst zur Rewe und dann fragen die dich, wo möchten sie ihre Milch im Regal stehen haben? Und du denkst dir, bitte, das ist mir doch scheißegal. Stell sie irgendwo hin, Hauptsache sie steht dann immer da, ist erwartbar, fertig. Man will nicht beteiligt werden. Man will, dass die Sachen funktionieren. Und bei den Sachen, die man selber in die Hand nimmt, will man gerne eine kleine Erfolgsgarantie haben. Und die hat man nicht.
Die Herausforderung von künstlicher Intelligenz. So wie machen wir das? Wir machen es zum einen mit anderen Stiftungen zusammen, mit Stiftung Mercator und der Michael Otto Foundation for Sustainability, auch mit Unterstützung von T-Online, Medial. Und wir machen es in Kooperation mit dem Bundesinnenministerium. Und wir machen das auf eine, und da sind wir ganz stolz drauf, weltweit einzigartige Weise.
Jetzt, pass auf, weltweit einzigartig.
So noch nicht stattgefunden. Wir kombinieren nämlich ein Bürgerrat, sodass es ja ein Format, ein Verfahren, was sich zunehmend in Deutschland durchsetzt, mit zufällig ausgewählten Bürgerinnen und Bürgern. Und da haben wir 120 an der Zahl aus ganz Deutschland zufällig ausgewählt, alle Regionen, unterschiedliche Bildungsschichten, unterschiedlich alt, also sehr, sehr divers. Und diesen Prozess des Bürgerrats, also wo Menschen miteinander über mehrere Wochen diskutieren, haben wir kombiniert mit einer breiten Online-Konsultation. Also wir hatten eine Website, wo alle Menschen in Deutschland mitmachen konnten, Ideen ja hochladen konnten, Meinungen einstellen konnten. Und das haben wir kombiniert.
Wir haben etwa 130.000 Hörer bei einer regulären Folge. Ich würde mal tippen, zwei Hörer wussten davon, dass es diese Homepage gibt.
Ja, das ist schon viel. Ich würde sagen, einer. Also ich wusste nichts davon.
Ich natürlich auch nicht. So, wir hören weiter.
Wir haben nicht nur gesammelt, sondern es gab Ideen und die Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer haben intensiv diskutiert, Deliberation über das Ganze. Also sie haben im besten Sinne gestritten und dann auch wieder versucht, Gemeinsamkeiten zu finden.
Also es wurde das Beste rausgeschält.
Genau, genau. Und dann ist Umsetzung natürlich ein Riesenthema. Weil das beste Beteiligungsprojekt ist nichts, wenn am Ende nichts passiert. Wenn dann dann führt das Ganze nur zu Frust. Und wir haben ja weniger Beteiligung als mehr am Ende des Tages. Und gerade deshalb haben wir mit dem Bundesinnenministerium zusammengearbeitet. Die Bundesregierung erarbeitet derzeit ihre Strategie zum Umgang mit Desinformation. Und die Ergebnisse unseres Projekts fließen in die Strategie mit ein. Und wir sind da nur der Mittler.
Ich will es noch ein bisschen spannend machen und noch nicht Ergebnisse vorstellen. Denn ich möchte Teilnehmer zu Wort kommen. Es gab auch so ein Image-Video und da sehen wir uns jetzt mal, hören wir uns jetzt mal an, was die Bürgerer Teilnehmer sozusagen haben.
Ich selber poste auch manchmal Sachen, wo ich mir gar nicht viel Gedanken drüber mache. Inzwischen sehe ich es ein bisschen anders. Man kann da ja doch ganz schön viel Schaden mit anrichten.
Die Masse der Menschen, es schläft noch und hat es irgendwie noch nicht im Kopf. Ich möchte, dass es laut und deutlich plakativ zu sehen.
Wir haben uns mit dem Thema, wie kann man das Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung im Artikel 5 des Grundgesetzes erhalten, gleichzeitig aber diese um sich greifenden Lügen und falsche und gezielte Desinformation trotzdem einzugrenzen und zu sanktionieren.
Ich war einfach beeindruckt von dieser Idee, den kleinen Bürger mitzuintegrieren, dass man einfach fernab von Wahlen zum Beispiel die Interessen bzw. die Vorschläge des kleinen Bürgers direkt an den Politiker ranbringt, so als würde man direkt mit ihnen sprechen, fand ich super, dass man selber Einfluss nehmen kann, auch ich als relativ junger Mitbürger noch, dass man trotzdem in einer Demokratie so weit an die Politik rankommt, das fand ich super faszinierend.
So weit, dass man Nancy Faeser ein Papier überreicht.
Zu dieser Frau am Anfang, die meinte, die Menschen schlafen alle noch und so, ne? Ja, weil man so denkt, haben die Fake News immer eine Chance. Weil du so denkst, auch wenn du jetzt gerade denkst, du bist auf der besseren Seite.
Die Fake News funktionieren ja so, dass sie einem sagen, wacht auf, schlaft nicht länger. Es ist eigentlich ganz anders.
Es ist doch nun wirklich allseits bekannt, wenn man die Leute fragt, halten sie sich für den überdurchschnittlichen Autofahrer, sagen alle ja.
Ja.
Das kann doch nicht der Ansatz sein.
Aber ich bin es wirklich.
Ja, ich bin ein Über-Überdurchschnittlicher Autofahrer. Das ist wirklich nicht gut. Was ich da höre, ist nicht gut. Wenn wir so etwas in der Case spielen, sitzen immer hunderte Leute vor uns, den kann man im Gesicht so ein bisschen sehen, du bist hier nicht allein und so. Ich höre den Mist gerade genauso wie du. Aber hier, wenn man dem so ausgeliefert ist, fühlt man sich doch sehr einsam in dieser Welt.
Wir haben jetzt ja schon mal gehört, Meinungsfreiheit scheint wichtig zu sein, aber dieser Artikel 5, das stört ja auch ein bisschen. Wir hören mal noch weiter.
Die Hoffnung habe ich, dass es auf fruchtbaren Boden fällt, dass die Bedeutung erkannt wird und dass es auch Mittel und Ressourcen gibt, um mit unseren Empfehlungen zumindest einige von ihnen auch umzusetzen. Denn das Leben wird nicht einfacher, es wird immer schwieriger.
Einmal, was ich jetzt über die zwei Wochenenden gemerkt habe, ist, dass ultra viele Menschen hier sind, die sich bisher nicht angesprochen haben, viel gefühlt haben von dem, was in der Politik abgeht und sich so darüber gefreut haben, endlich mal die Gelegenheit zu haben, hier ihre Meinung zu äußern und das Gefühl zu haben, dass sie auch gehört werden, dass sie mal endlich mehr Mitbestimmungsrecht haben.
Also in meiner Gruppe, die hat mich einfach nur begeistert. Wir haben sehr wertschätzend miteinander gesprochen, diskutiert, auch mit Konflikten diskutiert. Und ich habe ein super gutes Gefühl. Ich glaube, wir haben ein richtig gutes Empfehlungskonzept.
Ja, kommen wir doch mal zu diesem Empfehlungskonzept.
Kennst du Social AI?
Nein.
Ein neues soziales Netzwerk, in dem du der einzige Nutzer bist. Alle anderen sind AI.
Ah.
Und du postest einfach, du machst die App auf, sieht aus wie bei Twitter, du sollst was posten. Stellst du zum Beispiel eine Frage. Wir haben ja zehntausende Follower, also wir kriegen ja immer Antworten. Es geht ja nicht allen so. Das heißt, ich könnte jetzt hier reinschreiben, was soll ich heute Abend essen? Blablabla. Und dann kommen sofort verschiedene Nutzer, die darauf reagieren. Dem gehe ich dann weiter nach. Also irgendwer schreit Pizza, dann frage ich den, welche Pizza? Und dann kläre ich das mit dem so im Gespräch. Also schält sich so nach und nach einfach ein Gespräch heraus und eine soziale Landkarte, wo ich sehe, ach, dieses Profil hat mir doch schon bei der Frage geholfen, jetzt bleibe ich dem mal treu und so weiter. Und dann gestaltet sich das so. Und ich glaube, das ist die Lösung. Auch bei politischen Diskussionen. Wir haben dieses GPT-Thema. GPT ist ja erst mal nur, du hast halt so eine Google-Suchleiste, die gibt dir genau eine Antwort. Das ist unbefriedigend, du willst ja diskutieren. Ich glaube, im Widerstreit, 120 Leute, echte Menschen, diskutieren irgendwas und haben die ganze Zeit so abstrahierte Ideen, dass sie jetzt da rausgehen und den Leuten die Aufklärung geben. Sie haben ja so schön diskutiert, im besten Sinne gestritten und so Scheiße. Wenn du Fragen hast zu irgendwas, Superreichtum, was soll ich heute Abend essen, wie gieße ich meine Pflanze, frag Social AI. Dafür brauchst du keine Mitmenschen. Mitmenschen brauchst du für Leben, Liebe, Leidenschaft, was auch immer und nicht sowas. Das ist doch wirklich Ressourcenverschwendung von menschlicher Intelligenz.
60 Seiten ist das PDF lang mit den Empfehlungen des Bürgerrats.
Sind sie besser als bei der Ernährung, als man festgestellt hat, kostenlose Mittagessen sind gut?
Nein, das ist ganz grauenhaft. Ich bringe jetzt hier zwei Beispiele mit und die haben ja auch für ein bisschen Chororo gesorgt. Weil ja sehr schade ist, dass solche Dinge fast nur noch von Rechten Verrückten, wenn ich sie jetzt mal ganz bewusst kritisiert werden, die aber eigentlich müssten da alle sagen, hör doch bitte auf.
Und zwar, Also sehr gute Kritik.
Zustimmung des Bürgerrats 91 Prozent. Man gibt dann immer an, wie viele Leute dafür waren innerhalb des Bürgerrats. Also 91 Prozent sind für Folgendes. Die Verhinderung der Erstellung und Verbreitung von Desinformation durch Strafverfolgung und oder Sanktionierung. Folgende Maßnahmen werden vorgeschlagen. Strafverfolgung. Die Bundesregierung möge prüfen, ob auf Grundlage der Definition von Desinformation eine strafrechtliche Verfolgung oder anderweitige Sanktionierung möglich ist.
Das heißt, du postest...
91 Prozent sind da dafür.
Sind da dafür. Das heißt, du postest etwas Falsches.
Ja.
Und dann müssen wir da leider die Skizzen bringen.
Ich poste etwas Richtiges, aber es lässt sich nicht richtig verifizieren. Also stehe ich die ganze Zeit in der Gefahr, jetzt strafrechtlich relevant.
Also ich empfehle dir, dir so eine Rechtsabteilung wie Mark Zuckerbergs zuzulegen. Und dann kannst du weiterhin.
Und nur noch Wikipedia-Artikel posten.
Ja.
Nichts anderes.
Sonst sollte man keinen Podcast mehr aufnehmen. Also das muss man sich mal vorstellen, dass 91 Prozent dafür sind. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass das irgendein Bürgerrat ist, sondern wir haben es gerade gehört, da ist T-Online mit dran. Mercator-Stiftung, Bertelsmann-Stiftung. Präsentiert hat dieses Papier Konstantin von Notz von den Grünen, der sagt, Putin steuert Parteien wie AfD und BSW. Alle ins Gefängnis. Ihre Erfolge sind sein Erfolg gegen Europa, die USA, Demokratie plus Rechtsstaatlichkeit. Das Beschweigen dieser Fakten durch Konservative plus Libertäre hilft diesen antiwestlichen Plänen. So kompliziert ist das leider. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, aber was du da jetzt gerade geschildert hast, ist doch sehr simpel gestrickt. Und er verteidigt auch diesen, diesen Bürgerrat. So jetzt kommt noch eine zweite Maßnahme. Die hat sogar 92 Prozent Zustimmung. Er ist das Ziel. Die Gesellschaft soll schnell, effizient und unbürokratisch vor der gezielten Verbreitung falscher Informationen geschützt werden. Dafür braucht es eine parteiunabhängige zentrale Stelle zur Meldung, Prüfung und Richtigstellung von Desinformationen. Sowie zur Aufklärung. Maßnahmen, die wir empfehlen, die Einrichtung einer zentralen Stelle zu Desinformationen. Also sie wollen ein Wahrheitsministerium.
Was?
Was ist denn da los?
Ich bin auch schockiert darüber.
Dann haben die so einen Bericht geschrieben und vorgestellt.
Ja und das wurde auch und da hat selbst Nancy Felser gesagt, naja, das finde ich nicht so gut.
Also wir reden ja gleich noch über Thüringen.
Ja.
Kein Satz davon, den wir sagen, lässt sich irgendwie Wikipedia getreu festhalten und wäre nicht strafrechtlich relevant oder müsste einem Wahrheitsministerium vorgelegt werden, damit dann unbürokratisch, was soll das überhaupt sein, unbürokratisch. Also wir haben eine Einrichtung, aber keine Bürokratie.
Genau, da sitzen einfach drei Leute, die machen Daumen rauf oder runter und sonst kommen die Handstellen. Das ist wirklich grotesk, wenn man das hier hört. Und ich will sagen, es wird dann von rechts diskutiert. Hier zum Beispiel, bringen wir einen Clip mit Nios.
Nancy Faeser und ihr allgegenwärtiger Kampf gegen Desinformation geht in die nächste Runde. Unter dem Deckmantel der Demokratie soll weiter gegen unliebsame Meinungen vorgegangen werden. Das fordert nun auch der Bürgerrat des Projektes Forum gegen Fakes. Der selbst ernannte Bürgerrat übergab diese Woche in Berlin einen Forderungskatalog an Innenministerin Nancy Faeser. Unter anderem soll das Portal Korrektiv in Wahlkämpfen Desinformationsrankings erstellen. Ausgerechnet Korrektiv, die ja erwiesenermaßen selbst der Verbreitung von Falschinformationen überführt wurden. In diesem Zusammenhang interessant zu wissen, die Mercator-Stiftung, einer der größten Financiers von Korrektiv, taucht ebenfalls als Geldgeber bei Forum gegen Fakes auf. Und auch die Bundesregierung war bereits vor acht Monaten öffentlich für die Arbeit des Bürgerrates. Faeser kündigte an, die Forderung überprüfen zu wollen.
Ja, also Faeser will dieses Wahrheitsministerium jetzt nicht. Und man muss auch der Fairness halber sagen, das stimmt somit korrektiv nicht. Die werden zwar auch in diesem Bericht als vorbildlich erwähnt, aber es geht jetzt nicht darum, dass korrektiv schon auf dem Wege ist, dieses Ministerium zu prüfen.
Ich verstehe das total, dass sie so eine Newsmeldung da haben.
Ja, ich kann es auch total verstehen und finde es eben skandalös, dass es von anderen gar nicht skandalisiert wird, denn es ist im Ganzen ein Skandal. Und dann dachte ich mir, ist es doch jetzt ein guter Zeitpunkt, um nochmal ein bisschen über Meinungsfreiheit, Pressefreiheit, all das nachzudenken. Denn wir hatten ja dieses angestrebte Kompaktverbot und hören jetzt nochmal aus dem Augustentageshow-Bericht darüber.
Bundesinnenministerin Faeser hat das vom Verfassungsschutz als rechtsextremistisch eingestufte Magazin Kompakt verboten. Es sei ein zentrales Sprachrohr der rechtsextremistischen Szene, so Faeser. Nach Angaben der Behörden durchsuchen Einsatzkräfte seit dem frühen Morgen Räume des Magazins sowie Wohnungen von Geschäftsführungen Anteilseigner in Brandenburg, in Hessen, Sachsen und Sachsen-Anhalt. Dabei sollen Vermögen und weitere Beweismittel sichergestellt werden.
Daran erinnern wir uns, aber dann gab es ja gleich so ein Eilverfahren und Fäsers Pläne lösen sich nicht in Luft auf, aber es wurde zumindest Luft rausgenommen.
Das rechtsgerichtete Kompaktmagazin darf vorläufig wieder erscheinen. Das hat das Bundesverwaltungsgericht gestern entschieden und damit das Verbot von Innenministerin Faeser erst mal ausgesetzt. Eine endgültige Entscheidung soll in einem Hauptverfahren fallen. Mehrere Politiker der Regierungsparteien und aus der Opposition kritisieren, Faeser hätte das Verbot nicht ausreichend vorbereitet und begründet. Die Kompaktredaktion feiert die Entscheidung. Chefredakteur Elzessa bezeichnete sie heute in einer Pressekonferenz als Sieg gegen die Innenministerin.
Der gestrige Tag war der wichtigste Tag zur Verteidigung der Pressefreiheit seit der Spiegelaffäre 1962. Damals hat das Hamburger Nachrichtenmagazin obsiegt über die autoritären Übergriffigkeiten, vor allem des Verteidigungsministers Franz Josef Strauß, der dann zurücktreten musste. Und so hat Kompaktmagazin gestern obsiegt über die autoritären, um nicht zu sagen faschistischen Übergriffigkeiten, der Innenministerin Nancy Faeser. Der gestrige Tag war ein Sieg von David über Goliath, war ein Sieg der Demokratie über die Diktatur und war ein Sieg des Volkes über das Regime. Kurz gesagt, war ein Sieg von Kompakt über Nancy Faeser.
Ja, Faeser hat also Jürgen Elsasser eine tolle Bühne geboten, dass er jetzt Landesbekannt ist. Ich würde nämlich sagen, vorher kannte den nicht jeder.
Das hat er ja selber in Zahlen ausgedrückt. Er hat gesagt, vorher kannten uns zwei Millionen Menschen, jetzt 60 Millionen. Ich würde sagen, okay, ich glaube nicht, dass sie sich 60 Millionen kennen. Und ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass jetzt der Vergleich mit Spiegel damals statthaft ist oder irgendwas anderes, was er gerade alles so reingerührt hat.
Jaja, aber man sieht, dass dieses Konzept von Faeser ja überhaupt nicht aufgegangen ist. Wir hören nochmal hier aus der Tagesschau.
Nancy Faeser selber hat sich gerade geäußert in einem sogenannten Doorstep, also vor der Tür, bei einer Pressekonferenz eigentlich zu einem anderen Thema und Nancy Faeser hat gesagt...
Wir haben das jetzt zehn Sekunden lang gehört und er erklärt uns, dass es ein Doorstep ist, also ein spontaner und so weiter. Was glauben die Journalisten, dass ich zum Fleischer gehe und der mir erklärt, ja, also diese Haut hier ist wirklich besonders und ich will einfach nur die Wurst haben.
Kann man sehen, dass der Rechtsstaat und seine Überprüfungsmechanismen funktionieren. Sie sei aber nach wie vor optimistisch, dass im Hauptsacheverfahren das Bundesinnenministerium erfolgreich sei. Und in der Pressemitteilung, auch wie gesagt, die Urteilsgründe liegen noch nicht vor. In der Pressemitteilung hat das Bundesinnenministerium ja auch das Recht eingeräumt bekommen, die konfessierten Datenträger, Festplatten und so weiter und so fort zu kopieren und diese auch noch für das Hauptsacheverfahren zu nutzen. Die Geräte müssen zurückgegeben werden und es muss auch das beschlagnahmte Geld und sonstiges Sachvermögen zurückgegeben werden. Das ist ja Teil der Eilentscheidung von gestern.
Dennis Yücel von Der Welt weiß, was Zensur ist, als er in der Türkei im Knast saß. Er hat sich auch zu Wort gemeldet.
Das Presserecht ist ein hohes Gut. Das heißt immer, das sagt man immer so in Sonntagsreden, aber es ist tatsächlich auch ein hohes Gut und das schützt auch Publikationen, die, so heißt es in einem wegweisenden Urteil des Europäischen Gerichtshofs für Menschenrechte aus dem Jahr 1976, das Presserecht schützt auch Aussagen und Informationen, die den Staat oder Teile der Bevölkerung schockieren, verletzen und so weiter. Also auch kompakt ist meines Erachtens, erst mal zumindest, die Anfangsannahmen muss so lauten, ist durch das Presserecht geschützt und diese Art, wie sich auch schon an anderen Stellen in der jüngeren Vergangenheit gezeigt hat, in der Bundesregierung zum Stichwort Fördergeldaffäre, diese Art, mit rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien so umzugehen und so viel Beachtung zu schenken, als sei es das Kleingedruckte auf einem Beipackzettel, das finde ich so tief beunruhigend und ich denke auch, dass das langfristig dem Vertrauen in die Demokratie mehr schadet, als das Herr Elseser und sein merkwürdiges Magazin jemals gekannt hätten.
Eine sehr richtige Aussage. Der Verfassungsschutz spielt bei all dem ja eine gewisse Rolle und der ist ja vor ein paar Wochen auch besonders ins Gespräch gekommen. Wir sprechen hier über den bayerischen Verfassungsschutz. Der hat ja auch so eine Liste erstellt mit Medien, die pro russische Narrative, wie es hieß, verbreiten.
Irgendwelche Podcasts drauf, die wir kennen?
Ja, pass auf. Das war interessant, dass auch dann zurückgerudert wurde. Es musste dieser Bericht korrigiert werden, denn plötzlich stand dort in diesem Bericht Junge Freiheit, der Freitag, Tischis Einblick, Junge Welt, also alles so zusammen, wo man dann sagt, na ja, also da sind andere Positionen vertreten, aber sind das jetzt die Narrative in dem Sinne des Kremls? Und auch ist ja interessant, was dieser Verfassungsschutz sonst sich so alles ansieht. Also ich habe dann zum Beispiel festgestellt, der Bayerische Landesverfassungsschutz schaut sich also an, wie so gearbeitet wird. Also es wurden dann auch noch mal so Beispiele herangezogen, für welche, also wo gibt es so Doppelgängerartikel, die angelegt wurden, weißt du, also dass man Artikel so aussehen lässt, als seien sie von einer Zeit, sind dann gar nicht da. Aber es wird dann auch doch auch erwähnt, ob irgendwo Artikel erschienen sind, die eine eher pro-russische Seite einnehmen. Und was dann für mich ganz interessant war, welche Medien im Verfassungsschutzbericht generell stehen, der wurde am 18. Juni vorgestellt. Und da heißt es, wir haben alle Schutzmaßnahmen massiv hochgefahren, um uns gegen die aktuellen Bedrohungen durch Extremismus, Terrorismus und hybride Bedrohungen zu wappnen. Und dort sind aber dann in diesem Bericht auch aufgeführt, neben Compact oder so, auch linke Influencer und Podcaster. Und ich bin gespannt, ob du es nächste an Verfassungsschutz schaffst, weil du ja jetzt die Superreichen so angegangen bist. Ich sage zum Beispiel hier, dass der Podcast zu Ende Gelände mit aufgeführt ist, weil die ja auch gegen den Kapitalismus sind. Bei Ende Gelände. Oder, was ich auch gesehen habe.
Ich bin ja für den Kapitalismus.
Ah ja, okay, dann muss das hier ausdrücklich nochmal sagen, dass du da reingerätst. Oder zum Beispiel der Podcast Über Tage. Da habe ich gedacht, Moment, die kennst du auch. Da warst du auch mal zu Gast. Das ist ein Podcast von so zwei Jungs, die sich mit anarchistischen Theorien auseinandersetzen. Ich war da mal eingeladen, ich habe dann sogar nachgeguckt, um über den deutschen Film zu sprechen. Aber offenbar weiß man nicht, was sonst noch so im Schilde geführt wird. Also irgendwelche kleinsten Podcasts werden da aufgelistet. Das war dann doch ganz erhellend mal zu sehen, denn es gab noch eine Debatte in der FAZ zum Thema Verfassungsschutz. Da haben sich Klaus Leggewie und Horsten Meyer zu Wort gemeldet. Die sagen, aber muss man wirklich bis heute eine Art FDGO-Gesinnungstüff betreiben, der nicht akute Straftaten und aktuelle Gewaltakte verfolgt, sondern Einstellungen und Haltungen von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern beobachtet? Und noch weniger verstehen wir, dass man diese Gesinnungsgouvernante heute noch zu brauchen meint, da doch das Experiment Bundesrepublik, dem Aufstieg der AfD zum Trotz alles in allem gut funktioniert. Das Weimar-Argument, wonach die erste Republik am symmetrischen Druck der beiden Extreme zugrunden gegangen und wehrlos gewesen ist, ist längst widerlegt. Diese Republik hatte durchaus Mittel, es gab zu wenig kämpferische Demokraten. Und Gerhard Baum ist nun jemand, der für den Verfassungsschutz ist. Und da sagen Legevie und Mayer, Baum erinnert daran, wie sehr er sich als Minister um die Kontrolle des Verfassungsschutzes bemühte. Chapeau. Die Geschichte des Verfassungsschutzes voller Skandale. Illegale Abhöraktionen, vertrauliche Gespräche mit mutmaßlichen Gegnern der Demokratie, fingierte Terrorakte, Akten-Schreddereien, Bespitzelung von Kritikern. Noch skandalöser war die Ernennung eines Ministerialbeamten zum Amtschef, Hans-Georg Maaßen, der gelobte, diese Ämter zu reformieren, stattdessen aber bald zum Problem wurde. Er verharmloste eine regelrechte Menschenjagd in Chemnitz. Dann kommen sie auf NSU zu sprechen. Für sie ist also damit klar, bei allen Missgrößen sind gar nicht diese Skandale es, sondern die geräuschlose Routine des ganz legalen Ausspionierens von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern, die angeblich oder tatsächlich verfassungskritische Positionen äußern. Sie sagen, das sei nicht mehr zeitgemäß. Diese Beobachtungsfälle, Verdachtsfälle, das hat auch nicht dazu geführt, dass die AfD sich deradikalisiert oder Stimmen verliert. Sie sehen das auch als ein neues Problem, dass jetzt ja so eine schwammige Rubrik eingeführt wurde, wie sie das nennen. Sie schreiben, womit der Verfassungsschutz offenbar nicht gerechnet hat, war das Auftreten neuer potenzieller Gegner der Demokratie in der Querdenkerbewegung, einem Sammelbecken politisch Anihilisten, die buchstäblich gegen alles sind. Diese diffuse Gruppe wurde unter der schwammigen neuen Rubrik verfassungsrelevanten Delegitimierung des Staates versammelt. Ja, es stimmt, diese unappetitlichen Querulanten denken wir an die Reichsbürger, könnten eines Tages so gefährlich werden, wie Donalds Trumps Putschistenmob. Aber dann muss man ihre Gegnerschaft zur Verfassung so herausarbeiten, dass nicht schon jede Kritik am Staat, an der Verfassung und am politischen Personal als Delegitimierung bezeichnet werden kann.
Ja, vor allem, wir haben jetzt eine praktische Geschichtsschreibung. Der 6. Januar 2021 liegt eine Weile zurück. Wir haben seitdem eine Beweispräsentation für Donald Trumps Mitschuld im Primetime-Abendfernsehen über mehrere Tage in Amerika gehabt. Alle Diskussionen. Das Resultat ist, nach allen juristischen Verfahren, nach allen politischen Versuchen, dass man sagt, ok, dann klären wir es halt am Wahlabend. Also alle Versuche ist, ich finde das nicht gut, will ich sagen. Also ich finde es schon gut, wenn man ein gewisses instrumentelles, institutionelles und juristisches Instrumentarium hat, um einfach mal, wir haben jetzt auch einen AfD-Verbotsantrag wohl in dieser Tage.
Genau, da bin ich auch gar nicht dagegen. Ich bin auch nicht gegen diese Prozesse, die man geführt hat gegen Trump. Nur, das ist ja ein Unterschied, ob man jetzt Leute hat, wo etwas schon geschehen ist und sagt, da müssen wir jetzt was tun, oder ob man Gesinnungen überprüft und denkt, da wurde jetzt so über Superreiche gesprochen und die Eigentumsordnung, das ist ja auch was im Grundgesetz steht. Also stehen die doch nicht auf dem Boden des Grundgesetzes. Sind es also Staatsfeinde, müssen wir da mal schon präventiv vorgehen. Das ist ja das, was nahe liegt.
Wir können ja dann den Bayerischen Verfassungsschutz die Bayerische Verfassung schicken, wo drin steht, Grund und Boden ist zu enteignen oder so ist die Losung.
Delegitimierung des Staates, das ist so ein Begriff, das kann ja alles Mögliche sein. Und wir sehen ja gerade, wie das so ausgeweitet wird. Alles wird zu einem Kreml-Narrativ oder sonst was. Da wird es sehr schwierig. Überhaupt ist diese Delegitimierung des Staates etwas, was international gerade Wellen schlägt. Es gab ein International Journalism Festival und da war Agnes Kalamath von Amnesty, die sich da für die Journalisten einsetzt. Und die kommt nochmal auf die Pegasus-Affäre, diese Überwachungs-Affäre zu sprechen. Und wir hören uns da jetzt mal vier Clips an, auch wenn es ein bisschen mühsam ist. Aber vielleicht ist es doch erhellend, das auch nochmal international zu betrachten.
At this point in time there are at least 20 countries that have been, where people have been targeted and probably far more. So far we have at least 180 journalists who we believe have been targeted by Pegasus. And these are people who are investigating corruption, who are investigating massive human rights violations. Personally I was very taken to discover that people close to Saudi journalist Jamal Khashoggi have been targeted before and after his murder. And we have some evidence of the spyware being used. Post report we know that spyware have many shapes, not just Pegasus. Last week Apple sent threat notifications to users of iPhones in 92 countries. Last week we also published another report on a different kind of spyware called the Predator Prize, which is developed in the European Union and it sold from the European Union by the Intel XA Alliance. And there too we found a very broad use of the Predator. And that just one operator, one country, could target individuals globally.
Also auch von der EU gibt es quasi neue Spy Software. Und die Frage ist dann, wie sicher sind eigentlich dann Journalisten, wenn das angewendet werden kann?
You cannot sadly expect the European Union to be leading on the regulation of the spyware at the moment. There is a lot of demands, including from Amnesty International, for the EU to take its role. But what we are witnessing is, I will say, a complicity between governments. And, I mean, probably since the member states fought to include wording that would allow spyware against journalists in so-called national security cases, setting a very dangerous precedent, especially because we know how elastic the definition of national security is including in Europe. So what you are witnessing right now is what we need to realize as activists and as journalists is that spyware are one of the leading elements, I will say, und dictators of the restructuring of the international system, both political and economic. It is one of the driver of the technological revolution or a reflection of that revolution. It is central to the geostrategic realignment at global level. And nobody is prepared to regulate it because they all want to have an edge over the others.
Ja, es ist nämlich so, dass dieses national security Ding immer eigentlich in diesen Verordnungen drin steht. Also man ist gegen spy software. Das soll alles nicht sein, es sei denn. Es gefährdet also dass das journalistisch tun oder was auch immer. Das gefährdet die nationale Sicherheit. Also das ist quasi auch Delegitimierung des Staates. Dann ist alles wiederum möglich und das ist beängstigend zu sehen, denn die Technik ist ja so weit fortgeschritten. Was man dort alles dann machen kann, kann man sich ja immer so in kühnen Träumen ausmalen. Aber es geht in der EU immer mehr in diese Richtung und gerade mit der Bedrohungslage, dass man sagt da ist China, da ist Russland. Deswegen muss das jetzt so sein.
Neues Argument ist ja auch zu sagen, Handys bleiben bitte unangetastet. Man darf auch keine Bomben einbauen. Man weiß ja nicht, wie weit es getrieben wird. Ich meine selbst der deutsche Diskurs, innere Sicherheit und öffentliche Ordnung. Das ist ja schnell dabei argumentiert. Da muss ja nur einer mit einer Maräte umlaufen. Und schon hast du flächendeckend den Case dafür da jetzt einzukreisen.
Ich sehe schon den Bürgerrat, der uns das zu 92 Prozent empfiehlt. Jetzt gehen wir mal von dem internationalen Parkett noch mal weg, hinein in das Studio von Markus Lanz. Der hatte im August eine interessante Sendung zum Thema Meinungsfreiheit. Und die müssen wir jetzt noch mal aufgreifen, denn wir haben ja so viele Fälle jetzt gehabt. Compact haben wir schon angesprochen. Dann diese Verfassungsschutzsachen, Kreml-Narrative, die überall behauptet werden. Dann haben wir diese Einschränkungen pro palästinensischer Proteste. Ich will hier nochmal deutlich unterstreichen. Ich mache mir diese Slogans und alles, was da so gerufen wird, überhaupt nicht zu eigen. Ich sehe es nur als eine ganz große Gefahr an für die Meinungsfreiheit, wenn da alles sofort verboten wird. Und auch interessant ist, dass die Leute, die sich die ganze Zeit aufregen, nämlich aus dem Springer Verlag und aus sonstigen publizistischen Verwandtschaften, niemals diese Meinungsfreiheit auf der Seite einfordern. Das ist ja alles okay. Also wenn da Proteste verboten werden, alles Mögliche nicht mehr stattfinden soll an Universitäten, wenn dort die Bildungsministerin durchgreift, das ist alles okay. Kein Problem. Aber sonst ist Cancer Culture, wenn woanders was passiert. Und diese Einschränkung der Meinungsfreiheit, die man jetzt immer dann mit großen Sicherheitsinteressen und so weiter macht, sehe ich als ein tatsächliches Problem an. Und Lanz hat jetzt drei Leute zu Gast. Und man sieht dann einfach, dass wenn drei Leute, die intelligente Zusammenhaben zusammensitzen und man nicht im politischen Interesse verfechten müssen, dann ergibt das gleich eine ganz andere Sendung. Zu Gast sind Juli C., Nora Magwa, die ist Völkerrechtlerin und Kai Ambos, auch Juraprofessor, spezialisiert auf Strafrecht und auch internationales Recht. Und Lanz zeigt jetzt ein Plakat von einer Demo. Und da stand drauf, Kalifat ist die Lösung.
Das Plakat mit dem Kalifat, vielleicht können wir das noch einmal zuspielen. Da sind wir jetzt in einem Dilemma. Ja, zumindest ich als Nichtjurist schaue da drauf und denke, von der Meinungsfreiheit sozusagen gedeckt, nicht zu sagen, wir fordern das Kalifat, sondern steht ja da nur, Kalifat ist die Lösung. Aber es insinuiert sozusagen, dass man einen Kalifat errichten will. Und denke, na gut, das ist jetzt schwierig, weil da fordern Leute etwas im Rahmen dieser Demokratie, dieser Meinungsfreiheit.
Was undemokratisch ist.
Was zutiefst undemokratisch ist. Und das Erste, was sie direkt danach schleifen würden, wenn es dazu käme und abschaffte, wäre genau das.
Ja, so ist es.
Und kann einen das nicht stolz machen, dass wir das trotzdem gewähren?
Sagt Julie C und Nora Magwart sagt.
Ich glaube, das ist nochmal ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Das ist der Prüffall sozusagen.
Weil ich brauche die Grundrechte ja genau dann, wenn die anderen nicht wollen, dass ich das machen darf.
Also wenn ich mich darauf berufe als Minderheit, wenn ich die abweichende Meinung äußere. Also niemand muss sich auf die Meinungsfreiheit berufen, um das zu sagen, was eh alle denken. Dafür brauche ich die Meinungsfreiheit nicht.
Nur dann ist sie ja interessant, die Meinungsfreiheit. Und sie bringt mal ein anderes Beispiel. Und wir haben ja auch schon mehrmals diskutiert darüber, ob die Demokratie eigentlich die Lösung ist.
In einer Demokratie möglich zu sagen, ich finde die Monarchie die bessere Staatsform zum Beispiel. Wir müssen ja noch nicht mal ins Kalifat gehen, wo wir jetzt vielleicht auch noch mal deutlich gewalttätigere Herrschaften und so weiter machen.
Das schreiben Kollegen von mir. Monarchie ist die bessere Staatsform. Also das kann man schreiben.
Wo ist denn eigentlich die Grenze?
Das kann man schreiben. Da ist aber auch dann noch mal wichtig zu sagen, also das ist ja genau die Grenze, die ist dann erreicht, wenn es ein darauf ausgehen ist, quasi diese freiheitliche demokratische Grundordnung mit der Demokratie, mit den zentralen Grundrechten, mit eben dieser Absicherung des Pluralismus, wenn man die beseitigt und zwar nicht nur findet, es wäre gut, wenn sie beseitigt wäre, sondern auch da sozusagen aktiv wird in diese Richtung und wenn es wirklich gefährlich wird.
Ja, also das ist der 6. Januar, da gehen Leute dann mit dem Spaten auf die Straße und sagen, jetzt gehen wir hier rein.
Oder auf dem Reichstag ist man ja auch umgetornet vorher.
So, dann gibt es eine Bedrohung und dann wird hier eingeschritten, aber man kann nicht vorher einschreiten und das ist das Interessante, dass es eine Zensur nicht geben darf. Und Zensur ist also das, was vorher stattfindet, Nora Magwart erklärt.
Und Zensur ist nämlich genau das, dass man vor Erscheinen ein Medium schon verbietet oder einer Kontrolle unterwirft, ob das jetzt genehm ist, was da drin steht. Und das ist das, was verboten ist durch das Grundgesetz und insofern erlaubt wäre, zu sagen, jetzt gibt es eine Publikation, da sind beispielsweise volksverhetzende Inhalte drin, die muss aus dem Handel genommen werden und die darf nicht weiter verkauft werden. Das wäre unproblematisch. Aber dass man sagt, von vorne herein verbieten wir das, egal was jetzt in den nächsten Heften drin stehen würde. Das ganze Magazin wird verboten, das geht presserechtlich nicht und deswegen macht man diese Umgehungskonstruktionen über das Vereinsverbot. Und das haben wir eben jetzt gegen linkes Medium gesehen, jetzt geht es gegen rechtes Medium. Ich halte das für eine extrem problematische, autoritiere Politik, auf diese Weise zu intervenieren. Also die Pressefreiheit, wenn wir da anfangen, das aufzugeben, dann sind wir glaube ich als liberaler Rechtsstaat wirklich mit dem Rücken an der Wand.
Und die Pressefeiert die gar nicht?
Es ist ja auch ganz erstaunlich, dass wir doch in der akademischen Theorie ganz viele Positionen haben, die die Demokratie infrage stellen. Und da würde man ja nicht sagen, da müssen wir mal einen Verfassungsschutz hinstellen, wenn Slavoj Zizek demnächst auftritt.
Hat man ja fast gemacht hier bei der Buchmechanik.
Ja genau, da geht es ja dann schon so um Staatsräson. Oh, oh, oh, kann er das, sollte er das sagen. Und denk an Dietmar Dard oder an Milo Rao, die sich als Leninisten bezeichnen. Ja, Lenin sogar. Was ist denn da, müssen wir jetzt auch mal da vorbei.
Sofort die Bärte rasieren.
Das ist doch unsinnig. Kai Ambos?
Lädt natürlich zu Missbrauch ein. Und wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir finden das bei Compaq gut, weil wir dieses Magazin blöd finden, ist es morgen vielleicht gegen anderes, eine liberale oder nur konservative Zeitung. Das ist genau der Punkt.
Das ist ja auch schon ganz wie eben.
Die sind sich aber sehr einer Meinung dort. Das ist ganz ungewöhnlich.
Das gefällt mir wahnsinnig gut, dass man ein vernünftiges Gespräch stattfinden kann, weil Leute Ahnung haben und jetzt nicht sagen, ach wie kriege ich das morgen meinen Parteileuten verkauft, was ich ja abends gesagt habe. Und jetzt geht Nora Marquardt noch mal auf die Polizei ein. Denn es ist ja gerade bei diesen Protesten, den pro-palästinensischen Demos so oft gewesen, dass man einschreiten konnte, obwohl man doch eigentlich gar keine Legitimation dafür hatte. Aber dann sagte man, ja, aber es hätte etwas sich zusammen brauen können. Und deswegen haben wir das mal doch lieber verboten. Hier hat sie einen historischen Fall für uns, den ich auch gar nicht kannte.
Auch noch mal an die Brockdorf-Entscheidung zu erinnern. Das ging es um eine Atomkraft-Demo, die am Ende noch gewalttätig wurde und die sollte verboten werden.
Wir reden von welchem Jahr in dem Fall?
85 ist die.
85, ja.
Also so Anti-Atom-Bewege. Da war klar, da kommen dann die Autonomen aus Hamburg auch zur Demo. Es wurde gewaltbefürchtet. Die Versammlung fand dann trotzdem statt, obwohl sie verboten worden war und war auch friedlich. Auf dem Rückweg gab es dann aber doch massive Gewalt. Die Frage war, war dann das Verbot nicht doch gerechtfertigt? Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat es gesagt. Das Versammlungsverbot ist wiederum das allerletzte Mittel. Es waren 100.000 Leute auf der Demo, die nicht gewalttätig sind. Die haben doch ein Recht auf Versammlungsfreiheit. Die Polizei muss sich eigentlich bemühen, die Versammlungsfreiheit derjenigen, die friedlich bleiben, zu schützen. Und dann eben die, die unfriedlich sind, rauszuhalten und abzusondern und dagegen vorzugehen. Nicht dann zu sagen, dann darf niemand demonstrieren. Auch da, wir sind ein liberaler Staat. Ich glaube, es ist wichtig, das nicht zu vergessen.
Das geschieht nämlich dann oft nicht, wenn diese Demonstrationen einfach abgeblasen werden. Sondern man müsste eigentlich sagen, ja die, die hier gewalttätig sind oder die Volksverhetzung betreiben, zum Beispiel gegen Juden hetzen, die dürfen hier nicht teilnehmen. Und die müssen wir aussortieren, damit die anderen den Schutz der Meinungsfreiheit genießen können und des Demonstrationsrechts.
Das ist ja eine Beobachtung, weshalb ich auch sage, ich gehe nicht auf Demos. Die Polizei macht nie den Eindruck, dass sie eine progressive Linke, was auch immer, auf geklärte Demos schützt. Bei Nazi-Demos immer. Da habe ich immer den Eindruck, die laufen da drum herum, machen eine Bannmeile, beschützen die, damit die der schönen Demonstrationszug machen können. Und dieser allgemeine Eindruck, den ich habe, der wird eigentlich immer bestätigt.
Das ist besorgniserregend. Ich finde auch schlimm, dass wir so eine Kultur jetzt gerade bei Twitter sehen, dass einzelne Äußerungen derart skandalisiert werden, dass man auch da gleich nach dem Start ruft. Da muss doch jetzt mal was passieren. Hier muss mal einer reinschreiten oder der Anwalt ist schon informiert. Es gab einen Tweet von Julian Reichelt. Auf den kommt Lanz jetzt zu sprechen.
Julian Reichelt, ehemaliger Bildschefredakteur, twittert, Deutschland zahlte in den letzten zwei Jahren 370 Millionen Euro, drei Ausrufezeichen, Entwicklungshilfe an die Taliban, noch mehr Ausrufezeichen. Wir leben im Irrenhaus in einem absoluten, totalen, historisch einzigartigen Irrenhaus. Was ist das nur für eine Regierung? Das finde ich völlig unproblematisch. Ich hätte nie im Leben gegen Herrn Reichelt irgendwas gemacht.
Ja, sagt Kai Ambos. Und ich glaube, er hat absolut recht damit.
Reicht auch darum, eine zu schreiben, die wir dann lesen.
Ja. Warum muss man juristisch dagegen vorgehen? Also es hat natürlich auch nicht gefruchtet, hat nicht funktioniert, dagegen juristisch vorzugehen. Und es ist auch gut, dass das nicht passiert. Denn sonst wären wir bald in einer Situation, wo alles nur noch verklagt wird. Ambos kommt noch mal auf Kompakt zu sprechen.
Übrigens auch bei Kompakt, wenn der Habeck ins Gefängnis, Merkel die Königin der Schlepper. Das sind so Aussagen von Kompakt. Würde ich alles sagen, alles Meinungsfreiheit. Andere Sachen, zum Beispiel, wenn Minderheiten, jüdische Minderheit, muslimische, direkt Angriffe werden, dann sind wir wieder in der Volksverletzung. Da kann es schon kritisch werden. Aber bei Kompakt ist es differenziert.
Also wenn da drin steht, tötet Habeck, ist das wieder was anderes. Ja.
Steht das da drin oder was?
Nein, das steht nicht da drin. Wenn das da drin steht, dann muss man dagegen vorgehen. Und das geht dann nicht. Kai Ambrose bringt jetzt noch ein Beispiel vom Bundesverfassungsgericht. Und das fand ich ganz erstaunlich.
Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt auch Meinungen, die auf eine grundlegende Änderung der politischen Ordnung zielen, müssen wir tolerieren.
Also da muss der Verfassungsschutz jetzt nicht kleinen Podcasts hinterherrufen.
Das Grundgesetz vertraut auf die Kraft der freien Auseinandersetzung als wirksamste Waffe, auch gegen die Verbreitung totalitärer und menschenverachtender Ideologien. Das muss man vielen Politikern heute mal noch mal sichieren. Dementsprechend fällt selbst die Verbreitung nationalsozialistischen Gedankenguts als radikale Infragestellung der geltenden Ordnung nicht von vorneherein aus dem Schutzbereich von Artikel 5, ist also von der Meinungsfreiheit umfasst. Also selbst die Verbreitung nationalsozialistischen Gedankenguts müssen wir aushalten. Und dann wird noch mal betont, es geht um freien Diskurs. Und meine These ist eben, wir haben im Grunde heute zwei Positionen. Es gibt die Position, das ist die des Verfassungsgerichts, das ich da absolut unterstütze, das ist die Diskursposition, die Diskussion. Wir sollen in Diskurs treten, auch zum Beispiel mit den Studierenden in Berlin oder in Göttingen oder in Münster, die irgendwelche pro-Palästinensischen Demos machen. Und es gibt die autoritäre Verbotsposition. Und leider kurz ist diese Verbotsposition auf der exekutiven Ebene, ich denke zum Beispiel an das Bundesinnenministerium, sehr verbreitet und sehr im Fortschreiten begriffen.
Ja, wobei die nationalsozialistische Position ja immer so ein Ultranationalismus gegen Minderheiten beinhaltet.
Da wo es dann in der Volksverhetzung kommt, ist es wieder was Anderes.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie man eine klar erkennbare nationalsozialistische Position als gegenwärtige, aber vom Artikel 5 gedeckte Meinung irgendwie. Aber das habe ich das Problem auch bei der AfD. Dass immer Leute glauben, sie könnten mit der AfD über die Rentenpolitik reden und ausblenden, dass im Mittelmeer tausend Leute sterben, gezielt.
Nur man muss eben diese unglaubliche Freiheit, die da gelassen ist, der Meinung, die sollte man hochhalten. Und ich sehe da zunehmend so eine Tendenz, dass man das einschränken will, dass man überhaupt so einen Bürgerrat auf den Weg bringt, dann noch stolz das Ergebnis präsentiert und dann jemand, der ja auch juristisch und sich auskennt, wie Konstantin von Notz, dem noch beispringt und viele weitere. Da wundert es mich schon sehr. Und ich finde auch interessant, dass da T-Online dabei ist, die Bertelsmann Stiftung. Das sind ja nun Medienhäuser. Bertelsmann ist ein Medienhaustier online auch. Und was wollen die? Wollen die jetzt bald so ein Etikett haben? Wir sind die Guten und dann bekommen sie noch ein bisschen Förderung vom Staat und alle anderen, die jetzt in der freien Szene, sage ich mal, unterwegs sind. Die müssen sehen, ob sie überhaupt noch dazu gehören. Und sonst bekommen sie das Prädikat Fake News und dann ist Schluss. Also ich finde das ganz, ganz furchtbar, dass man also eigentlich hier über den Bürgerrat so eine Gatekeeper-Funktion installieren will, wie sie noch nie da war, nämlich in Wahrheitsministerium.
Tja, ich habe nur Skandalöses gehört, also sowohl, dass es einen Bürgerrat gibt, als auch, dass Meilschberger einen Fernsehpreis gewonnen hat. Ja, ist alles nicht gut. Auch nicht gut, Thüringen zu vermelden, aus dem Herzen Deutschlands ist, dass dort eine Verfassung gilt, die sagt, hier muss gewählt werden und 30 Tage nach der Wahl muss konstituiert werden. Wir gehen beide Schritte noch mal einzeln durch, denn im September wurde da auch gewählt.
Es geht nach Thüringen.
Es geht nach Thüringen und Wolfgang Thierse, wir kennen ihn als Plauderer. Er ist im Grunde einer, der gerne mal Papiere schreibt, in denen steht, wäre es nicht cool, ein Weizministerium zu haben oder irgendetwas. Abstruse Ideen, die mit der Realität wenig zu tun haben. Und es bewies uns auch diesmal im Deutschlandfunk-Interview am 3.9., also zwei Tage nach der Wahl, sagt er folgendes.
Sie müssen bei allem Streit zeigen, dass sie sich einigen können. Das erlebt man doch auch wieder, dass gerade in Ostdeutschland dieser Streit den Leuten auf die Nerven geht. Das verstehe ich gut. Aber ich verstehe nicht so gut, dass dann gesagt wird, es braucht immer einen starken Führer. Da muss die starke Hand angemessen werden. Das ist doch auch der Hintergrund, warum Höcke und Wagenknecht so populär sind. Zwei gegensätzliche Figuren, aber darin sind sie sich ähnlich. Man wünscht sich eine starke, eine strahlende Figur, die entscheidet und gewissermaßen die Menschen durch das Problemland führt und ihnen die Lösungen bietet, die sie sich so sehr und erklärlicherweise betone ich wünschen.
War es der Tenor in irgendeiner Diskussion, dass gerade ein Führer zur Diskussion steht? Also welcher Führer sollte das sein? Also die Zustimmungswerte für den Bernd in Brandenburg waren so 15 Prozent. Für den Urban ist es glaube ich nicht messbar. Und selbst Höcke, der nun wirklich bundesweit bekannt ist, der kann gar nichts gewinnen. Den will man nicht als Ministerpräsident, der gewinnt seinen Wahlkreis nicht. Ich sehe gerade nirgendwo einen Führer.
Nicht, weil er den Wahlkreis gewinnt, ja.
Ja, also ich sehe nirgendwo einen Führer. Zweitens, ich sehe auch nicht, dass irgendwer gerade irgendwas will, sondern die Leute sind halt wütend und sagen, sie sind wütend. Wenn man sie fragt, was wollen sie denn, dann stehen sie in dieser 100 Sendung und sagen, ja, keine Ahnung, soll ich hier alles ändern oder so. Also Wolfgang Thierse macht ein sehr intuitives Argument oder er liegt komplett daneben in allen Aspekten, die er berührt. Man sollte Wolfgang Thierse fragen, um dann genau das Gegenteil journalistisch zu beachten. Er ist sozusagen das Anti-Orakel. Er weiß gar nichts. Er hat so eine Gefühlsduselei, die eine Nulltraktion hat. Mike Moring, dagegen ehemaliger CDU-Chef in Thüringen, ist auch angetreten bei dieser Wahl und saß am Tage danach, am 2.9., also an dem Montag, bei der FAZ im Podcast. Und das war wahnsinnig interessant, denn man kann jetzt die Wolfgang Thierse Theorien des starken Führers, der großen Antwort, die man jetzt mal erwirklicht haben will, mal nachgehen. Auch Mike Mohring hat seinen Wahlkreis nicht gewonnen, sitzt nicht im nächsten Thüringer Landtag. Wer stattdessen?
Mike Mohring, er wird hier vorgestellt... .wahlgestanden und alles andere. Also über dieses Ergebnis, das Sie erzielt haben, dieses Mal zu sprechen, wäre unhöflich. Wollen Sie es selbst sagen oder soll ich Ihnen den Part abnehmen?
Da wird es ein bisschen rumgedrückt. Jetzt haben wir Sie hier eingeladen. Dabei sind Sie nicht mehr am nächsten Landtag. Also sind Sie überhaupt ein Gesprächskast für uns, so ungefähr.
30,1 Prozent, gar nicht wenig eigentlich, wenn man das mit CDU-Kandidaten in anderen Wahlkreisen vergleicht, aber dennoch verloren gegen die AfD-Kandidatin, die, glaube ich, 38 Prozent der Stimmen bekommen hat. Wie war das für Sie?
Ich war den ganzen Tag heute sprachlos, weil ich mir das nicht vorstellen konnte. Doch, ich habe es mir schon vorstellen können und nicht geglaubt, dass es passiert, dass diese Frau, die überhaupt keinen Wahlkampf gemacht hat, die auf eine Zeitungsnachfrage gesagt hat, warum sie in den Thüringer Landtag will, keine Angabe gemacht hat, trotzdem gewählt wird für die Leute, die eigentlich den Anspruch haben, Widervertrauen in Politik zu kriegen. Und das ist der Widerspruch, der da ist. Einerseits schreien sie danach, nicht mehr den Parteien zu vertrauen, wenn ich das Wort so aufgreifen kann, weil sie was Neues suchen und wählen dann blind irgendwas, ohne zu wissen, was da auf sie zukommt.
Ja, kein Führerprinzip, und auch nicht die Suche nach einer großen Antwort oder so, sondern einfach, mir egal, wer ihr antritt. Und das beschreibt er auch. Es ist den Leuten egal, wer da antritt.
AfD-Wähler wählen, es kann man sagen, alle Leute, die in Wahlbüros sitzen, wie folgt, die kreuzen, auch bei der Kommunalwahl kann man das sehen, wo kumulierende Panaschieren gibt bei uns, wo man sozusagen mit den Stimmen häufeln kann und kann den Kandidaten direkt wählen. Bei der AfD wird einfach oben angekreuzt. Die Partei, egal wer da drunter steht. Bei den anderen Parteien suchen die Leute nach dem Name und wollen speziell jemanden aus der Nachbarschaft, aus dem Bekanntenkreis, aus dem Verein, aus dem Ortsverband auch wählen und machen da ihre Kreuze.
Bei der AfD ist das egal.
Ja, so viel zu, die AfD ist niedlich, weil sie noch an Politik glaubt. Na gut, die AfD kann durchaus noch an Politik glauben, die Wähler nicht. Die Wähler der AfD glauben nicht mehr an Politik. Die sagen einfach nur noch, fuck you. Das ist der Molotow-Cocktail, den wir jetzt hier ins Parlament werfen. Nicht mal AfD-Anhänger sind sehr davon überzeugt, dass die AfD unbedingt regieren sollte. Man will die wirklich nur als Streit und Opposition.
Wir müssen sozusagen umgekehrt gehen.
Das hier im SWR, im Anforum.
Das ist auch mein Eindruck nach dieser Inside-Wagen-Knecht-Duko, die ich gesehen habe. Die Leute sind unzufrieden, ja. Konkret können sie höchstens noch was sagen zu Flüchtlingen, aber auch da wissen sie nichts Konkretes, sondern sagen nur so was wie zu viel oder unkontrolliert. Medien-Diskurse geben sie wieder. Aber diese Frustration und diese Wut, die man hat und die natürlich Wagen-Knecht kanalisieren kann, diese Wut möchte man eigentlich behalten. Man will die nicht loswerden. Das heißt, man will nicht, dass das BSW jetzt regiert und tatsächlich das ein oder andere besser macht. Das wäre ja denkbar, dass bei manchen Punkten, die was auf die Wege bringen. Nein, das ist aber gar nicht das Interesse, glaube ich, hauptsächlich, sondern man will eigentlich diesen permanenten Zorn-Modus aufrechterhalten. Und das geht ja nur, indem man nicht regiert.
Das identitätsstiftende Merkmal ist das Leiden. Das haben wir ja in Westworld gehört. Identität kommt aus dem Leiden. Deswegen heißt es ja auch Dolores. Und ihr Gegenpart sagt, ich hatte mal einen Sohn. Und er stellt dann fest, ich bin gar kein Mensch, ich bin eine Maschine. Und er wird dann gefragt, sollen wir die Erinnerung an deinen Sohn, an irgendeiner seltenen Krankheit, also als die Maschine noch dachte sie, er sei ein Mensch, hat sie einen Sohn verloren an eine Krankheit. Und man fragt dann die Maschine, nach der Aufklärung, du bist übrigens eine Maschine, sollen wir die Erinnerung, wenn die dich so quält, einfach nehmen? Und dann sagt er, nein, der Schmerz ist doch die einzige Sache, die mich noch mit ihm, an die ich mich noch erinnere. Also nicht mal eine Maschine, die eine Aufklärung darüber hat, dass sie eigentlich gar keine echten Gefühle hat und so weiter, sagt, ne, nehme mir nicht meine Identitätsstiftenden Leiden. Und so ist das hier auch. Leute wollen einfach vor sich hin leiden. Und zwar als Ausweglosigkeit, weil ihnen niemand ein Angebot macht. Weil gegen Superreiche vorzugehen und in Thüringen plötzlich zu sagen, Simsalabim, euer Haushalt ist jetzt doppelt so hoch. Bürgerrat, was wollt ihr mit den zusätzlichen 60 Milliarden machen? So ungefähr, könnte man ja auch, ist aber nicht. So, stattdessen sagen einfach nur alle, ich will hier, da sind gar keiner regiert. Ich will keine Privilegien verteilen. Ich wähle die AfD. Soll die regieren? Nein.
Sozusagen umgekehrt sagen, 70 Prozent der Menschen in Thüringen haben die AfD nicht gewählt. Es gab Umfragen, die vor allem auch in Richtung Sachsen, aber auch Thüringen geführt wurden. Da wurde gezeigt, nur 37 Prozent möchten überhaupt die AfD in Regierungsverantwortung sehen. Und interessanterweise, sogar 40 Prozent der AfD-Wählerinnen wollen das gar nicht.
Bitte regiert nicht, macht einfach Stimmung.
Macht einfach Stimmung. So und jetzt im Transalpien-Podcast der Zeit, der sehr gut ist, in dem der Schweizer, der Österreicher und dann Lenzi Jacobsen für Deutschland einen Podcast darüber machen, wie es so zugeht im deutschsprachigen Raum. Wir hatten jetzt die Nationalratswahl, wir haben ja angesprochen, wird kurz noch mal diese Idee aufgeworfen. Ja, aber mit konstruktiver Politik, die AfD regiert dann mit, könnte man sie ja entzaubern.
Deswegen, ich es ja wirklich einigermaßen absurd finde, dass es auch jetzt nach diesen Wahlen immer noch Leute, auch Kommentatoren gibt, die meinen, man könnte solche Parteien, also in diesem Fall die AfD, aber ja auch die FP über euch noch irgendwie zähmen.
Politik aus dem großen Zirkusvorstellungen, in dem man den Tiger dazu bringt.
Das Wichtige ist, dass man immer den Eindruck erweckt, selbst den Domtörstab in der Hand zu nehmen.
Wenn ich das schon höre, also warum sollten, also jetzt mal ganz abgesehen von der Begrifflichkeit, ausgeschenkt, warum sollten die sich zähmen lassen? Also die werden ja gewählt, weil sie wie ein weitausgestreckter Mittelfinger herumlaufen. Also das ist ja die ganze Idee dahinter. Und also zwei Beispiele nur aus Österreich. Man kann ja vielleicht was lernen draus. 2000, als die FPÖ in die Region gekommen ist, sind sie plötzlich sanfter aufgetreten. Also die Ministerinnen und Minister waren eher von der nicht-radikalen Seite, die Sie ganz staatsmännisch geben. Alles hat irgendwie ganz okay ausgeschaut, obwohl ganz Europa gesagt hat, die Österreicher, das ist nicht okay, was ihr da macht. So, was ist passiert? Die FPÖ war nach ein paar Jahren Regierungsbeteiligung gespalten. Also es hat plötzlich zwei gegeben, das BZD vom Heider und die FPÖ. Und sie war quasi tot. Fast vorwärts, 2017 Strache wird Vizekanzler, plötzlich auch Staatsmanager. Und ein bisschen gezähmter. 2018, Entschuldigung, nicht 2017. 2018 Strache, Vizekanzler, Staatsmanager, gezähmter. Was aus dem geworden ist, wisst ihr. Das haben wir in dem Podcast ausführlich besprochen. Und wer hat politisch überlebt? Und ist jetzt bei 30 Prozent? Das wissen wir nicht. Aber der andere ist der Gott sei bei uns, der FPÖ, der Herbert Kickl. Der ist nie sanft gewesen. Nie. Auch nicht als Innenminister. Und warum zur Hölle sollte er sich auch nur ansatzweise mäßigen? Es gibt keinen Grund und sie werden es nicht tun. Die AfD wird es nicht tun und die FPÖ wird es nicht tun.
Ja, also wenn man sich Kickls Wahlkampf anschaut, fällt einem die Kinnlade runter und er hat damit gewonnen. Er hat 29 Prozent oder sowas geholt. Ist der Wahlsieger. Das erste Mal liegt die FPÖ vorne.
Und wir haben es bei Trump gesehen. Da haben auch Anfangs Leute gedacht, der wird sich deradikalisieren. Nein, er hat sich im Amt radikalisiert.
Genau, und die Wiederwahl steht überhaupt nur in Aussicht, weil er sich danach noch härter radikalisiert hat.
Ja.
Also da kommt ja nur noch Blödsinn.
Bei Meloni wird das auch so sein. Wenn sie jetzt nicht, wenn sie…
Genau, jetzt gerade ist so eine zahme Variante.
Jetzt macht sie so gerade so ein bisschen zahm, weil sie da auch einiges will für der EU.
Sobald der Wahlkampf läuft, ist das wieder…
Dann geht das wieder rund.
Weil ansonsten wird sie ihr Recht überholen. Also in deren Sicht, das ist sehr dramatisch, was an Thüringen passiert. Eine sehr große AfD-Fraktion ist schon ein echtes Problem. Plus diese Entkopplung von neuem Parlamentarismus und Bevölkerung.
So, und das Dramatische ist, wir als CDU Thüringen, unser Credo war immer, die Wahlkreise zu gewinnen. Unsere Verwurzelung vor Ort, das war das Starke. Und selbst bei dem schlechten Wahlergebnis 2019, was ja auch schon die Finalisierung Höcke-Rammelow hatte, haben die, die in den Landtag gekommen sind, alle ihre Wahlkreise gewonnen. Und das ist erst mal anders. Da verändert sich was, weil damit auch eine Verwurzelung wegbricht, weil dann auch eine Nähe zu den Ortsverwänden kaputt geht. Und deswegen macht dieses Wahlergebnis mehr mit uns, als alle Wahlergebnisse zuvor.
Ja, das ist ein sehr wahnsinnig interessantes Argument, das muss man sich auch genau, denn niemand kennt natürlich seine Wahlkreiskandidaten irgendwie für der Landtagswahl, also ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, wer für Hessen hier für mich im Landtags ist. Aber die kennen mich. Also die haben einfach mit Frankfurt zu tun. Nur wenn die ihre Wahlkreise nicht gewinnen und genau wissen, es kommt auf die Partei an, also wenn sich die Partei in irgendeine Richtung entwickelt, muss ich das auch, sonst ist mein Listenplatz wie auch immer. Es gibt jetzt eine Entkopplung von oben sozusagen. Also Politiker, die sowieso schon von unten als kenne ich nicht, weiß ich nicht, wer das ist und so weiter. Jetzt entkoppeln die sich von oben auch noch und verlieren den Bezug zu Thüringen. Also das ist wirklich ein dramatischer Zustand. Carsten Schneider als Ostbeauftragter war im Deutschlandfunk-Interview zur Gast am 31. 8., also sogar noch vor der Wahl und erklärte damals schon, wie entkoppelt Politik und Lebenswirklichkeit dort ist.
Ja, es gibt viele Menschen, die kennen niemanden, der in einer Partei ist. Das ist nicht wie in Good Old West Germany ist es leider auch nicht mehr so. Obwohl, in den 70er Jahren, an jedem Familien-Tisch, in dem man saß, der Mitglied der SPD, der CDU war. Das gibt es bei uns gar nicht. Also wenn 2,2 Millionen Einwohner in Thüringen, davon sind vielleicht 15.000, 16.000 Mitglied in einer demokratischen Partei. Das heißt, man trifft nie jemanden, der tatsächlich auch an so einem Diskussionsprozess auf dem Bundesparteitag mitgemacht hat und Informationen auch wirklich weitergeben kann, aber auch klar argumentiert in der Sache für eine Partei. Sondern das ist ein bisschen mehr Zuschauerstellung. Und das merke ich natürlich, weil viel Unverständnis manchmal auch da ist über die politischen Entscheidungsprozesse viele nicht beteiligt sind, weil sie eben auch nicht mit mit einer Partei sind.
Und sie wollen es nicht sein, und das ist auch ein wichtiger Punkt noch mal im Bezug auf das BSW. In dieser Doku Inside BSW waren ein paar frustrierte Leute zu sehen, die sich bemühten um eine Mitgliedschaft und man sie dann immer weiter vertröstete, weil man ja erst mal so ein Kader bilden will. Da würde ich sagen, hat die Kamera Einzelfälle eingefangen von Leuten, die tatsächlich sehr idealistisch sind und sagen, ich muss da jetzt was tun und der Sache helfen. Für die meisten Wähler des BSW wird das überhaupt gar keine Rolle spielen, soll ich da eintreten, sondern es geht um das Spektakel und sind da die entsprechenden Figuren dabei, die das Stück aufführen können, aber ich selbst muss mich nicht engagieren.
Also man muss sich wirklich vor Augen führen.
Eigentlich wie wir in die Oper gehen, da kommt ja auch nicht einer von uns beiden auf die Idee, auch mal unten im Orchestergraben mitzuspielen.
Genau, reine Publikumsrolle, null Involvement und selbst bei der Wahl, da man erkennt sie so auf dem Wahlzettel.
Naja, deswegen heißt der BSW damit, die Leute es nicht so schwer haben.
Kleine Parteien wie die Grünen verfügen über hunderte, wenn nicht tausende Ortsverbände in Westdeutschland, die alle größer sind als der Landesverband Brandenburg. Also das ist ein Ausmaß an Nichtbeteiligung, Desinteresse und so weiter. Der Karsten Schneider betont das ja auch nochmal.
Naja, man muss den nicht erbarnen. Viele waren Mitglied in einer Partei und waren nicht. Ich bin mich überzeugt, dass zum Beispiel in der SED, das wurde schon erwartet, man könnte das auch nicht tun, klar. Aber viele haben das mit der Faust in der Tasche und die haben sich gesagt, ich war einmal in der Partei, ich geh keine mehr. Das ist das eine. Und zum zweiten, sind wie die SPD in Ostdeutschland, das halt Neugründung. Bei den Grünen ist es auch der Fall, wir haben ja nicht die von den Massenparteien, wie die CDU oder die Linke, die Leute übernommen. Das ist nie ein großer Ansturm geworden, sondern das ist ein bisschen ein politischer, naja, Zuschauerstellung. Sie gehen zur Wahl, aber sie beteiligen sich nicht in dem Maße. Putt ist aktiv an der Willensbettung über Mitgliedschaften in Parteien. Und das ist jetzt schon fast 35 Jahre so. Deswegen ist meine Hoffnung, dass das so mal komplett umdreht. Die ist begrenzt. Und deswegen muss man sich sehr genau überlegen, wie wir das repräsentativ-demokratische System, dessen großer Anhänger ich bin, das Deutschland beigebracht haben, eben auch gängig macht, dass die Bevölkerung noch den Eindruck hat, sie sind da auch beteiligt. Deswegen mitmachen. Aber eben auch starkenmaße politische Entteilungsprozesse eben dann auch klar zugespitzt machen, sodass die Leute sie auch verstehen. Und wenn ich das noch sagen darf, Herr Buschert, ganz viele hören leider nicht Deutschlandfunk, sondern sind abgedriftet in Kanäle, die irgendjemand im Netz macht und doch aus die Westen oder auch in den USA ähnlich, werden dort mit Informationen, die keine Informationen sind, sondern Fake News, gefiltert und das begegnen mir sehr, sehr oft, dass ich viel Zeit aufwenden muss, um das wieder klarzustellen. Ich bin doch die Regierung, das stimmt nicht. Was ich da gelesen habe, ist anders.
Ja, übrigens ein wichtiger Punkt, weil wir eben diese Diskussion zum Thema Artikel 5 usw. hatten. In Deutschland ansässige Medien genießen eine gewisse Freiheit, die wir da gerade bedroht sahen. Beim Thema TikTok steuert über Singapur chinesische Interessen und spielt irgendwelche Videos vor, von denen niemand nachvollziehen kann, wer welche Videos sieht. Da sind wir jenseits von der Artikel 5 Diskussion oder Zensur oder so, sondern hier geht grundsätzlich erst mal akademisch aufklären, was passiert da. Dokumentationspflichten, wem wird alles angezeigt und so weiter und so fort. Also in der Ansicht ist dieser Einwurf, den hat er schon genau richtig.
Ja, das richtet sich ja dann an die Konzerne, also an Bightens. Die müssten dann in anderer Weise das transparent machen. Und auch ein Mark Zuckerberg müsste...
Der ganz Besondere....
ja bestellt werden und dann müssten nicht da in seinem Podcaststudio, sondern der müsste dann in Brüssel das mal erläutern. Und dann müssen da klare Fakten geschaffen werden, dass die Meinungsfreiheit gewahrt ist, aber dass nicht Zuckerberg das so steuert, wie er will. Denn das findet er jetzt gerade statt. Er spielt ja einfach den Großredakteur, der sagt, jetzt gibt es nur noch nackte Frauen ab morgen bei mir.
Ja, also ich habe noch einen großen Themenkomplex zum Thema Mark Zuckerberg und wie wir kommunizieren, inklusive, wenn er sagt, keine politischen Inhalte und so weiter, wie weit und so. Hören wir uns dann in den nächsten Folgen irgendwann, wenn es passt, an. Also in Thüringen wurde jetzt gewählt und ich würde sagen, aus dem, was wir jetzt gehört haben, können wir doch eigentlich schließen, wenn jetzt irgendwer kommt und sagt, wir sind aber die größte Fraktion, dann muss man sagen, ja, aber Parteibindung zählt hier nicht mehr. Also es gibt jetzt einfach ein Parlament, das es bestellt, da sind 88 Leute drin. Jetzt, welche Partei und so, das ist den Leuten egal. Warum sollten wir das im Parlament nochmal abbilden? So, so als ersten Aufwurf der Frage, wer stellt jetzt eigentlich den Landtagspräsidenten oder so? Nun gut, in der Verfassung steht, nach 30 Tagen muss konstituiert werden. Konstituieren heißt nicht nur treffen, sondern auch hart regeln, wie man sich selbst verwaltet. Also eine Geschäftsordnung muss her. Es gilt zwar die alte, aber der alte Landtagspräsident, der gilt nicht mehr, sondern der muss neu. Und solange man keinen hat, ist er dieser komische Alterspräsident. Wir haben alle gehört, es gab da Turbulenzen, gehen gleich darauf ein. Ich will nur ein paar Präampeln vorhin mal setzen. Eine Krise ist nicht das, was wir immer denken, was eine Krise ist. Also beim Thema Wirtschaft, wenn man einfach nur arm ist, ist das keine Wirtschaftskrise, sondern dann ist man einfach nur arm in einer sehr gut funktionierenden Wirtschaft. Wirtschaftskrise ist, wenn man reich ist und nichts kaufen kann. Wie zum Beispiel, ich habe zwar 10 Milliarden, aber ich kriege trotzdem keine Instelfabrik. Also hier muss man genau definieren, was ist eigentlich Krise? Krise des Parlamentarismus. Also ich habe weder eine Prügelei gesehen, noch ein Abweichen von irgendwelchen Formalien, sondern wenn zwischendurch Geschrei ist und der eine sagt, das ist aber Verfassungsgericht, was sie hier machen, und das ist aber nur der Landtagsdirektor und der Alterspräsident sagt, das ist mir egal, ich will das hier und so weiter, dann sagt halt die nächste große Fraktion, dann rufen wir das Verfassungsgericht an. Da würde ich sagen, das ist keine Krise, sondern das ist einfach nur gelebter Parlamentarismus. Wenn der Rechtsweg da reinkommt und die Funktion des Rechtswegs ist, einen Loser zu markieren und ihm zu isolieren, dann ist das ja wohl wunderbar gelungen, denn der Herr Alterspräsident von der AfD hat ja dann im zweiten Anlauf einfach gesagt, ja gut, wenn das da drinsteht in dem Verfassungsbeschluss, dann ist das halt so, ich gebe mich jetzt geschlagen. Und die AfD hat sich daher geschlagen.
Würde ich sagen, das System funktioniert.
Das System funktioniert wunderbar, allerdings nicht so, wie wir es halt bisher gewohnt waren. Ich finde zum Beispiel auch, wenn Markus Söder oder Friedrich Merz öffentlich irgendetwas fordern, was klar verfassungswidrig ist, wie zum Beispiel Absenkung von Bürgergeld unter das Existenzminimum oder was auch immer, und dann steht aber niemand daneben und sagt, dann rufe ich jetzt mal das Verfassungsgericht an und sie reden solange nicht weiter, ist das auf jeden Fall ziemlich gut. Also das, was wir in Thüringen gesehen haben, dass man einfach sagt, wir kommen hier nicht weiter, wir rufen die nächste höhere Instanz an, weil es hier oben was geht und nicht nur eine Meinungsbekundung stattfindet, dann werden doch einige so zur Disziplin gerufen und dann ist es eben nicht nur der Artikel 5 Meinungsbeitrag, sondern im Parlamentarismus gibt es noch so ein paar andere Sachen, an die man sich halten muss und da wurden gerade alle drauf verpflichtet und das ist auch gut.
Das wäre auch was für die Talkshows.
Absolut.
Dass man sagt, stopp, wir vertagen die Sitzung. Wir rufen jetzt an, wir machen es dann wie bei Jauch, wie bei Wer wird Millionär? Dann wird jemand vom Verfassungsgericht angerufen, der sagt, na ja, da kann ich Ihnen sagen, Herr Söder, das geht nicht. Denken Sie sich was Neues aus.
Richtig. Also wir brauchen eine neue Krisendefinition. Und wenn Parlamentarismus besonders gut funktioniert, weil er handfest Verfassungswidrigkeit markiert und sagt, solange ist hier Pause. Auch gut. Dritte Präambel, die ich ganz wichtig machen möchte. Wenn dem demokratischen Ablauf plötzlich der ideelle Überbau fehlt, weil irgendwer sagt, das habe ich aber in Sonntagsreden anders gehört. Das sozioökonomische Projekt sagt, aber das muss jetzt so und so gemacht werden. Und dann sagen einfach 88 Leute, ne, wir halten uns jetzt mal in die Verfassung. Das ist das einzige, was zählt. Der Rest Geschichte des politischen Denkens von mir aus. Deswegen trotzdem noch keine besondere Geschichte. Einfach weg. Demokratie Theorie. Schön und gut. Wir machen Demokratie Praxis. Finde ich gut. In deren Sicht, ich habe es sehr gemessen, mir das anzuschauen.
Du bist sehr dagegen, wenn die ganze Zeit die Verherrlichung der Demokratie. Darüber gesprochen wird, dass das die Demokratie in den Dreck zieht.
Richtig.
Und dass die Formen nicht mehr gewahrt werden.
Es zieht die ein oder andere Theorie in den Dreck. Aber da gehört sie auch hin.
Ja.
Ich will die Praxis gelebt und folgenreich.
Du brauchst nicht diese Bemäntelung. Wenn man diese Bemäntelung will, dann kann man das ja auf Schloss Bellevue immer mal wieder bekommen. Ich brauche auch keine Wolfgang Thierse.
Das brauche ich alle nicht. Ich will wissen, welche Regeln gelten. Ich finde es auch sehr gut, wenn Journalisten in einer Situation sind, wo sie sich gerade nichts zutrauen, sondern noch mal in die Verfassung vorereingucken, damit sie keinen Blödsinn erzählen. Das ist auch ein sehr disziplinierendes Ding.
Das finde ich auch immer sehr gut. Dann wird es nämlich präziser. Aber was du da ansprichst, ist ja interessant, dass man doch eigentlich noch möchte, dass diese Konventionen eingehalten werden. Also da sind plötzlich doch noch mal alle für Schlips und Kragen, sage ich mal. Und das war auch so gut zu beobachten. Als Nouripour und Lange zurücktraten, haben sie ein Statement abgegeben. Und dann bekamen sie schon unglaublich viel Lob von Journalisten, aber auch Juristen bei Twitter. So macht man das großartig. Und dann wurde bekannt gegeben, dass Franziska Brandner wohl kandidieren will. Und sofort twitterte dann Ricarda Lang, eine großartige mögliche Nachfolgerin. Und ich gratuliere zu diesem Schritt. Und dann haben darüber wieder ganz viele Journalisten und andere aus der Öffentlichkeit stammende Menschen geschrieben. So geht man miteinander um, der Demokratie. Das ist das, das ist größer. Nein, natürlich ist das einfach Unsinn.
Dafür gehe ich in die Oper. Ich kann es immer wieder sagen.
Die hat jetzt, ich glaube, das waren jetzt sehr unangenehme Tage für Ricarda Lange und für Omid Nouripour auch. Und die machen das natürlich mit Balter Faust und mit zusammengebissenen Zähnen. Und dann kann man sagen, ja, schön, dass sie jetzt nicht Scheiße prüllen in die Kamera. Aber ich muss das jetzt auch nicht so glorifizieren, dass daran sich jetzt zeigt, wie wunderbar unsere Demokratie gelebt wird. Nein, es ist ein Ränkespiel im Hintergrund. Es ist eigentlich ein bisschen wie bei Game of Thrones, nur ohne Tote.
Ja, wir haben jetzt auch wieder eine Vorstandssitzung bei uns im Verein. Ich als zweiter Vorsitzender bin ja zuständig für so interne Sachen. Das heißt auch Ablauf der Veranstaltung. Und ich verstehe, dass da einige da sind, die sich schon immer mal wieder gerne sehen wollten und so weiter und so fort. Aber ich möchte gern, dass da Sachen geregelt werden. Und zwar in der kürzesten Zeit wie möglich. So, Demokratie heißt für mich Frage, Antworten einsammeln, auszählen, fertig. Nächster Punkt. Und ich habe da noch meine Meinung und wie auch immer und so. Lenz Jakobsen, wir haben ihn eben schon im Podcast gehört, hat das ganz toll geschrieben in der Zeit. Ich trage kurz vor, Thüringer Landtag, kein Kampf ohne Lärm. Im Text, es kommt darauf an, dass der Lärm, der bei diesen Auseinandersetzungen entsteht, so wie jetzt in Thüringen nicht als Todeszeichen des Parlamentarismus gedeutet wird, sondern als Zeichen seiner Lebendigkeit. Die Öffentlichkeit hat sich in den Merkel-Jahren gewöhnt an eine Regierungs- und Parlamentsbetrieb, der leise vor sich hin schnurrt, der einen meist in Ruhe lässt. Das war schon immer eine Täuschung. Jetzt aber wird die so eingeschliffene Erwartungshaltung gefährlich. Also nicht das, was in Thüringen passiert, das war gefährlich, sondern dass wir eine Sehgewohnheit hatten, dass wir dachten, die klären das so unter sich. Die Regierung ist eine Familie.
Roger Williamson hat das hohe Haus geschrieben. Er hat sich jede Sitzung im Bundestag ein Jahr lang angehört, über sich ergehen lassen, muss man sagen. Und er war ja verzweifelt darüber, dass ohne Leidenschaft dieser Parlamentarismus sich vollzieht. Dann kommt ein Merkel, die noch mal alle mit nebulösen Floskeln einschläfert und dann ist vorbei.
So, und Lenzi Jacobsen stellt jetzt eine entscheidende Frage. Denn wie wird die Öffentlichkeit umgehen mit Ruhestörungen wie in Thüringen? Und ich sage, und wir nehmen uns das Video, was die Zeit geschnitten hat aus diesen drei, vier Stunden Sitzung. Ich habe mir die Sitzung nicht angehört, sondern ich kenne auch nur diese Ausschneide im Wortlaut. Ich sage jetzt, wie geht die Öffentlichkeit damit um? Mein Angebot ist, wir genießen das jetzt. Wir hören den lebendigen Parlamentarismus und sagen, jawohl, das ist gut.
Los geht's.
Meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren Abgeordneten, ich heiße Sie herzlich willkommen zur ersten Sitzung des Thüringer Landtags der achten Wahlperiode.
Bevor wir in die weitere Tagesordnung eintreten.
Ich stelle mir das so vor, er wollte gerade zu seiner feierlichen Öffnung den Landtag und macht so eine vergiftete Hallo-Rede. Mein erster Alterspräsident, er darf keine politischen Reden halten. Jedenfalls nicht in diesem Posten. Und die so, ja, sorry, hier Geschäftsordnungsanträge. Das ist doch genau richtig. Das ist doch wie, wenn Lanz eine Pressekonferenz macht und Söder da abfeiert und irgendwie. Und auch beim Bürgergeld müssen wir noch mal rein und so. Da will ich doch auch daneben stehen und sagen, sorry, Frage zur Geschäftsordnung, ist das mit der Verfassung vereinbar oder nicht?
So geht's. Würde ich Sie bitten, Herr Alterspräsident, nach Paragraph 40 Absatz 2, da ja wir kurz auch vor Abstimmung stehen, spätestens zur Tagesordnung festzustellen, dass wir beschlussfähig sind.
Ich nehme Ihre Meldung zur Kenntnis und werde Ihnen zur gegebenen Zeit das Wort urteilen, nämlich entsprechend der Regelung in Paragraph 31 Absatz 2 der Geschäftsordnung, noch meine Rede. Lassen Sie mich nun bitte weiter ausführen.
Herr Alterspräsident, mit toller Gebühr, aber der Paragraph 31 Absatz 2 sieht nur vor, dass nach Reden, dass die Aussprache Erfolg zur Geschäftsordnung, wir befinden uns ja gerade in der Aufstellung der Tagesordnung.
Ja, ich habe es höflich gesagt, ich unterbreche die Sitzung. Gestatten Sie mir nun folgende Hinweise zur Tagesordnung. Über den Verlauf dieser konstituierenden Sitzung des 8. Thüringer Landtages.
Jetzt kommt der Direktor Verwaltung.
Der Direktor der Landesverwaltung ist auch neu. Also ich habe das auch nicht gewusst, dass man da so reinspringen kann.
Also der unterbricht ihn jetzt.
Ja, der weist ihn so auch formal ja hinten.
Ich stelle mich nach Ihrer Rede.
Das ist?
Ernennung der Schriftführer und Herstellung.
Führer zu meiner Rede.
Nein, Sie hatten Ihre Rede nicht.
Herr Alterspräsident, ich hatte mich gemeldet und wir hatten eine gemeinsame Verabredung mit allen parlamentarischen Geschäftsführern, dass Sie so dann jetzt die Beschlussfähigkeit feststellen, indem Sie die Namen der Abgeordneten verlesen.
Ich unterbreche die Sitzung.
Das ist doch grandios. Damit fesselt man doch die Leute vor den Fernseher. Da würde man doch erst beantragen, bitte Tagesordnungspunkt so und so 20.15 Uhr.
Ja.
Kostet RTL kein Geld, nicht 100 Millionen. Und dann Action.
Meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren, ich setze meine Rede fort über den Verlauf dieser konsolidierten Sitzung des 8.
Herr Alterspräsident, erkennbar wollen Sie meinen Geschäftsordnungsantrag hier nicht aufrufen, den ich gestellt habe. Das ist im Demokratieverständnis, was Sie selbst vorgetragen haben, völlig irrig. Sie haben in der Rolle als Alterspräsident überparteilich zu handeln. Ihr Verhalten und Ihre Sitzungsleistung lassen jetzt schon erhebliche Zweifel an einer unparteiischen und neutralen Amtsführung zu. Verlange ich hier weiterhin nach dem Antrag, den ich gestellt habe, nach § 40 Absatz 2, die Beschlussfähigkeit des Hauses festzustellen. Sie verletzen damit die Rechte der Abgeordneten hier, der Mehrheit des Hauses. Und ich verlange jetzt zwingend von Ihnen, dass Sie diesen Antrag zur Abstimmung stellen, um hier nicht weiter die Rechte der Abgeordneten zu verletzen.
Ich hoffe, wir brauchen am Ende keinen Ortebeden, der ihre Hände röntgen muss. Ich unterbreche die Sitzung für 30 Minuten. Herr Bühl hat beantragt, dass die Beschlussfähigkeit des Thüringer Landtages festgestellt wird. Auch die Geschäftsordnung des Thüringer Landtages sieht in § 1 die Feststellung der Beschlussfähigkeit erst nach Ernennung der vorläufigen Schriftführer und dem namentlichen Aufruf der Abgeordneten vor. Davon kann nicht abgewichen werden. Als Anderspräsident bin ich verpflichtet, die geltenden Rechtsnomen strikt zu achten. Dazu aber muss der neue Landtag zunächst konstituiert sein. September datierende Einladung zur heutigen ersten Plenarsitzung für den Tagessortnungsprozesse.
Herr Treutler, ich habe einen Geschäftsordnungsantrag gestellt. Herr Treutler, Sie haben eben gesagt, Sie wollen nach der Geschäftsordnung die GILT verfahren. Dann haben Sie bitte die Geschäftsordnung auch zu.
Ich entziehe Ihnen das Wort.
Herr Treutler, hier steht in der Geschäftsordnung in Absatz 1, Absatz 1 Absatz 4, dass die Beschlussfähigkeit vor dem Präsidentenwahl zu erklären ist. Und das wollen wir jetzt tun.
Also hier ist es wirklich wahnsinnig interessant. Er entschied nämlich das Wort. Nur das darf er ja gar nicht. Und dann sagt er, bitte stellen Sie das Mikrofon ab. Und er dreht sich sogar um und sagt irgendwie der Landtagsverwaltung, hier machen Sie mal das Mikrofon aus. Nur er hat ja nicht mehr Rederecht als jeder andere. Es wäre genauso gut, wenn die jetzt eine Fraktion sagen, stellen Sie mal das Mikrofon ab.
Und die Verwaltung hört natürlich den Teufel schon jetzt die Mikrofone ab.
Genau, die Landesverwaltung so, nee, machen wir nicht. Sie sind ja nur der Alterspräsident. Und man sieht auch schon, das war ja der Streit insgesamt. Er möchte gerne, dass die Tagesordnung, wie sie ist, eingehalten wird. Alte Geschäftsordnung, pipa po, nämlich erst Konstitution des Landtags und dann alles andere. Also zuerst die Wahl eines Landtagspräsidenten und dann alles andere. Und dann sagen die anderen, wir können hier Änderungen auf Tagesordnung und was weiß ich alles stellen. Wir wollen halt noch mal eine Änderung haben. So, legitimerweise, wie wir jetzt auch bestätigt haben. Meine Vermutung ist, die AfD hat es hier wirklich drauf angelegt, einfach ihre Kandidatin alternativlos in diesen Wahlgängen zumindest zweimal scheitern zu lassen, aber dass sie alleine dasteht und man dann sagen kann, die wurden schon wieder nicht gewählt, nicht mal ein Landtagspräsident so. Alle Erklärungen, die ich jetzt gehört habe zum Nein, das war so provoziert, der Höcke wusste genau, dass das nicht geht und so weiter, glaube ich nicht, fand ich nicht plausibel. Ich fand nur plausibel, dass sie sich gesagt haben, nee, wenn wir nur streng genug mit so einem alten Mann, der da oben sitzt und einfach sagt, dann lassen die anderen das schon zu. Die werden ja nicht den Landtag gezielt und so im Chaos stürzen, oder? Und die CDU so, doch, machen wir. Also es wurde einfach richtig ausgefochten, offenes Visier von allen, was ist hier Sachlage? Und es spitze sich dann eben zu, dass die AfD, wie ich jetzt so rückblickend sage, dann schon so eine Falle gelaufen ist, nämlich dass dieses Ereignis einfach in den Geschichtsbüchern steht und zwar umso deutlicher und umso häufiger, gott es auch wiederholt, je mehr Rechte sich der Alterspräsident hier nimmt, die er nicht hat. Wir haben jetzt schon gehört, er möchte nicht, dass über die Tagesordnung abgestimmt wird, er möchte die Schlussfähigkeit nicht feststellen, er möchte gerne Rede halten, er wollte jetzt schon ein Mikrofon entzogen haben.
Sie schaden hier der Demokratie, indem sie den Mehrheitswillen dieses Hauses ignorieren, wenn wir nicht die Geschäftsordnung jetzt auch anwenden.
Herr Bühl, ich ermahne Sie zur Ruhe.
Herr Magen geht auch nicht.
Herr Treutler, ich widerspreche vehement gegen Ihre Ausführung. Ich widerspreche. Es gibt einen Geschäftsordnungsantrag, ich widerspreche, Sie haben diesen jetzt abzuschütteln.
Einen Ordnungsruf?
Herr Treutler, Sie haben jetzt abzustimmen.
Ein Verfassungsbuch nach dem anderen von der AfD.
Ich widerspreche auch diesem Geschäftsruf.
Da brauchen Sie meine Rede nicht. Ich verteile Ihnen einen zweiten Ordnungsruf.
Was Sie hier treiben, ist Machtergreifung.
Ja, es ist halt nun mal Machtergreifung. Der Typ hat sich ein Recht nach dem anderen genommen, das es gar nicht gibt für ihn. Er hat es aber nicht gemerkt irgendwie.
Er sitzt jetzt da, er thront ein bisschen über denen, also gehört ihm schon alles.
Dann die CDU allerdings, die haben die Chancen ein bisschen genutzt.
Wir fordern den zweitältesten Abgeordneten auf, die Sitzung vorzuführen.
So fordern kann man ja alles, solange man eine Mehrheit im Parlament hat. Also Anträge stellen kann man jetzt ohne Ende. Man wird einfach der zweitälteste, wo ich auch noch nie gehört.
Es wird jetzt folgendes geschehen. Jede Fraktion bringt ihre Rechtsauffassung hier ein.
Wir müssen hier hinzufügen, es sind schon 90 Minuten vergangen. Die sind immer noch da an diesem Fall.
Das ist ewig lang. Vier Stunden ging das insgesamt oder so. Die Rede durfte dann irgendwann zu Ende gehalten. Man hat ihm so Zuständnisse gemacht, weil man genau weiß, das landet nicht in den Geschichtsbüchern. Dieser Kampf CDU gegen AfD wird dann so ein bisschen, die anderen Fraktionen sagen sich, wir kämpfen ja auch mit. Also es kam sozusagen, die Verfassungsbrüche waren so eindeutig, dass sich alle ihren kleinen Platz im Geschichtsbuch erarbeitet haben, um auch noch mal mit Redebeiträgen da präsent zu sein. Also hier haben wir jetzt die SPD.
Ich will auch für die Fraktionen der SPD und für jeden einzelnen oder jede Einzelabgeordnete feststellen, dass wir diese letzten drei Stunden Sitzungsleitung tatsächlich eher als Fass betrachten, weil wir wie noch nie in diesem Hohen Haus zu keiner Debatte, es wurde keine Debatte zugelassen, dass Ordnungsrufe erteilt wurden, dass Geschäftsordnungsanträge nicht befasst werden dürfen, dass auch nicht mal eine Debatte zur Tagesordnung oder zur Geschäftsordnung zugelassen werden, finde ich wirklich sowas von demokratieverächtlich.
So, jetzt hat sie das noch vom Tisch vorgetragen. Der CDU-Type auch, die ganze Zeit so laut rufen da von seinem Tisch. Und sehr bemerkenswert, finde ich, ist jetzt natürlich nur ein ganz kleines Detail. Und man kann auch sagen, Stefan übertreibst nicht oder so. Aber dass die CDU sich dann in der Pause mit der AfD einigt, wir machen es jetzt vor dem Verfassungsgericht und dass nicht die AfD selber das verkündet, in dieser Rednerposition, Alterspräsident, was auch immer das bedeutet, hin oder her. Aber sichtbar halt, nein, wir haben bisher den Alterspräsidenten nur in aufgeregter, hilfloser Situation am Tisch gesehen, völlig überfordert. Jetzt sehen wir die CDU aber am Rednerpult plötzlich.
Der Alterspräsident hat uns eben noch mal in der Aussprache der parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer mitgeteilt, dass er der Rechtsauffassung der AfD folgt. Er hat uns auch mitgeteilt, dass er den von mir gestellten Geschäftsordnungsantrag zur Feststellung der Beschlussfähigkeit nach § 40 Absatz 2 nicht feststellen wird. Aus diesem Gesichtspunkt und aus der Diskussion, die wir hier gemeinsam verfolgt haben, auch dem Austausch der Rechtsauffassung, ist für mich klar, dass wir heute hier einen nächsten Schritt gehen müssen, weil wir in dieser Konstellation nicht zu einem Ergebnis kommen werden. Und unter all diesen Voraussetzungen, und man macht sich sowas ja auch nicht einfach, werden wir, und so haben wir uns eben verständigt, zum letzten Mittel greifen und den Thüringer Verfassungsgerichtshof anrufen, um damit eine Klärung des Sachverhalts zu verziehen.
Also während wir, und wir kennen ja die Sehgewohnheit, Bärbel Bahr, Wolfgang Kubicki sitzen so an diesem Ding und leiten so eine Sitzung und so. Jetzt haben wir diesen aufgeregten Alterspräsidenten gesehen, der der Situation nicht gewachsen ist. Wir kriegen aber als Finale so einen seriös daherkommenden CDUler, der am Pult nochmal erklärt, wie wir das kennen. Ganz ruhig und gelassen, wir gehen jetzt vor das Verfassungsgericht.
Ich glaube der Alterspräsident hat ein bisschen mit dem Blutdruck bekommen, oder? Ja, der war schon ziemlich...
Also wenn es ist mal wieder so, wenn das eine Strategie der CDU, der AfD war, dann ist sie wirklich dumm gewesen und nicht aufgegangen. Und es ist zum zweiten Mal, ich fand ja schon, wir haben es ja auch hier geguckt, dieses Gespräch, Vogt gegen Höcker, da hat er ihn ja auch sinnloserweise sich aus der Reserve locken lassen, Höcker, so dass er da einfach wirklich abgestempelt wurde.
Blamiert.
Ja, und diesmal wieder. Die CDU kommt doch relativ seriös aus dieser Nummer raus, während die AfD nicht nur performativ, sondern eben dann auch noch inhaltlich blamiert dasteht, denn das Verfassungsgerichtsurteil war ja dann da. Und umso bestürzender finde ich allerdings einen Hinweis von Rudolf Stichwe auf Twitter, der diesen NZZ-Artikel von Katina Keilani geteilt hat, der wie vorhin schon angesprochen in Gänze in die Stellungnahme der AfD aufgenommen wurde vom Verfassungsgericht als das ist ja die NZZ, das ist ja nun seriös und so weiter. Und der Text ist aber so krass, was sie da geschrieben hat. Zum einen, es war ein verstörendes Schauspiel, die anderen Fraktionen inszenierten sich als Hüterin der Demokratie. Dabei muss man doch einsehen, die AfD hat die Wahl gewonnen. Der Alterspräsident ist streng nach Lehrbuch durch die Sitzung gegangen, trotz Störmanöver der CDU. Das Schauspiel im Erfurter Landtag war unwürdig und die begleitende Berichterstattung war teilweise so intoniert, als ob es Treutler gewesen sei, also der Alterspräsident, der gegen die demokratische Ordnung verstoßen habe. Dabei liegt es eigentlich auf der Hand, die AfD hat die Wahl gewonnen. Die CDU könnte mit ihr eine bequeme Mehrheit haben, wenn sie sich nicht erstens in ihre Brandmauer eingemauert und so weiter und so fort. Mit dem Finale, das sie dann schreibt, abzuwarten bleibt, ob das mit einem CDU-Mann an der Spitze, das Verfassungsgericht, besetzte Thüringische Verfassungsgericht, dies auch so sieht. Oder halt, oder denkst, du kannst nicht publizistisch, während hier gerade ausgefochten wird, was steht in der Verfassung, woran müssen wir uns halten und so weiter. Alle werden festgenagelt. Sie werden richtige Gewinner und Loser gekürt in so einer Sache. Ich kann sich publizistisch daneben stehen und sagen, ich habe ja auch mal eine Meinung. Er wird zwar morgen auch vom Verfassungsgericht, aber ich stehe ja nicht vom Verfassungsgericht. Ich habe ja nur eine Meinung geschrieben. So und sie hatte dann diesen Tweet, bei dem ich echt denke, alter, das ist so grenzwertig, also über die Grenze. Sie schreibt, mit Tochter am Tisch, Thema Erfurt, sie kennt meine Meinung und sagt, ich supporte die andere Seite. Ich? Darfst du ja. Das ist ja das Schöne an der Demokratie. Sie, aber du sollst es nicht dürfen. Perfekte Zusammenfassung der Lage. Also sie bringt ja auch ihre Tochter ins Spiel als Beispiel für diese Verfassungsfeinde, die uns vom Verfassungsgericht gegen unser wir haben doch die Wahl gewonnen Recht und so. Also das geht doch nicht. Das ist doch wirklich jenseits von allem.
Ja, wir werden derlei noch viel erleben.
Ein Hinweis noch, Benjamin Hoff, das ist der Staatskanzlei-Leiter von Ramelow gewesen, hat auch noch mal auf die Wibke-Muh-Saal hingewiesen, die da von der AfD durchgedrückt werden soll, als zumindest Kandidatin für zwei Wahlgänge für die Landtagspräsidentschaft. Die wurde mal zu Betrug, wegen Betruges verurteilt und der Betrug richtete sich gegen den Landtag.
Ah ja, super.
AfD-Wähler interessieren sich für gar nichts. Nein, das ist wirklich ein Inhalte. Es ist einfach außen vor. Na ja, und Alis Weidel hat natürlich noch mal so eine gespielte Entrüstung und geplant da eh klar, weil nämlich Vogt sich schon am Tag vorher eine Prozessvollmacht ausgestellt hat. An seinen Anwalt, der ihn dann verfassungsrechtlich vertritt, wo ich mir denke, ja, der breitet sich halt vor. Er weiß halt, was kommt. So, ihr wollt einen Verfassungsbruch. Er weiß es, breitet sich vor, fertig ist. Also wirklich, das ist absurd und ich verstehe nicht genau.
Genau so sollten wir das jetzt auch betrachten als absurdes Theater, das aber erstmal das Funktionieren der Institutionen zeigt und zeigt auch, wie offenbar die anderen Parteien bereit sind, sich richtig anzulegen. Und da kann man doch nur gespannt sein.
Absolut. Zum Ende will ich dir noch einen Clip vorspielen. Du hast es von Dios noch nicht angesprochen. Ich hätte gedacht, es ist ein Thema. Aber man hat ein Lied gefunden von Udo Jürgens. Ja. Unentdeckterweise bislang.
Manchmal mit etwas Glück ist es möglich, Stimmen aus dem Jenseits zu hören. Ein unentdecktes Lied von Udo Jürgens, hier zum ersten Mal, als ich fortging.
Das ist natürlich das, was man sich wahrscheinlich wünscht.
Dass man irgendwann noch mal so ein Schätzchen in der Kiste findet.
Was soll ich jetzt dazu sagen?
Na dich freuen.
Ach so, ja, ich habe mich gefreut, dass es noch ein Lied gibt.
Es ist nicht alles nur KI.
Na, ich hätte tatsächlich gedacht, dass es mehr gibt, weil Udo Jürgens so viele Alben aufgenommen hat und ich mir gut vorstellen konnte, dass man viel produziert hat, was dann am Ende nicht aufs Album gekommen ist. Möglicherweise findet man jetzt auch in den nächsten Jahren noch was kann sein.
Textfragmente, die dann turniert werden müssen.
Ja, da bin ich nicht sehr dafür, aber ich hätte schon gedacht, dass es mehr Demo-Aufnahmen gibt. Offenbar ist das nicht der Fall, also man hat das, was man aufgenommen hat, auch alles verwertet. Jetzt gibt es dieses eine Lied. Das ist ganz schön. Es gibt deutlich interessantere Lieder von Udo Jürgens. Ich liebe ja sehr. Ich kann doch einfach noch fünf Udo Jürgens Hits empfehlen. Zum rausgehen. Du sagst jetzt eins und du darfst aber nicht jetzt, du darfst jetzt nicht wieder sagen, dass die andere das besser gesungen hat.
Also die Version von Helene Fischer von Messie Cherie ist wirklich atemberaubend. Muss man sagen. Und sie hat es in seiner Gegenwart gesungen. Und er war auch begeistert.
Ich finde sehr schön. Mein Bruder ist dein Maler. Dann sollte man sich anhören, im Kühlschrank brennt noch Licht. Das ist eher ein unbekannteres Lied. Ein Narr sagt Dankeschön. Dann zehn nach elf. Und nochmal, weil wir den Rechtsruck und diese Piefigkeit und all das haben, natürlich nochmal ein ehrenwertes Haus.
Und griechischer Wein?
Griechischer Wein natürlich auch, denn das ist ja das Lied, das die Gastarbeiter als großes Thema hatte. Ich war noch niemals in New York. Ja, es gibt viele, viele Lieder. Ich wollte jetzt ein paar empfehlen, die vielleicht nicht allen so präsent sind. Wir empfehlen etwas Musikalisches, oder ich empfehle etwas Musikalisches auch im Salon. Ich berate aber noch nicht was.
Die Leute waren begeistert.
Ja, ich habe ja sogar zwei Hörer getroffen, zufällig in der Alten Oper, als ich da beim Konzert von Isabel Faust war, die tatsächlich drei Stunden und 20 Minuten gespielt hat, die Violinsonaten von Bach. Wahnsinn. Ich werde also wieder etwas empfehlen. Wir sprechen gemeinsam über das Buch Gutes Geld, Wege zu einer gerechten und nachhaltigen Gesellschaft von der Ökonomin Philippa Siegel Klöckner. Außerdem hattest du angekündigt, und ich habe es schon hier liegen, dass du tatsächlich über den Gegenstandpunkt sprechen willst. Ich glaube, da geht es auch viel um Delegitimierung des Staates.
Ich habe gehört, der Verfassungsschutz schaut hier zu, was wir so treiben, und wir wollen es nochmal klar positionieren.
Wer weiß. Also ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich habe mir auch die Ausgabe gekauft. Was du sagst, man muss das für die Leute, die meisten kennen das ja nicht. Das ist ein sehr special Interesse. Stefan ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen getriggert von Gegenstandpunkt-Lesern, die er kennengelernt hat. Und deshalb sagt er sich, ich muss mich dem mal widmen. Es ist also eine Nischenzeitung, eine Marxistische, Staatskritische Nischenzeitung, bei der Stefan jetzt denkt, da muss er sich mit auseinandersetzen, weil er in seinem Umfeld Leute getroffen hat, die Gegenstandpunkt lesen.
Wir hatten junge Leute aus Bielefeld bei uns im Büro. Die meinten, die lesen das alle. Ich habe mir gedacht, seid ihr alle total bescheuert?
Wir werden jetzt mal schauen. Ich habe es mir auch extra gekauft, damit du keine Unsinnere bist.
Also ich gehe punktuell rein und habe den Mittwoch dafür Zeit.
Gut.
Also mal sehen.
Hast du sonst noch was schon, was du angelegen willst?
Ich war doch sehr erschrocken, wie schlecht ich dieses neue Buch von Harari finde.
Ah ja.
Nexus.
Ich hatte nur ein Interview dazugehört, aber da können wir ganz gut drüber sprechen dann.
Das ist wirklich traurig.
Naja.
Prima. Ich bringe noch was Literarisches mit und wer also diesen Podcast unterstützen will, kann das in verschiedener Weise tun. Einmal dadurch, dass man diesen Podcast weiter empfiehlt oder auch oder und auch in den sozialen Medien teilt. Darüber würden wir uns sehr freuen. Wir freuen uns auch über eine gute Bewertung. Außerdem, wer möchte, kann auch Clips schneiden und die woanders veröffentlichen und dann aber auf unser Podcast verlinken. Auch das hilft natürlich sehr weiter.
Ja, und zwar in allen politischen Lagern.
Ja.
Uns interessieren auch, was die Dummen dazu sagen.
Und dann gibt es natürlich die Möglichkeit, uns finanziell zu unterstützen, indem ihr den Salon abonniert. Das ist am einfachsten möglich mit einem Steady-Abo. Das bekommt man am einfachsten, wenn man auf die Homepage geht, www.neuezwanziger.de. Da ist ein goldener Button. Dann kommt man auf die Steady-Seite und kann ab drei Euro im Monat den neuen Salon und auch alle alten Salons, die im Januar 2020 begannen, ja dieses Projekt, alle hochgeladen sind. Die kann man dort hören. Wer es bequemer als iPhone-Kunde mag und bereit ist, ich glaube, 50 Cent mehr auszugeben, der kann das tun über Apple, kann dort einfach den Salon abonnieren. Das ist ganz einfach. Und wer schon bei Patreon angemeldet ist und gerne auf der Plattform bleiben will, kann das auch dort tun. Wir empfehlen allerdings Steady. Und damit ist dann der Zugang offen für ganz viel Podcast, für viele Stunden. Wir sprechen immer so drei Stunden über Texte, die wir gelesen haben und auch immer im Mittelpunkt steht, dann ausführlich ein Buch, das wir beide lesen, das wir diskutieren. Das war im letzten Monat Crazy Rich. Und da passt es eigentlich ganz gut, dass der neue Titel Gutes Geld heißt.
Und falls hier Leute zuhören, die zu viel gutes Geld haben, weil sie super reich sind und gehört haben, diese Typen hier, die haben was gegen Superreiche. Irgendwann hat man ja so ein Superreichtum, an dem man sich nicht mal nach unten orientiert, sondern nach oben. Also dieser Capri-Sonnen-Typ, der dann sagt, ja, aber ich reg mich auch nicht darüber auf, dass der Elon Musk oder der Jeff Bezos so viel Geld hat. Wenn man so eine Bewunderung nach oben hat, von Superreichtum nach oben und man sagt sich so, krass, ich mache immer nur Restaurants, aber ich würde gerne auch so ein Pädatil sein oder so. Wir haben alle Bücher besprochen zu Pädatil, zur Philosophie von Pädatil und dem weiteren Denken in diesem Dunstkreis. Das kann man dann bei uns nachhören. Gibt es für eigentlich gar kein Geld für euch.
Ach so, ich dachte, jetzt kommt der Aufruf an die Milliardäre, um das Geld zu spenden.
Nein, ich will kein Geld von wehren. Okay.
Aber vielleicht kann man die Milliardäre dazu bringen, dass sie sich ein paar Podcastfolgen anhören. Vielleicht die Besprechung von Crazy Rich und noch mal heute Zuckerberg. Long-Termism und Pädatil-Biografie. Dazu müsste man sie eigentlich bringen. Das wäre ganz gut. Na ja, wir vertrauen erstmal auf die Nicht-Milliardäre und freuen uns, wenn wir uns dann im Salon wiedersehen. Einen schönen Monat.
Bis dann.